WE WILL CALL THE COMMITTEE TO
ORDER AND WITH THE ABSENCE OF A
QUORUM WILL START AS A SUB
COMMITTEE -- PLEASE NOTE THE
FOLLOWING TODAY WE HAVE FIFTEEN
MEASURES ON THE AGENDA. TWO OR
IN CONSENT.
SB THREE NINETY FILE ITEM FIVE
BY SENATOR TOM UMBERG.
AND SB FOUR SIX TWO FILE ITEM
SEVEN BY SENATOR AND RESTORING.
THE AUTHOR IS PULLED SB.
SEVEN SEVEN SEVEN FILE ITEM.
FIFTEEN LASTLY PLEASE NOTE.
THERE ARE GENERAL GUIDELINES FOR
BILLS HEARD IN THIS COMMITTEE IS
TO ALLOW TESTIMONY FROM TWO
WITNESSES. FOR SUPPORT AND TWO
WITNESSES FOR OPPOSITION TO
SPEAK FOR TWO MINUTES EACH.
STAKEHOLDER GROUPS IN ENTITIES
THAT ARE NEITHER IN SUPPORT OR
ON NOR IN OPPOSITION WILL BE
ALLOWED. TO GIVE TESTIMONY FOR
NO MORE THAN TWO MINUTES WHEN I
CALL FOR TWEETERS.
IF I HAVE A MEASURE THAT HAS
MORE THAN TWO ENTITIES IN THE
TWEENER CATEGORY ONLY TWO WILL
BE ALLOWED TO SPEAK. FOR TWO
MINUTES EACH.
SO WE ARE GOING TO BEGIN WITH
FILE ITEM.
NINE SB FOUR NINETY THREE
SENATOR JACKSON WELCOME.
GOOD AFTERNOON -- MISTER CHAIR
AND MEMBERS.
OF I AM PLEASED TO BRING TO YOU
TODAY A BILL THAT WILL ENSURE
CONTINUED.
EQUAL OPPORTUNITY.
IN OUR EDUCATIONAL SYSTEM FOR OF
WOMEN AS WELL AS MEN.
TITLE NINE WHICH IS THE FEDERAL
SEX EQUITY IN EDUCATION LAW.
HAS BEEN VITAL TO ENSURING THAT
ALL STUDENTS WOMEN AND MEN GIRLS
AND BOYS AT EVERY GRADE LEVEL
HAVE EQUAL OPPORTUNITY FOR
SUCCESS IN ACADEMICS.
AND AT ATHLETICS INCOME PURSUE
AN EDUCATION.
IN AN ENVIRONMENT SAFE FROM
SEXUAL HARASSMENT AND VIOLENCE.
SADLY AND FRANKLY SOMEWHAT
SHOCKINGLY SEXUAL ASSAULT AND
VIOLENCE.
IS IN HIGHER EDUCATION IS
PERVASIVE.
ACCORDING TO THE TWENTY SIXTEEN
CAMPUS CLIMATE SURVEY VALIDATION
STUDY OF TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND
COLLEGE AND UNIVERSITY STUDENTS.
AN ESTIMATED 62% OF WOMEN AND
61% OF MEN.
EXPERIENCE SEXUAL HARASSMENT.
ONE IN FIVE WOMEN AND ONE IN
FOURTEEN MEN WILL EXPERIENCE OR
HAVE EXPERIENCED SEXUAL ASSAULT.
ARE IN KICK IN COLLEGE.
HOWEVER DUE TO THE UNDER
REPORTING OF SEXUAL HARASSMENT
AND VIOLENCE THE RATES ARE
LIKELY MUCH HIGHER.
THIS IS NOTHING SHORT OF AN
ACADEMIC AN EPIDEMIC.
IN OUR ACADEMIC INSTITUTIONS
THAT REALLY CALL FOR CULTURE
CHANGE.
TITLE NINE HAS BEEN A CRITICAL
COMPONENT IN ADDRESSING.
EQUITY INEQUITIES IN OUR
COLLEGES IN EDUCATIONAL SYSTEM.
I CALIFORNIA HAS LOOKED TO AND
RELIED UPON TITLE NINE FOR
DECADES.
BUT WE'RE INCREASINGLY CONCERNED
BY THE DISMANTLING OF TITLE
NINE'S PROTECTIONS BY A FEDERAL
ADMINISTRATION THAT HAS
EXPRESSED OPEN HOSTILITY TO THE
SAFEGUARD TO PROVIDES.
AN TO ADDRESSING GENDER BASED
VIOLENCE IT HAS IN FACT ALREADY
PROPOSED FEDERAL REGULATIONS
THAT ABSOLUTELY GOT TITLE NINE'S
CRITIC CRITICAL PROTECTIONS.
THIS MEASURE THEM.
CODIFIES ADDITIONAL PROCEDURAL
REQUIREMENTS FOR SCHOOLS TO
FOLLOW TO ENSURE THAT EXISTING
FEDERAL AND STATE LAW IS
EFFECTUATE INCLUDING ADDING
SEXUAL VIOLENCE TO THE
DEFINITION OF SEXUAL HARASSMENT.
IN THE EDUCATION CODE DIRECTING
ALL POST SECONDARY EDUCATIONAL
INSTITUTIONS TO IMPLEMENT
FUNDAMENTAL PROCESS SEASON
REQUIREMENTS REGARDING SEXUAL.
ASSAULT AND HARASSMENT AND
SEXUAL VIOLENCE PREVENTION
INCLUDING ADOPTING IN PUBLISHING
GRIEVANCE PROCEDURES AND
PROVIDING FOR PROMPTAND
EQUITABLE RESOLUTION OF
COMPLAINTS.
AND FINALLY REQUIRING AN
EDUCATIONAL INSTITUTION TO TAKE
IMMEDIATE ACTION WHEN IT FINDS
ITS SEXUAL HARASSMENT HAS
CREATED A HOSTILE ENVIRONMENT TO
ELIMINATE THAT HOSTILE
ENVIRONMENT. TO PREVENT ITS
REOCCURRENCE AND ADDRESS ITS
EFFECTS SO THAT ALL OUR STUDENTS
ARE ASSURED OF A HEALTHY CLIMATE
WITHIN WHICH TO LEARN AND THRIVE
AND GET THE EDUCATION THAT WE
ALL EXPECT AND WANT.
THEM TO GET AND THAT THEY
DESERVE SO I AM JOINED BY
JESSICA STANDER OF THE EQUAL
RIGHTS ADVOCATES THE SPONSOR THE
BILL.
AS WELL AS A MILIEU WAGONER A
STUDENT SURVIVOR [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS
JESSICA STENDER AND I'M AN
ATTORNEY EQUAL RIGHTS ADVOCATES
PROUD BECAUSE SPONSOR OF US
BEFORE. NINE THREE FOR OVER
FORTY FIVE YEARS WE PRACTICE
UNDER TITLE NINE AND RELATED
FEDERAL AND STATE CIVIL RIGHTS
ANTI DISCRIMINATION LAWS.
EDUCATION CIVIL RIGHTS WERE
ESTABLISHED TWO EGGS AND EXISTS
TO ENSURE EQUITABLE ACCESS
EDUCATION.
SEXUAL HARASSMENT INCLUDING
SEXUAL VIOLENCE IMPEDE THE
STUDENTS ACCESS TO APPLE IS
EDUCATION.
BEYOND JUST CREATING PHYSICAL
AND PSYCHOLOGICAL HARM.
AMPLE EVIDENCE SHOWS THE
MAJORITY OF VICTIMS AND
SURVIVORS ARE WOMEN AS WELL AS
L. G. B. T. -- MINORITY AND
OTHER UNDER HISTORICALLY
UNDERREPRESENTED GROUPS.
AS CENTER JACKSON NOTED EXISTING
STATE AND FEDERAL LAW PROHIBITS
DISCRIMINATION BASED ON SEX AS
WELL AS OTHER CHARACTERISTICS IN
OUR EDUCATIONAL SYSTEMS AND
REQUIRES SCHOOLS TO TAKE PROMPT
AND EQUITABLE -- RESPONSES WHEN
THEY'RE AWARE OF SUCH RESIDENT
THAT COULD IMPEDE STUDENTS
ACQUITTAL ACCESS TO EDUCATION
HOWEVER THERE'S INSUFFICIENT
LARA GUIDANCE ON THE PROCESS
SEES THAT SCHOOL SHOULD UNDERGO
AND SHOULD TAKE WHEN THEY'RE
RESPONDING TO THESE TYPES OF
INCIDENTS.
OF SEXUAL HARASSMENT AND
VIOLENCE SO THIS BILL WILL
ENSURE THAT OUR STATE COLLEGES
AND UNIVERSITIES TAKE ADEQUATE
STEPS TO RESPOND APPROPRIATELY
TO THESE INCIDENTS.
IT DELINEATES TRANSPARENT
EQUITABLE PROCESS SEES THAT
SCHOOLS MUST TAKE THAT COMPLY
WITH EXISTING CALIFORNIA LAW AS
WELL AS GOVERNOR BROWN'S TASK
FORCE CITY CONVENE THEIR
RECOMMENDATIONS AS TO HOW SCHOOL
SHOULD RESPOND TO THESE
INCIDENTS.
SPECIFICALLY REQUIRES TRAINING
FOR SCHOOL OFFICIALS INVOLVED IN
THESE INVESTIGATIONS AND
IMPARTIAL HEARING WHERE BOTH
PARTIES ARE GIVEN EQUAL
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT EVIDENCE
AND WITNESSES BEFORE NEUTRAL AND
OBJECTIVE DECISION MAKER.
AND THAT PERSON IS SEPARATE FROM
THE INVESTIGATORY -- DUTIES ARE
SEPARATE FROM THE DID YOU TO
COURT ADJUDICATORY DUTIES
FINALLY A PROVIDE STUDENT
PARTIES WITH THE RIGHT TO TO THE
TO CONDUCT A LIVE -- CROSS
EXAMINATION PURSUANT TO
SAFEGUARD THAT WE'VE SEEN OUR
NECESSARY IS ADVOCATES IN THIS
REALM AND FINALLY AS I NOTED
THESE PROVISIONS ARE A LOT ARE
IN LINE WITH GOVERNOR BROWN'S
TASK FORCE RECOMMENDATIONS.
BECAUSE AS BEFORE NINE THREE
OUTLINES THE PROCESS SEES AT
INSTITUTIONS OF HIGHER EDUCATION
SHOULD TAKE TO RESPOND TO THESE
TYPES OF INCIDENTS WE BELIEVE
THIS IS ESSENTIAL TO ENSURE THAT
STUDENTS CIVIL RIGHTS ARE
RESPECTED AND AND UP HELD IN
THIS REALM.
AND I WOULD LIKE TO NOW TURN IT
OVER TO OUR US STUDENT WITNESS
EMILY WAGNER TO PRESENT HER
STORY.
I'M GOOD AFTERNOON.
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SB.
FOUR NINETY THREE MY NAME'S
EMILY WAGNER I'LL SOON BE A
COLLEGE SENIOR IN CALIFORNIA I'M
HISTORY EDUCATION MAJOR
GEOGRAPHY MINOR AND MEMBER OF
THE WOMEN'S ROWING TEAM AT MY
SCHOOL.
DURING MY SOPHOMORE YEAR I WAS
VERY BY A MEMBER OF THE
UNIVERSITY'S FOOTBALL TEAM.
I HAD THOUGHT I HAD A HARD TIME
FIGURING OUT WHAT TO DO AND I
DIDN'T KNOW WHERE TO TURN.
MY SCHOOL IS A SMALL CAMPUS AND
SINCE WE WERE BOTH ATHLETES.
I OFTEN OTHER CROSSED PATHS WITH
HIM AND HIS ROOMMATE WHO WAS
THERE WHEN IT HAPPENED.
GOING TO CALPERS BECAME
INCREASINGLY DIFFICULT -- MY
COACH NOTICED I WAS OUT OF SORTS
AND CALLED ME IN FOR A MEETING.
I JUST CLOSER WOULD HAPPEN AND
SHE CALLED THE DEAN OF STUDENTS.
WHO IS ALSO IN CHARGE OF TITLE?
NINE I WAS TERRIFIED TO REPORT
THE RATE BECAUSE THE SCHOOL SO
SMALL.
AND THE UNIVERSITY HAS A HISTORY
WITH SWEEPING SEXUAL ASSAULTS
UNDER THE RUG.
HOWEVER NOTHING COULD HAVE
PREPARED ME FOR HOW BAD IT
ACTUALLY WAS.
FROM THE VERY BEGINNING THE TEAM
WAS VERY VAGUE AND UNCLEAR ABOUT
THE ENTIRE PROCESS THE POSSIBLE
OUTCOMES IN TIME LINES WERE
NEVER FULLY EXPLAINED TO ME.
THE TEAM SEEMED TO LACK TRAINING
OFTEN MAKING INAPPROPRIATE
STATEMENTS AND CONSTANTLY ASKING
ME FOR HUGS.
SHE FREQUENTLY BAD MATH BAD
MOUTH ANOTHER STUDENT WHOM HE
HAD ALSO ASSAULTED AND TOLD ME
THAT IT WAS IN MY BEST INTEREST
NOT TO ASSOCIATE WITH HER.
ON SEVERAL OCCASIONS I HAD TO
POINT OUT TO THE DEAN THAT SHE
WAS HANDLING THE MANNER IN IT
UNPROFESSIONAL MANNER.
WHEN AMERICA'S FRIENDS BECAUSE
BEGAN THREATENING ME ON SOCIAL
MEDIA THE DâN ASSURED ME THAT
HE WAS ALSO HAVING A VERY HARD
TIME WITH ALL OF IT?
AND THAT HE HAD TO GO HOME EARLY
FOR THE DAY.
SHE PUT ME IN ANOTHER SURVIVOR
AND A HOTEL FOR THE WEEKEND.
AND TOLD US THAT WE'RE AND SAFE
IN OUR HOMES WHICH MADE US FEAR
FOR OUR LIVES EVERY DAY.
THE SCHOOL ISSUED THREE NO
CONTACT ORDERS BETWEEN MARY
PERSONALLY AS WELL AS BETWEEN TO
HIS FRIENDS IN THE HOOD BEEN
THREATENING ME.
THEY DIDN'T KNOW I DIDN'T KNOW
HIS FRIENDS YET I HAD TO BE
SUPER CAREFUL WHERE I WENT OR I
COULD OTHERWISE RISK GETTING IN
TROUBLE FOR BEING AROUND THEM.
I COULDN'T LEAVE MY HOUSE MUCH.
I NEVER MET THE INVESTIGATOR IN
THE MATTER BECAUSE SHE WAS AND
GERMAN BESSIE GATOR AND AS FAR
AS I KNOW.
SHE NEVER ACTUALLY CAME TO OUR
CAMPUS.
THE WAY MY UNIVERSITY HANDLED MY
CASE IS SADLY NOT UNIQUE.
THEY PAID NO MIND TO THE FACT
THAT THEY WERE CONSTANTLY ASKING
ME. THREE LIVE ONE OF THE MOST
DIFFICULT DAYS OF MY LIFE.
THE INVESTIGATOR RECALL ME
DURING CLASS EXPECT ME TO TALK
ABOUT THE RAPE RIGHT THEN AND
THERE. TO SACRIFICE A LOT OF
TIME THAT I WANTED TO SPEND ON
SCHOOL WORK AND ROWING. TO
READING LOTS OF LONG AND
COMPLICATED DOCUMENTS THAT THEY
WERE ALWAYS SENDING ME.
I BECAME VERY DEPRESSED.
I THIRD FALLING BEHIND IN MY
CLASSES DUE TO THE TRAUMA OF THE
RAPE.
HOWEVER WHEN I REQUEST
ACCOMMODATIONS THE DEAN WOULD
NEVER SPONSORING.
I'M A VERY PRIVATE PERSON AND IT
WAS EXTREMELY DIFFICULT FOR ME
TO EXPLAIN THE EFFECT OF
ASSAULTS ALL MY PROFESSORS.
BUT THAT RESPONSIBILITY FALLS
SOLELY ON MY SHOULDERS.
THIS PAST FALL AFTER TO
UNIVERSITY FINDINGS OF HIS
RESPONSIBILITY. TO APPEALS AND
MORE THAN FIVE EXTENSIONS IT
BECAME CLEAR TO ME THAT IF I
DIDN'T SETTLE.
THEY WOULD CONTINUE TO EXTEND
THE INVESTIGATION FOREVER.
I FELT LIKE THE SCHOOL WANTED TO
CRUSH EVERY BIT OF FIGHT THAT I
HAD LIVED.
I'M HERE TODAY SO HOPEFULLY
SURVIVORS WHO CHOOSE TO REPORT
WILL NOT FACE THESE DIFFICULTIES.
AND WON'T BE SCARED TO ATTEND
THEIR OWN UNIVERSITIES AND SO
THE PEOPLE WHO ARE IN CHARGE OF
TITLE.
NINE WILL BE TRAINED TO RESPOND
TO REST MEN AND ASSAULT.
STUDENTS AT THE MOST VULNERABLE
AND TERRIFIED DESERVE THIS. FOR
THESE REASONS I SUPPORT SP.
FOUR NINETY THREE THANK YOU FOR
PROVIDING ME THIS OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK FOR SURVIVORS [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
IF YOU GIVE YOUR NAME IN THE
GROUP YOU'RE WITH.
CHECK OF REGULAR THE NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORK
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
HI GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
SABRINA ASHEN I'M LEGISLATIVE
CHAIR FOR CALIFORNIA WOMEN
LAWYERS AND THE VICE CHAIR FOR
NATIONAL WOMEN'S POLITICAL
CAUCUS AND BOTH ORGANIZATIONS
ARE IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
THANK YOU.
RANDY FEEL ALLEY AT UC BERKELEY
ALUMNI IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU FOR SHARING YOUR STORY --
DIVA CON I'M ALSO UC BERKELEY
ALUMNI AND I'M IN STRONG SUPPORT.
LOS ANGELES CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY AND I STRONGLY
SUPPORTS BILL.
IF YOUR MANAGER FROM THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
RIVERSIDE A STRONG SUPPORT THIS
BILL.
MY NAME IS VINCENT RASO MISSED
AN EASY RIVERSIDE AMOUNTS ARE
INCOMING GOVERNMENT LEASH
INSTRUCTOR IN HERE SAVE STRONGLY
SUPPORT THE BILL.
KATHLEEN SAYING I'M ALUMNI OF UC
BERKELEY AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT
THIS BILL.
GERRI MILLER STUDENT AT
CALIFORNIA LIFTING UNIVERSITY IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
IN GEORGIA AT THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA RIVERSIDE IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
BUT IF SOMEONE OF AND SALAS FROM
UC RIVERSIDE AND I'M IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
DOES THAT ENGINES ARE FROM UC
RIVERSIDE AND I'M IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
RACHEL CO UC BERKELEY ALUMNI
WITH ACCESS WOMEN'S HEALTH
JUSTICE IT STRUCK SUPPORT.
MARISSA HOW TO SHOW UP SOON AT
UC RIVERSIDE AND I'M IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
RACHEL GARBO ALUMNI FROM CAL
POLY SAN LUIS OBISPO AND STRONG
SUPPORT.
I'M AND SAYING A STUDENT AT
SIERRA COLLEGE IN STRONG SUPPORT.
SANTIAGO TABULAR ALUMNI OF UC
SANTA CRUZ IN STRONG SUPPORT.
EMILY MONTELLO TELFORD FROM --
ACTUALLY HELLO MY FROM UCSB AND
A REPRESENTATIVE FROM STUDENTS
AND SEXUAL ASSAULT AND I'M
STRONG SUPPORT.
FELIPE AVAILABLE STUDENT AT UC
SANTA BARBARA AND WITH STUDENTS
FOR REPRODUCTIVE JUSTICE IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
KILL IN ANNECY FROM UC BERKELEY
IN STRONG SUPPORT.
SHERRI LEAVE FROM UC SANTA CRUZ
I'M IN STRONG SUPPORT.
JANET ALL ON YOU SEE OUR LIMóN
NINE IN STRONG SUPPORT.
I'M A CIRCUIT HERE DO STUDENT
BODY PRESIDENT AT UC BERKELEY
STRONG SUPPORT.
ASIA FIREBAUGH UC BERKELEY IN
SERRA SHINE FROM UC BERKELEY
REPRESENTING THE UC SOON
ASSOCIATION IN STRONG SUPPORT.
AND YOU CHEN UC BERKELEY ALONG
IN STRONG SUPPORT.
MANY MARTINEZ SAID IN A YOU SEE
VERISIGN STRONG SUPPORT.
YEAH MORE YESTERDAY I YOU SEE ON
A STRONG SUPPORT.
WHEN TENER LOYAL MARYMOUNT
UNIVERSITY STRONG SUPPORT?
VANESSA BLAYLOCK STUDENT AT
PITZER COLLEGE STRONG SUPPORT.
LEGAL L. YOU SEE OUR STRONG
SUPPORT.
ROBBIE HAS SON UC BERKELEY
ALUMNI IN STRONG SUPPORT.
NUMBER SEVEN ST UC RIVERSIDE IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
LIBBY BENEDICT REPRESENTING NAY
ROLE PRO CHOICE CALIFORNIA AND
UCLA ARE NOT ALONE IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
LARA JIMENEZ WITH CALIFORNIA
LETTING US REPRODUCTIVE JUSTICE
IN STRONG SUPPORT.
MARGE PLUMMER THE WOMEN'S
FOUNDATION A CALIFORNIA IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
WE KIND OF FELT SER A SENIOR AT
UC BERKELEY IN STRONG SUPPORT.
CARLY EVEN THERE -- UC BERKELEY
ALUMNI IN STRONG SUPPORT.
DAY NAVA UC DAVIS LONG NINE
STRONG SUPPORT.
KRISTEN AND THE CALIFORNIA
PARTNERSHIP TEN DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE IN STRONG SUPPORT.
FILES AND ON BEHALF OF PEACE
OVER VIOLENCE IN STRONG SUPPORT.
JOIN THE KARMIC ON BEHALF OF THE
WOMEN'S POLICY INST TO WOMEN'S
FOUNDATION OF CALIFORNIA AS A
SPONSOR AND IN STRONG SUPPORT.
MY VALUES AND ALL REPRESENTING
AMERICAN ASSOCIATION OF
UNIVERSITY WOMEN IN SUPPORT.
DEANNA DURAN CSU NORTHRIDGE
ALUMNI AND STRONG SUPPORT.
STEPHANIE IS A WITH THE
COMMISSION ON THE STATUS OF
WOMEN AND GIRLS IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
AFTER TO HEAR STUDENT AT UC
BERKELEY AND STRONG SUPPORT.
I'M A FULLER LAW STUDENT UC
HASTINGS IN STRONG SUPPORT.
MEGHAN I'M STRONG LOS UNOS TO A
UC HASTINGS IN STRONG SUPPORT.
OBLIVIOUS MOVED UP FROM THE UC
STUDENT ASSOCIATION IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
KAREN PERCENT FOR MATTER LAW
GROUP AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT.
VETERANS STUDENT WESSELS COLLEGE
IN A STRONG SUPPORT.
THE OFFICE OF THIS.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
RIGHT RIGHT THERE THE DAY.
HELLO I'M CITY GARAM CALIFORNIA
ATTORNEY AND I RUN A NON PROFIT.
THAT SEEKS TO HAVE MORE FAIR
PROCEDURES ENTITLED MY
PROCEEDINGS.
WE HAVE BOTH MEN AND WOMEN THAT
HAVE COME TO US DUE TO UNFAIR
PROCEDURES -- I WE GENERALLY
SUPPORT THE BILL BUT WE HAD TO
SAY WE HAVE POSTED.
TO THE STATE ON THE ON THE
ANALYSIS BUT WE GENERALLY
SUPPORT IT BUT WE DO HAVE A
COUPLE OF VERY VERY SERIOUS
CONCERNS.
BASED ON THE EXPERIENCES OF THE
FIFTEEN HUNDRED FAMILIES HAVE
COME TO US.
OVER THE LAST FIVE OR SIX YEARS.
THE FIRST ONE IS THE TRAUMA
INFORMED HEARINGS.
ACCORDING TO THE BILL IT SAYS
THAT -- HEARINGS ARE TO BE
TRAUMA INFORMED AND
INVESTIGATIONS ARE TO BE TRAUMA
INFORMED.
COMMON FORM THEORIES WERE
DEVELOPED AS A COUNSELING
TECHNIQUE AN INTERVIEW TECHNIQUE
TO HELP VICTIMS NOT BE
INTIMIDATED AND RECOGNIZE A BE
ABLE TO REMEMBER OR FAX.
AND IT'S PERFECT FOR THAT THAT'S
EXACTLY WHAT IT SHOULD BE USED.
FOR PEOPLE TO COME FORWARD AS
VICTIMS SHOULD NOT BE GRILLED
SHOULD NOT BE INTIMIDATED.
IT HELPS THEIR MEMORY IF THEY'RE
ALLOWED TO STE RECOUNT THEIR
EXPERIENCES.
THE PROBLEM IS THAT SCHOOLS ARE
MISS SUPPLYING TRAUMA INFORMED
THEORIES AND USING THEM TO
EXCLUDE EVIDENCE FOR EXAMPLE.
IF YOU HAVE A COUPLE THE DATED
FOR SIX MONTHS THEY BREAK UP AND
LATER ONE FILES A CLAIM AGAINST
THE OTHER.
AND THE AND THE INCIDENT WAS
HALFWAY THROUGH THAT EXPERIENCE
THAT RELATIONSHIP.
AND THE PERSON WHO'S ACCUSED
WILL SAY WELL WAIT A MINUTE YOU
KNOW WE HAD THIS ONGOING
RELATIONSHIP FOR THREE MORE
MONTHS IT SEEMED LIKE SHE WAS
HAPPIER HE WAS HAPPY SOMETIMES.
AND IT SEEMED AS THOUGH -- YOU
KNOW EVERYTHING WAS GREAT.
THE INVESTIGATOR WILL SAY TO
THAT PERSON THE ACCUSED THAT'S A
RELEVANT.
WE DON'T EVEN CONSIDER THAT
BECAUSE THAT CAN BE THE RESULT
OF TRAUMATIC BEHAVIOR.
PEOPLE THAT ARE VICTIMS ACT AND
GIVE INCONSISTENT STORIES.
THE PROBLEM WITH THAT ISN'T THAT
THAT ISN'T A POSSIBILITY YES
IT'S A POSSIBILITY THAT SOMEBODY
TRAUMATIZED MIGHT TELL
INCONSISTENT STORIES OR BEHAVE
INCONSISTENTLY.
THE PROBLEM IS IT'S A QUESTION
OF FACT FOR THE DECISION MAKER
IT'S NOT EVIDENCE TO BE EXCLUDED
AND WE HAVE CAL AT LEAST ONE
CALIFORNIA CASE DIRECTLY ON THIS
POINT WE ALSO HAVE SEVERAL CASES
ACROSS UNITED STATES DIRECTLY ON
THIS POINT.
THE CALIFORNIA CASE SAY THAT THE
TRADE THEY WEREN'T PROPERLY
TRAIN BECAUSE THEY WERE TRAINED
IN THE TRAUMA AND FOR METHODS.
THAT'S THE FIRST ISSUE THE
SECOND ISSUE AND I HAVE TO THANK
CENTER JACKSON FOR ADDING CROSS
EXAMINATION TO THE TO THE BILL
BUT THE PROBLEM IS IT STILL HAS
TO BE DONE.
ACCORDING TO THE BILL THROUGH
WRITTEN QUESTIONS PER NEUTRAL
INVESTIGATOR I'M ERE TO TELL
YOU THERE IS NO NEUTRAL
[inaudible]
SCHOOL OFFICIAL.
EVER BECAUSE THAT PERSON OWES AN
OBLIGATION HAS A LEGAL DUTY TO
PROTECT THE STUDENT THEIR
QUESTIONING.
WHAT WE'VE SEEN AND WE SEE THIS
HAPPEN ALL THE TIME?
IS THAT THE PERSON ASSIGNED WITH
ASKING QUESTIONS DOES NOT ASK
THEM REWARDS THEM TRIES TO
SOFTEN THEM.
AND SO YOU DON'T HAVE ANY KIND
OF AN EFFECTIVE.
ODD QUESTIONING OF THE WITNESSES
AS A ROUTE JUST WANNA REMIND THE
THE WITNESSES HERE THAT THANK
YOU YOU HAVE FOUR MINUTES TOTAL
SORRY OKAY.
OTHERS IN UP YOUR OTHER PERSON
SO I'M SORRY OKAY I APOLOGIZE
FOR THAT.
ACROSS EXAMEN EXAMINATION HAS TO
BE FLEXIBLE IT CAN'T BE SCRIPTED
AND HAVING SOMEBODY IN ANOTHER
ROOM AVAILABLE BY VIDEO FEED
WILL MINIMIZE ANY TRAUMA.
HI MY NAME IS KIM JONES THANK
YOU FOR HAVING ME HERE TODAY --
I'M OF THE MOM OF THREE KIDS TWO
BOYS AND A GIRL.
NEVER DREAMT TO THAT WHEN I SENT
MY SON OFF TO COLLEGE THAT HE
WOULD BE THE ONE I WOULD NEED TO
WORRY ABOUT MOST I WAS CONCERNED
ABOUT MY DAUGHTER -- LISTENING
TO THE YOUNG GIRL TELL HER STORY
WAS VERY MUCH THE STORY.
SIMILAR TO MY SONS BEING FALSELY
ACCUSED OF SOMETHING HE DID NOT --
TO HE WAS NEVER TOLD OF HIS
ALLEGATIONS HE HAD TO SHOW UP
AND COME TO THESE HEARINGS HE
DIDN'T KNOW WHY HE WAS NOT
ALLOWED TO WALK FOR GRADUATION
THERE WAS NO RULING THAT WAS
MADE HE DIDN'T THAT HE NEVER HAD
A HEARING HE WAS TOLD HE WOULD
HAVE.
A FAIR HEARING THAT NEVER
HAPPENED -- HE WAS FOUND
RESPONSIBLE FOR SEXUAL ASSAULT
HE KISSED A GIRL -- HE WAS
EXPELLED FROM THE CSU SYSTEM
NEVER WELCOME BACK AND WE
APPEALED AND ULTIMATELY FILED A
LAWSUIT.
AND I'M HERE TO TELL YOU WE WON
BECAUSE WE FINALLY HAD SOMEBODY
WHO WAS.
A THIRD NEUTRAL PARTY THAT WOULD
HEAR US AND LOOK AT THE FACTS AS
THEY WERE AND LOOK AT THE
EVIDENCE.
AND I'M HERE TO TELL YOU YOU
KNOW THAT YES IT NEEDS TO BE
FAIR IT NEEDS TO BE UNBIASED FOR
ALL PARTIES.
ABSOLUTELY AND THERE'S THERE IT
YOU KNOW.
YOU NEED TO THINK OF THEM AS
WELL [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
IF YOU TO GIVE YOUR NAME AND THE
ORGANIZATION THAT YOU'RE WITH.
MY NAME IS MICHELLE JACQUELINE
AND MY ORGANIZATION IS RESPECT
LIFE FOR ALL.
I AM IN OPPOSITION BECAUSE I
DON'T SEE ANYTHING REFERRING TO
CONCRETE EVIDENCE TO PROSECUTE
SOMEONE AND THIS IS VERY
CONCERNING TO ME.
THAT A LOT OF PEOPLE COMPLAIN
WHEN THEY'RE IN A SITUATION THE
UP OF VULNERABILITY THEY'VE BEEN
DRINKING ALCOHOL AND ALL GOING.
TO UC'S LAST WITNESSES OR JUST
YOUR NAME AND THE ORGANIZATION
YOU'RE WITH THANK YOU THANK YOU.
ANY ANY WINNERS.
PLEASE COME UP.
A GOOD AFTERNOON ENTER MARTINEZ
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY I
WANT TO THINK THE AUTHOR AND THE
SPONSOR FOR SPENDING NUMEROUS
HOURS WITH US.
AS WE WORK TO THE CONCERNS WE
HAVE WITH THE BILL -- WE MADE A
LOG PROGRESS ON OUR CONCERNS --
THERE ARE A COUPLE ISSUES OF
CONCERN THEY THEY'RE PROBABLY
MORE PRUDENT TO BE DRESSED IN
THE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE THAN
THIS COMMITTEE HAVE.
SPECIFICALLY RIGHT OF ACTION --
BUT WE DO APPRECIATE THE THE
DIALOGUE THAT YOU HAVE -- YOU
PROVIDED TO OUR OFFICE -- WE'VE
MET NUMEROUS TIMES DURING.
THE SENATE AND THIS HEARING
RICHARD LOOKING FOR TO SPEAK TO
THE SCOTTISH IS THE FUTURE.
GOOD AFTERNOON ALEX CRAZY
ASSOCIATION INDEPENDENT
CALIFORNIA COLLEGES UNIVERSITIES
AS ONE ECHO -- WHAT MY PREVIOUS
COLLEAGUES SAID ABOUT --
EXTENDING THANKS TO THE AUTHORS
STAFF IN THE SPONSORS FOR ME
WITH US MULTIPLE HOURS AND WILL
CONTINUE TO WORK THROUGH THESE
ISSUES IS MOVES FOR AND ALSO
JUST WANT TO THANK THAT THE
STUDENTS SURVIVOR FOR COMING
FORWARD.
THANK YOU AND IF OTHER TWEETERS
WOULD JUST GIVE THEIR NAME AND
THE GROUP THERE WITH.
JUSTIN SELLING ABOUT THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNICABLE THE
CHANCES OFFICE NO FORMAL
POSITION BUT WILL CONTINUE
WORKING WITH THE AUTHOR.
PRIME MACLAINE YOU THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE A OF CALIFORNIA AND WE
AT ECHO THE SENTIMENTS OPEN SAID
BY MY COLLEAGUES [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
THE COMMITTEE.
BACK TO ROME.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND UP
WHEN IT'S APPROPRIATE I'D LIKE
TO MOVE THE BILL AND I WANTED TO
START BY THANKING THE AUTHOR FOR
BRING IN THIS IMPORTANT AND
SENSIBLE MEASURE BEFORE THIS
COMMITTEE.
I WAS MOVED BY THE TESTIMONY
FROM THE STUDENT AND IF YOU CAN
CONVEY.
THAT OUR WORDS IMPACTED MANY OF
US AND NEED TO BE HEARD.
IT'S IMPORTANT THAT WE HAVE A
TRANSPARENT PROCESS THAT WORKS
FOR EVERYONE AND I'M ENCOURAGED
THAT THIS BILL DOES JUST THAT
AND WOULD URGE MY COLLEAGUES TO
SUPPORT IT WHEN THE TIME IS
APPROPRIATE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS COMMENTS.
US SENATOR JACKSON WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE YES THANK YOU
BRIEFLY -- AND I DO WANT.
TO THANK OUR WITNESS.
WE'VE HEARD THAT STORY MANY
TIMES.
THROUGHOUT THE STATE THROUGHOUT
THE NATION.
AND I BROUGHT THIS BILL BECAUSE
I AM BOTH HORRIFIED BY THE
PREVALENCE OF THIS SITUATION.
AND THE FACT THAT WE HAVE TO
HAVE A FAIR AND EQUITABLE
PROCESS.
AS A RECOVERING LAWYER I AM
COMMITTED TO DUE PROCESS OF LAW
FOR BOTH THE ACCUSED.
AND FOR THE VICTIM AND I'M I
APPRECIATE THE COMMENTS OF THOSE.
WHO ARE CONCERNED ABOUT THE
POTENTIAL FALSE ALLEGATIONS I
THINK WE HAVE TO REMEMBER?
THIS IS AN ADMINISTRATIVE
PROCEEDING THIS IS A SCHOOL
MISCONDUCT PROCEEDING SO IT
ISN'T A CRIMINAL PROCEEDING --
IN FACT VERY FEW WOMEN COME
FORWARD. TO IT TO DO THESE
ADMINISTRATIVE PROCEEDINGS --
BECAUSE OF THEIR FEAR THAT THE
PROCESS WILL BE SIMILAR TO WHAT
THIS YOUNG WOMAN EXPERIENCED
THERE ARE -- ALLEGED
PERPETRATORS WHO HAVE BEEN
HISTORICALLY OR OUR ACTIONS A
STARKLY IN SOME INSTANCES WHICH
I THINK WAS REFLECTED BY THE
TESTIMONY OF THE WITNESS HERE
TODAY.
PREVIOUSLY WHERE THE SYSTEMS
DIDN'T WORK FOR EITHER PARTY.
AND THIS BILL IS AN ATTEMPT TO
CREATE THAT THAT BALANCE OF DUE
PROCESS RECOGNIZING THIS IS AN
ADMINISTRATIVE PROCEEDING NOT A
CRIMINAL PROCEEDING.
AND TO MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE A
PROCESS FOR ALL SCHOOLS TO FALL --
YOU KNOW SCHOOLS ARE EDUCATIONAL
INSTITUTIONS THEY'RE NOT COURTS
OF LAW PER SE WHAT THEY NEED IS
THEY NEED TO HAVE A SENSITIVITY
TO THE ISSUES.
THEY NEED TO BE ABLE TO PROVIDE
A HEARING MECHANISM SO THAT --
THAT EACH PARTY WILL HAVE A
RIGHT TO BE HEARD AND THE NEED
TO THOSE PARTIES BE PROTECTED --
WHEN YOU HAVE SOMEONE WHO HAS
BEEN VICTIMIZED -- THIS CAN BE A
HORRIFIC EXPERIENCE AND WE KNOW
HISTORICALLY OVER TIME THAT
SCHOOLS HAVE HAVE BEEN A LITTLE
TONE DEAF.
OR THEY'VE BEEN INADEQUATE THEY
HAVE BEEN TRAINED IN HOW TO
PROPERLY DO THISWE WANT TO HAVE
THE ABILITY TO CROSS EXAMINE
THAT'S PART OF WHAT THE DUE
PROCESS -- SYSTEM SHOULDBE AND
SO GOING FORWARD -- TO WHEN IT
CONTINUE WORKING.
WITH EVERYONE HERE IS MENTIONED
I'VE CONVENE MEETINGS -- TITLE
NINE IN ORDER FOR IT TO MEET ITS
EXPECTATION HATCH TO PROVIDE
EQUITY FOR ALL STUDENTS AND WE
TOOK A LOT OF THIS -- FROM WHAT
WAS THAT THEN THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION SPENT TWO YEARS
WORKING.
ON A PROCESS THAT WOULD BE MORE
FAIR -- THE GOVERNOR PRESENTED
SOME OPTIONS WHEN HE VETOED THIS
BILL SAID I'D LIKE TO LOOK INTO
THIS FURTHER WE TOOK ALMOST ALL
OF THOSE RECOMMENDATION A COUPLE
WE TWEAKED A LITTLE BIT -- AND I
REALLY BELIEVE THAT WE ARE
MOVING IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION TO
TRY TO GET TO RESOLUTION THAT
WILL PROTECT VICTIMS IT WILL
PROTECT THOSE ACCUSED BUT IT
WILL ULTIMATELY DO JUSTICE FOR
THE STUDENTS AND WITH THAT I
WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE -- THANK THE WHEN IT
THANK SENATOR JACKSON FOR
BRINGING THIS MEASURE -- FOR IT
BIG KNOWLEDGE OF YOU'VE BEEN A
LONG TIME CHAPLAIN AS OF SEXUAL
EQUITY.
BEING ADDRESSED IN THIS BILL I
SUPPORTED SB SIXTEEN SIX ONE
SIXTY NINE LAST YEAR AND WAS
SUPPORT AS BEFORE.
NINETY THREE THIS YEAR -- ALSO
WANT TO MENTION THAT I WAS PART
OF THE HEARINGS I THINK IT'S
SOME OF MY COLLEAGUES WERE UP
AND DOWN THE STATE -- BOTH AT
UCLA UC SANTA BARBARA ON THIS
TOPIC AS WELL.
THE VERY GOOD HEARINGS WHERE WE
WERE ABLE TO HEAR VERY MUCH FROM
FROM THE STUDENTS.
SO I KNOW THAT YOU'VE BEEN
WORKING WITH THE SEGMENTS TO
ADDRESS SOME OF THEIR CONCERNS.
I UNDERSTAND THAT THE PROGRESS
THAT HAS BEEN MADE OF LATE AND
YOUR INTENT TO TAKE AMENDMENTS
AND THE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE TO
ISSUES THAT ARE.
UNDER THAT COMMITTEES PREVIEW
AND I WILL ASK YOU IF YOU WOULD
PLEASE KEEP MY STAFF --
ABSOLUTELY -- INFORMED OF THOSE --
AND WITH LACK OF A QUORUM.
WE WILL BRING IT UP FOR A VOTE
WHEN WE ESTABLISH A CHOIR THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR AND THANK YOU
MEMBERS THANK YOU CENTER
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
LOOKING FOR AUTHORS.
NOT SEEN ANY.
IF THE US SERGEANT.
UP [inaudible]
DOCTOR PAN.
PLEASE COME FORWARD AND IF YOU'D
LIKE TO START WITH ITEM FOUR SB
[inaudible]
TWO NINETY SEVEN HAVE A WELL
THEN WHY DID YOU WAITING
[inaudible]
ALL RIGHT [inaudible]
BEGIN.
OKAY THANK YOU THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS. FOR DECADES
SCHOOLS AND COMMUNITY COLLEGES
HAVE STRUGGLE TO MEET SUMMER
CONSTRUCTION DEADLINES.
ED OF STUDENTS ARRIVING FOR
CLASSES IN THE FALL.
OFTEN RESULTING IN COSTS THE
LAYS AND DISPLAY STUDENTS.
THE FIRST WEEKS OR EVEN MONTHS
OF CONTRACT ACTIVITY.
UNDER NEWLY AWARDED CONSTRUCTION
CONTRACT FOR FOCUSED ON THE
PRELIMINARY WORK.
OF AWARDING SUBCONTRACTS MAKING
SHOP DRAWINGS NORDIC MATERIALS.
THE AUTHORITY TO AWARD
CONSTRUCTION CONTRACTS PRIOR TO
STATE ARCHITECT APPROVAL CURLY
EXISTS FOR DESIGN BUILD PROJECTS
AND FOR K. TO TWELVE LEASE
LEASEBACK PROJECTS.
BUT NOT FOR COMPETITIVELY BID
PROJECTS.
THIS BILL SB TWO NINETY SEVEN
WOULD ALLOW SCHOOLS AND
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICT TO
WARD CONSTRUCTION CONTRACTS.
BUT NOT PERFORM CONSTRUCTION
WHEN DECIDE NOT PERFORMANCE
CONSTRUCTION PRIOR TO RECEIVING
PLAN APPROVAL FROM THE STATE
ARCHITECT.
THAT'S STREAMLINING SUMMER
CONSTRUCTION PROJECTS.
SB TWO NINETY SEVEN ALSO ALLOWS
COMMITTEE COLLEGE DISTRICTS TO
AVOID COSTLY DELAYS FOR
MAINTAINING STUDENT SAFETY.
IS PROVIDED BY THE FIELD ACT.
SB TWO NINETY SEVEN SUPPORTED BY
SCHOOL FACILITY PROFESSIONALS IN
CONSTRUCTION COMPANIES WHAT CO
TO FIGHT CODIFY LEGISLATIVE
RECOMMENDATION.
MADE BY TASK FORCE COMMISSION BY
THE DIVISION OF STATE ARCHITECT.
I UNDERSTAND THAT THERE IS
OPPOSITION FROM CONTRACTOR LABOR
GROUPS IN MY OFFICE IS CURRENTLY
WORKING WITH THE SPONSORS.
OPPOSITION IN SCHOOL DISTRICT TO
ADDRESS THEIR CONCERNS RELATED
TO CONSTRUCTION DEPUTE DISPUTES
AND CHANGE ORDERS.
TODAY I AM PLEASED TO HAVE WITH
ME DAVID TALENT OF THE
ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA
CONSTRUCTION MANAGERS SPEAKING
SORE IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL IN
THE ANSWER ANY TECHNICAL
QUESTIONS.
EXPECT THE ASPIRIN I THOUGHT
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SENATOR -- SUPPORT
WITNESSES.
HELLO AB MY NAME'S DICK CALLAN
WITH THE ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA
CONSTRUCTION MANAGERS I WAS
ACTUALLY A MEMBER OF THE TAX
TASK FORCE THAT -- DOCTOR PAN --
MENTIONED AND THE STATE
ARCHITECT -- HAS IMPLEMENTED OUR
TASK FORCE RECOMMENDATIONS AND
NOW DOCTOR PAN THAT BRINGS TO A
BILL FOR THE LAST ITEM WHICH
REQUIRES A CHANGE TO THE FIELD
BACK.
FROM THE MANY PROJECTS DESIGN
BUILD AND LEASE BACK THAT
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICTS HAVE
HAD I'VE HEARD OF NO ISSUES WITH
MANAGING THE EXPECTATION THAT
THERE WILL BE SOME DE SA.
STATE ARCHITECT CHANGES TO PLANS
ONCE THEY'RE APPROVED BUT THE
BENEFITS GAINED FROM BEING [E
TO ORDER MATERIALS AND HAVE THEM
STAGE. FOR THESE EVER A SHORTER
WINDOWS OF VACATION TIME IN
SCHOOL I THINK FAR OUTWEIGH THE
RISKS -- THIS IS A SPECIAL TOOL
I DON'T THINK THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE DISTRICT WILL WANT NEED
TO USE THIS ON EVERY ONE OF
THEIR HARD BID PROJECTS PROBABLY
ONE IN -- TEN AND I TRUST THOSE
DISTRICTS AND THEIR ATTORNEYS
AND THEIR ARCHITECTS IN MY FORTY
YEARS OF BEING A CONSTRUCTION
CONTRACTOR WITH THEM.
I FIND THEM TO BE WELL QUALIFIED
COMPETENT AND CAREFUL AS THEY
PREPARE THEIR BID DOCKS AND
THEIR CONTRACTS.
QUITE FRANKLY IF THEY AREN'T
FAIR TO CONTRACTORS THEY DON'T
GET GOOD BITS AND IN THIS
CLIMATE GETTING GOOD BIDS IS
REALLY IMPORTANT TO THEM.
I AGREE WITH DOCTOR PAN THE
SCHOOL DISTRICT AND CONSTRUCTION
INDUSTRY GROUPS VIEWS ARE NOT
REALLY VERY FAR APART I'M SURE
WE CAN GET LANGUAGE.
AT TO GET THEM TOGETHER THANK
YOU FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION.
ANY SUPPORT MRS.
ORTIZ.
I DAMON CONKLIN WITH -- SEGMENT
ORIGINAL BUILDERS EXCHANGE ON
BEHALF OF OUR ELEVEN HUNDRED
MEMBER COMPANIES REPRESENTING
GENERAL CONTRACTORS -- WE ARE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
REGISTER CLING ON BEHALF OF THE
SMALL SCHOOL DISTRICTS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
EMP DEAL WITH THE COALITION FOR
ADEQUATE SCHOOL HOUSING AND
SUPPORT.
MARC CHRISTIAN WITH THE AMERICAN
INSTITUTE OF ARCHITECTS
CALIFORNIA SUPPORT OF AN CONCEPT
WORKING WITH THE AUTHORS OFFICE
ON THOSE ISSUES -- DON'T
FINANCIAL RISK.
OKAY ANY OPPOSITION WITNESSES.
FROM FOUR TO THE FRONT DESK.
AS YOU HEAD OF HEARD WHEN AGO WE
HAVE A FULL MINUTES.
IN COMBINATION.
IN A SPLIT YOUR TIME.
SCOTT GOVERNOR HALF OF THE
CONSTRUCTION EMPLOYERS
ASSOCIATION WE ARE THE LARGEST
UNIONIZED GENERAL CONTRACTORS IN
THE STATE WE DO ABOUT. 5060% OF
ALL THE SCHOOLS IN STATE
CALIFORNIA WE HAVE BEEN WORKING
WITH THE SENATOR TO ADDRESS
CONCERNS REGARDING LIABILITY
WHICH IS ALWAYS OUR NUMBER ONE
ISSUE.
THE NOTION OF AWARDING A
CONTRACT BEFORE THE PLANS HAVE
BEEN APPROVED.
IT'S A LITTLE SCARY FOR THE
CONSTRUCTION INDUSTRY BECAUSE
THE STATE ARCHITECT WILL
INVARIABLY MAKE CHANGES.
THEN THE QUESTION IS WHO'S ON
THE HOOK FOR THOSE CHANGES --
YOU KNOW THERE'S CONCERN THAT
DISTRICTS WILL TRY AND PASS THAT
LIABILITY ON TO CONTRACTORS.
WHICH SHOULD BE PERILOUS FOR US.
SO WE WANT TO ENSURE THAT IF THE
DISTRICT ELECTS TO USE THIS
METHOD.
THAT.
ANY CHANGES REQUIRED BY DSA
WOULD FALL BACK ON TO THE
DISTRICT BECAUSE THEY ELECTED TO
DO IT THIS WAY.
THERE'S ALSO A THE SUPREME COURT
CASE IT'S ABOUT A HUNDRED YEARS
OLD CALLED SPEARING THAT'S A
PART OF THE SPEAR AND DOCTOR AND
WHICH REQUIRES -- PUBLIC
AGENCIES TO WARRANT PLANS THIS
CREATE SOME CONFUSION THERE IF
YOU ARE KNOWINGLY ISSUING.
INCOMPLETE PLANS WE'VE ACTUALLY
CODIFIED THE SPEAR AND DOCTOR IN
CALIFORNIA LAW.
THAT ABOUT FIFTEEN YEARS AGO SO
THIS CREATE SOME CONFUSION THERE
AGAIN LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH THE AUTHOR BUT THESE ARE
PIVOTAL ISSUES FOR THE INDUSTRY
THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS BRETT BERYL
WITH UNITED CONTRACTORS THE
CALIFORNIA CHAPTERS OF THE
NATIONAL UNDER CONTRACT
ASSOCIATION CONFERENCE
LEGISLATIVE CONFERENCE THE PLAN
HE PIPING INDUSTRY.
AND THE WESTERN WALL AND CEILING
ALLIANCE AND WE'RE ALSO HERE IN
OPPOSITION BUT WORKING WITH THE
AUTHOR -- TO CORRECT THESE
ISSUES AND I JUST WANNA AMIR
WHAT MY COUNTERPART IS CA HAS
SAID THIS THIS AFTERNOON SO
THANK YOU.
CAN YOU ELABORATE THE EXACTLY
WHAT YOU ARE TRYING TO CHANGE
HOW YOU.
AMENDED IT WE WOULD LIKE TO SEE
THE AMENDMENTS THAT PUT THE ONUS
ON THE THE DISTRICTS BECAUSE
LIKE MUCH LIKE SCOTT MR GOVERNOR
HAS SAID -- WHEN YOU ALLOW
CONTRACTS TO BE ISSUED PRIOR TO
THE PLANS BEING FINALIZED YOU DO
RUN A SEARCH YOU RUN INTO
CIRCUMSTANCES WHERE THOSE WOULD
NEGATE THOSE WOULD NECESSITATE
CHANGES TO BOTH THE MATERIALS
THAT ARE DELIVERED? TO THE TYPE
THE HOW THE JOBS GOING TO BE
DONE -- THE CRITERION THE BITS
BACK ALL COME INTO PLAY AT THAT
POINT AND SO YOU KNOW IF WE
DON'T ADDRESS THIS ISSUE YOU'D
RUN INTO MUCH MORE LITIGATION
AND CHANGE ORDER PROBLEMS AS WE
MOVE FORWARD IN THIS TYPE OF OF
STRUCTURES [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
NEAR THE OPPOSITION WITNESSES SO
FROM THE AUDIENCE.
OKAY AS CHAIR CORSET THAT
TRAINERS [inaudible]
IN BETWEEN.
NO OKAY THANK YOU SO MUCH NOW TO
THE MEMBERS -- ANY DISCUSSIONS
AND QUESTIONS [inaudible]
OKAY NOTHING [inaudible]
THE SERVER.
OKAY -- YEAH.
ARAMBULA WELL THIS DOCTORS MUST
LOOK ALIKE TO YOU DOCTOR.
RAISE YOUR HAND I CAN TELL --
YOU KNOW I WANTED TO SHARE A BIT
OF THE CONCERNS WITH THE
OPPOSITION AND ENCOURAGE THE
AUTHOR TO WORK ON THIS BECAUSE
IT'S IMPORTANT TO MANY OF US IN
OUR DISTRICTS AND THE PEOPLE
THAT WE REPRESENT AS WELL SO --
I'M HAPPY TO SUPPORT THIS TODAY
BUT JUST ENCOURAGE -- COURSE AS
WE GO FORWARD THAT -- WERE ABLE
TO WORK OUT SOME OF THE
DIFFERENCES THAT WERE DISCUSSED
TODAY.
WHAT THAT I'M LOOK FOR TO MOVE
IT WHEN WE HAVE A CORE?
SENATOR WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
SO I THINK WE ARE STILL SHORT OF
HE ORANGE AND OWNER BANKING THAT
LATER OKAY THANK THANK YOU --
AFTER CHOI FIRST OF ALL I JUST
WANNA SAY IS IS THAT I
APPRECIATE WHEN WE'RE BUT THE
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
OPPOSITION -- CERTAINLY HERE --
THEIR CONCERNS -- TO POINT OUT
THAT THIS IS A MODEL THAT'S BEEN
USED SUCCESSFULLY ACTUALLY FOR
AGAIN ARE A YEAH ON THE AND
OTHER CIRCUMSTANCES ARE LEASE
LEASEBACK PROJECTS ARE DESIGN
BUILD PROJECTS.
I THINK THAT -- YEAH WE YOU KNOW
WHERE -- WE CERTAINLY -- WILL I
THINK WORK OUT THE ISSUES WITH
THE OPPOSITION REGARDING -- AND
STANCE MATT LIABILITY AND
CERTAINLY YES THAT'S THE THE
THERE IS SOME UNCERTAINTY
BECAUSE THE DSA MAY MAKE SOME
CHANGES IN EXACTLY HOW THAT GETS
ASSIGNED TO SONY UNDERSTAND THE
CONTRACTORS NOT BEING WANTING TO
BE ON THE HOOK FOR THAT.
AND I I WOULD ALSO IMAGINE
THOUGH -- IS THAT BEYOND ANY
LEGISLATION IT'S REALLY WELL
WORK WITH THEM ON IN IN IN
DRAFTING THE FINAL VERSION OF
THE BILL IS IS THAT -- IF IF
SOMEONE HAS A CONTRACT THAT'S
GOING TO PUT ALL THE LIABILITY
ON THE CONTRACTOR -- I I WOULD
HOPE THE CONTRACTOR WOULDN'T
ACCEPT THAT THAT CONTRACT AS
WELL SO -- IF IT BUT SAME TIME I
UNDERSTAND IMPORTANCE OF PUTTING
SOME THINGS IN THE ACTUAL BILL
THAT THE BECOMES LAW ON CODE
THAT ALSO PROVIDE SOME
PROTECTION AS WELL CERTAINLY
HAPPY TO WORK WITH THE
OPPOSITION.
ON THIS BUT I THINK THIS AGAIN
WILL BE A BENEFIT FOR US SCHOOL
DISTRICTS.
THANK IMPACT THE PAN.
AND THE ORDER THAT THE WATER
WHEN WE HAVE A COR THANK YOU
[inaudible]
WHAT'S NEXT. FIFTEEN HAS BEEN.
THIRTY OKAY DOCTOR PAN WHERE YOU
HAVE A AND OTHER ONE FIFTIES.
YES SB.
SIX SIXTY THANK YOU SB SIX SIXTY
OKAY WELL THANK YOU MISTER VICE
CHAIR MEMBERS.
CAMPUS COUNTS THE SERVICES ARE
NOT MEETING THE GROWING STUDENT
DEMAND AND SB SIX SIXTY REQUIRES
THE CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY
IN CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES
TO ESTABLISH A GOAL OF HAVING
ONE MENTAL HEALTH COUNSELOR.
EVERY FIFTEEN HUNDRED STUDENTS
ENROLLED AT EACH OF THEIR
RESPECTIVE CAMPUSES.
THIS RATIO IS RECOMMENDED BY THE
INTERNATIONAL ASSOCIATION
COUNSELING SERVICES TO
ADEQUATELY ADDRESS MENTAL HEALTH
NEEDS ON TAP COLLEGE CAMPUSES.
SB SIX SIXTY ALSO HOPES TO
REMEDY THE GENERAL LACK OF
CONSISTENT REPORTING THROUGHOUT
EACH SYSTEM BY REQUIRING EACH
CAMPUS REPORT THE LEGISLATURE
EVERY THREE YEARS.
THERE IS A GROWING NEED FOR THE
SERVICES AND SB SIX SIXTY
ADDRESSES THE MENTAL HEALTH
CRISIS FINAL.
FACING CALIFORNIA'S PUBLIC
HIGHER EDUCATION SYSTEM OF
GIVING US THE INFORMATION WE
NEED. TO CONTINUE TO GIVE THE
CARE OUR STUDENTS DESERVE.
A POINT OUT THAT THE RECENT
STATES HAVE SHOWN WE HAVE SEEN A
LARGE INCREASE AND DEPRESSION
OTHER CONDITIONS.
BOTH IN ADOLESCENTS AND
OFTENTIMES COLLEGE SOON TO TALK
ABOUT LATE ADOLESCENCE EARLY
TWENTIES BUT WE ALSO KNOW THAT
TRANSITION TO A HIGHER EDUCATION.
ALSO THIS CREATES MANY STRESSORS
AND THIS IS ALSO ABOUT BE SURE
THAT THE STUDENTS CAN
SUCCESSFULLY COMPLETE THEIR
EDUCATION SO STUDENT WHO'S NOT
TRANSITIONING WHILE THE
STRUGGLING WITH DEPRESSION OR
OTHER MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES AND
BY THE WAY MANY OF MENTAL HEALTH
ISSUES FIRST MANIFEST THEMSELVES
BY THE WAY IN.
LATE ADOLESCENCE FOR EARLY
TWENTIES IF WHICH IS EXACTLY
WHEN STUDENTS ARE COLLEGE WE BE
SURE THAT THEY ARE ABLE TO GET
THE HELP THEY NEED SO THAT THEY
CAN COMPLETE THEIR EDUCATION AND
BE ABLE TO THEN -- THE OF THE
SUCCESSFUL IN CALIFORNIA SO I AM
PLEASED TO HAVE WITH ME TODAY
DOCTOR IAN WALLACE A MENTAL
HEALTH COUNSELOR FROM CALIFORNIA
STATE UNIVERSITY MARITIME
ACADEMY.
AND CHART.
DRUDGERY SO WITH THE CALIFORNIA
STATE STUDENT ASSOCIATION ASPECT
WE ASK WHEN I VOTE.
OKAY WITNESSES SAID DR WELLNESS.
GOOD AFTERNOON COMMITTEE MEMBERS
OF I AM DOCTOR IN LOS COUNSELING
PSYCHOLOGISTS FROM CALIFORNIA
STATE UNIVERSITY MARITIME
ACADEMY ON BEHLF OF THE
CALIFORNIA FACULTY ASSOCIATION
I'M HERE TO TELL YOU THE
STUDENTS ARE SUFFERING
ACADEMICALLY AND PERSONALLY.
BECAUSE COUNSELING CENTERS IN
THE CSU ARE CHRONICALLY AND
WOEFULLY UNDERSTAFFED WHICH IS
WHY WE NEED SB.
SIX SIXTY CAL MARITIME I'M THE
ONLY FULL TIME MENTAL HEALTH
COUNSELOR MY PART TIME CALLING
IN AYE SERVER THOUSAND CADETS IN
OUR SCHEDULES ARE FULL.
EACH DAY A COUNCIL FIVE TO SEVEN
STUDENTS ARRIVE EARLY AND STAY
LATE YET MY FELLOW CSU COUNTERS
AREN'T CENTERS WITH COUNSELOR TO
STUDENT RATIOS THREE AND FOUR
TIMES GREATER THAN MARITIME.
FAR ABOVE THE INDUSTRY STANDARD
OF ONE TO FIFTEEN HUNDRED SO
WHAT'S THE RESULT.
CANCERS MEETING WITH STUDENTS IN
CRISIS FOR THE MOST DISTRESSED
AND THE MOST SUICIDAL.
THESE DANGERS RATIOS TURN
COUNSELING CENTERS INTO CRISIS
CENTERS.
STUDENTS NOT IN CRISIS ARE PUT
ON WAIT LIST OR FOR OFF CAMPUS
TO AN INADEQUATE MENTAL HEALTH
CARE SYSTEM ALL THE WHILE EACH
CSU STUDENT CONTINUES TO PAY
HUNDREDS OF DOLLARS.
IN HEALTH FEES EVERY YEAR FOR ON
CAMPUS HEALTH CENTERS THAT TURN
THEM AWAY.
NATIONALLY DEMAND FOR METALS
SERVICES ARE UP 30% 40% THIS
PAST YEAR CAL MARITIME WITHOUT
EXPANDING CAPACITY SOME CENTER
SQUEEZING MORE APPOINTMENTS
CHANGING TIMES FROM FIFTEEN TO
THIRTY MINUTES.
OTHER CENTERS INSTITUTE MODELS
WERE SELF HELP MATERIALS GROUP
COUNSELING OR COMMUNITY
REFERRALS ARE THE FIRST LINE OF
TREATMENT.
THIS IS THE KIND OF SUB STANDARD
AND SHOPPING MENTAL HEALTH CARE
THE LIKE KAISER PERMANENTE A. B.
FIND MILLIONS OF DOLLARS BY
STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
IN THE CSU.
THESE INTERVENTIONS ONCE SEEN AS
ADJUNCTS TO THE GOLD STANDARD OF
ONE ON ONE COUNSELING OR WORK
AROUNDS FOR UNDERSTAFFED CENTERS.
DISGUISED AS PROGRESS IN
INNOVATION.
SB SIX SIXTY ALSO ACCOUNTING
CENTER DIVERSIFY STAFF PROVIDE
CULTURALLY COMPETENT CARE THIS
MEANS HAVING COUNCILS REFLECTS
STUDENTS RACIAL GENDER SEXUAL
ECONOMIC AND OTHER IDENTITIES.
THE SEVERAL NOW IMPROVE THE WELL
BEING OF STUDENTS OF COLOR BUT
WILL HELP ELIMINATE THE
ACHIEVEMENT GAP.
A MAJOR PILLAR OF THE CSU
GRADUATION INITIATIVE.
TWENTY TWENTY FIVE LASTLY I URGE
YOU TO RECOGNIZE THE GRAVITY OF
THE SITUATION AND NOT IGNORE THE
METAL THESE OUR STUDENTS ASK YOU
TO RATIONALLY CONSIDER DANIEL
EISENBERG'S WORK FOR THE
UNIVERSITY MICHIGAN WHICH SHOWS
THE INCREASING MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES PAYS FOR ITSELF.
IN RETENTION INTUITION.
AND LASTLY ON BEHALF OF THE
COUNCIL ACROSS CSU WE COUNT ON
YOU TO WEAR THE REAL COST OF
INACTION IN THIS PROVIDE CSU
STUDENTS ADEQUATE MENTAL
SERVICES.
ASK FOR SUPPORT SB SIX SIXTY
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT WITH -- GOOD
AFTERNOON COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY
NAME IS SURGERY SO SUS AN
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR FOR THE CAL
STATE SOON ASSOCIATION WHICH
REPRESENTS NEARLY HALF A MILLION
CSU STUDENTS ACROSS THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
REALLY THANKFUL TO THE SENATOR
AND THE CALIFORNIA FACULTY
ASSOCIATION FOR THEIR LEADERSHIP
ON THIS ISSUE.
SINCE IN THE CAL STATE SYSTEM
HAVE A WHOLE HOST OF ISSUES THAT
THEY DEAL WITH AND ATTEMPTING TO
ATTAIN A DEGREE.
HAVE YOU HEARD FROM CSU STUDENTS
THIS ENTIRE YEAR -- OUR STUDENTS
SHOP SUFFER FROM HIGH RATES OF
HOMELESSNESS AND MENTAL -- AND
AND FOOD AND SECURITY RATES THAT
ARE UNBELIEVABLE -- PRIOR -- TO
TO RESEARCH BEING DONE.
THAT THE STRESS IS TO BE CALLED
SHOULDN'T HAVE NEVER BEEN
GREATER WHICH IS WHY OUR
STUDENTS NEED ADDITIONAL MENTAL
HEALTH RESOURCES ON THEIR
CAMPUSES IN FACT.
THE ISSUE OF MENTAL HEALTH
RESOURCES HAS BEEN SUCH A
PRIORITY FOR OUR STUDENTS THAT
IT HAS BEEN A TOP PRIORITY IN
OUR POLICY AGENDA FOR THE LAST
TWO YEARS IN A ROW.
AND IT'S EASY TO UNDERSTAND WHY
THIS IS SUCH A PRESSING ISSUE
JUST UNDER HALF OF OUR CAMPUSES
HAVE THE THE RATIO OF ONE COUNT
SORT OF FIFTEEN FIFTEEN HUNDRED
STUDENTS PROPOSED IN SB.
SIX SIXTEEN THIS MEANS THAT ON A
MAJORITY OF CAMPUSES STUDENTS
REPORTING SIGNIFICANT WAIT TIMES
SOMETIMES UP TO A MONTH TO SEE A
MENTAL HEALTH COUNSELOR.
AND CAP THAT HOW MANY TIMES THAT
THEY CAN SEE A COUNSELOR UP TO
SOMETIMES AS LOW AS FIVE TIMES A
YEAR.
THAT'S WHY PASSING AND FINDING
SIX SIXTY IS I SB SIX SIXTY SO
CRUCIAL WHEN A STUDENT CAN
ACKNOWLEDGE OUR NEED FOR MENTAL
HEALTH RESOURCES THEY SHOULD NOT
HAVE TO WAIT NEARLY A MONTH TO
SEE SOMEBODY.
ESPECIALLY GIVEN THAT THE FACT
THAT MENTAL HEALTH THE ISSUES
CAN PERCENT REAL AND IMMEDIATE
SAFETY CONCERNS FOR THE STUDENT
AND FOR STUDENTS AROUND THEM.
ADDITIONALLY ON ALL OF OUR
CAMPUSES STUDENT FEES ARE USED
TO PAY FOR THESE RESOURCES THIS
MEANS THAT.
THE MOST OBVIOUS WAY TO EXPAND
RESOURCES ON CAMPUSES WITHOUT
THE SUPPORT OF THE STATE THERE'S
SB SIX SIXTY IS TO INCREASE
THESE CAMPUS BASED FEES WHICH
SOMEOF OUR STUDENTS ON ON ON
SOME OF OUR CAMPUSES ARE FORCED
TO CONSIDER.
GIVING KIND OF THE RATIO THAT WE
HAVE TODAY.
BUT THIS REALLY ONLY COMPOUNDS
THE CYCLE OF AFFORDABILITY
MENTAL HEALTH CHALLENGES
STUDENTS ARE STRUGGLING WITH
THEIR TOTAL COST OF ATTENDANCE
TUITION FEES HOUSING BOOKS FOOD.
THE ONLY FILL A SOLUTION -- FOR
WITH RESPECT TO MENTAL HEALTH
THIS EXACERBATE ONE ISSUE
AFFORDABILITY TO SOLVE ANOTHER
MENTAL HEALTH. FOR US THAT'S NOT
A SOLUTION DAHLE.
FINALLY FOR OUR STUDENTS THE
ISSUE OF MENTAL HEALTH IS ABOUT
PRIORITIES.
IN THIS CASE -- PRIORITY MEANS
FINDING AN ADVOCACY.
SINCE OUR PRIORITIZE THIS ISSUE
THROUGH INCREASING THEIR OWN
CAMPUS BASED FEES TO PAY FOR
MORE RESOURCES FACULTY HAVE
PRIORITIZE THIS ISSUE BY
SPONSORING THIS BILL IN
ADVOCATING ON THIS ISSUE.
WERE URGING -- YOU ALL THE
LEGISLATURE AS WELL AS THE CSU
TO PRIORITIZE THIS ISSUE AS WELL
WE URGE AYE VOTE TODAY.
THANK YOU.
OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH I THINK
WE MAY HAVE -- COR ROOMS SO A
CLICK AHEAD THIS DEVILISH OUR
CORE.
MEDINA CHOI HERE ARAMBULA
[inaudible]
BLOOM.
GABRIEL -- WHEN [inaudible]
KILEY [inaudible]
LEVINE [inaudible]
LOW [inaudible]
PATTERSON.
SANTIAGO WEBER.
YEAH OKAY NOW WE'RE MOVEON ON TO
ANY WITNESSES SO IN OPPOSITION
YOU CAN COME FOR DAVE HIP IN A
PRESENTATION TO MAKE.
SUPPORT THE I'M SORRY THIS IDEA
OR THE SUPPORT -- MEMBERS OF
FROM THE AUDIENCE OF FOUR HAD
THE SUPPORT MEMBERS THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN VERS MITCH
SNIDER WITH CALIFORNIA LABOR
FEDERATION ALSO IN SUPPORT.
CHECK OF REAGAN NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORK IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
VIDEO BORN AMERICAN ACADEMY OF
PEDIATRICS AND SUPPORT.
MARIO CAREER ON THE HAVE THE
CALIFORNIA FACULTY ASSOCIATION --
THE WHEN A CO SPONSOR OF THE
BILL JUST WANT TO POINT OUT THAT
THERE'S TWENTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS IN LAST YEAR'S BUDGET
THIRTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS IN
THIS YEAR'S BUDGET TO HIRE
TENURE TRACK FACULTY.
THAT MONEY CAN BE USED TO HIRE
THE COUNSELORS THANK YOU IN
SUPPORT.
KATHLEEN SAYING -- ALUMNI OF UC
BERKELEY AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT.
RACHEL GARBO ALUMNI FROM KAPALI
SOON THIS THE BEST PHONE I
STRONGLY SUPPORT.
MICHELLE A MONICA RESPECT LIFE
SPEAKER I STRONGLY SUPPORT.
RANDY FIELD ALLEY AT A LOT OF UC
BERKELEY IN SUPPORT THANK YOU --
A DIVA CON ALUMNI OF UC BERKELEY
AND STRONG SUPPORT.
AWESOME GENERAL CAL STATE
FULLERTON A STRONG SPORTS BILL.
MORE SO HOW TO SHOW STUDENT NAY
A UC RIVERSIDE DIAGNOSED WITH A
CHRONIC MENTAL ILLNESS IN
TRANSPORT.
I'M AND THINGS DIDN'T AT SIERRA
COLLEGE IN STRONG SUPPORT.
IN TWO WORKED AT THE UNIVERSITY
OF CALIFORNIA IN AT THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
RIVERSIDE IN STRONG SUPPORT.
I'M A CIRCUIT HERE DO STUDENT
BODY PRESIDENT UC BERKELEY
STRONG SUPPORT.
IS A FIREBALL FROM UC BERKELEY
IN STRONG SUPPORT.
MORGAN OF DARTMOUTH COLLEGE
TRONG SUPPORT.
THE UNLESS STATE UC BERKELEY IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
GOT THEM ALL YESTERDAY AT UC I
STRONGLY SUPPORT.
LIVVIE BENEDICT UCLA ALARM IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
ALEXANDER COULD CATCH A CITY
CALLED TRANSIT SAN FRANCISCO ON
US -- FOR LIFE SAN FRANCISCO
INSTRUCTOR.
FATIMA OAKLEAF UC BERKELEY IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
OKAY NOW ANY.
OPPOSITION WITNESSES.
IF YOU HAVE BEEN IN PRESENTATION
TO MAKE YOU CAN FOR COME.
FOR OKAY YOU CAN THIS IS STATE
YOUR NAMES AND THEY HAVE A TOTAL
FOUR MINUTES TOGETHER.
WONDERFUL THANK YOU.
HI HI GOOD AFTERNOON AYE MAGGIE
WHITE WITH THE CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY SYSTEM.
WELL WE APPRECIATE THE SANDERS
ATTENTION TO THE ISSUE OF MENTAL
HEALTH WE ARE IN OPPOSITION TO
THIS BILL FOR TWO PRIMARY
REASONS.
FIRST TO UNDERMINES THE
AUTHORITY OF OUR BOARD OF
TRUSTEES INCITING POLICY IN
ALLOCATING RESOURCES AS IT
BELIEVES ARE BEST SERVE CSU
STUDENTS.
SECONDLY WHILE ONE ON ONE
COUNSELING IS OBVIOUSLY AN
IMPORTANT COMPONENT EVER MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES OUR CAMPUSES ARE
GOING BEYOND THIS TO
INNOVATIVELY ADDRESS THE NEEDS
OF STUDENTS.
AND PARTICULARLY THOSE ARE
UNLIKELY TO SELF SELECT AND IS
SEEKING ASSISTANCE WITH THEIR
MENTAL HEALTH.
REQUIRING THAT WE USE OUR
LIMITED RESOURCES TO MEET
STATUTORY EMPLOYMENT RATIOS
COULD HAVE THE UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCE OF UNDERMINING
SUCCESSFUL STRATEGIES CURRENTLY
IN PLACE ON OUR CAMPUSES.
THIS ONE TO FIFTEEN HUNDRED
RATIOS AN ASPIRATIONAL GOAL THAT
WAS ESTABLISHED MANY YEARS AGO
AND IS NOT BACKED UP BY RESEARCH
OR DATA.
MENTAL HEALTH IS AN EXTREMELY
HIGH PRIORITY FOR CSU BOARD OF
TRUSTEES AND I DO NOT WANT THERE
TO BE ANY CONFUSION REGARDING
THE NATURE OF OUR POSITION.
WE FULLY BELIEVE AND PROVIDING
THIS SERVICE TO STUDENTS IS ONE
OF SIX PILLARS OF OUR GRADUATION
A SHIP TWENTY TWENTY FIVE AND
REACHING AND HELPING EVERYONE IN
NEED AS A TOP PRIORITY FOR OUR
SYSTEM.
WITH ME TODAY IS DOCTOR JOYCE
DIVERT JAMES ASSOCIATE VICE
PRESIDENT OF STUDENT HEALTH AND
COUNSELLING SERVICES AT
SACRAMENTO STATE. TO SPEAK ABOUT
THE VARIETY OF PROGRAMS THAT HER
STAFF FOR PROVIDING TO STUDENTS.
THANK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON AND
THANK YOU FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY
TO SPEAK TO YOU.
ABOUT THE MENTAL HEALTH CAN
DISCERN OF OUR STUDENTS AND HOW
WE'RE ADDRESSING THOSE.
WE'VE TAKEN A COMPREHENSIVE
APPROACH TO STUDENT MENTAL
HEALTH AND SUICIDE PREVENTION.
WE'RE FOCUSED ON PREVENTION
EARLY INTERVENTION AND INCREASED
ACCESS TO SERVICES.
IN TWO THOUSAND AND EIGHT WE HAD
FOURTEEN TENURE TRACK FACULTY
COUNSELORS AND WE SAW ROUGHLY 3%
OF OUR STUDENT POPULATION.
IN INDIVIDUAL COUNSELING
SESSIONS WE OFFERED NO OUT REACH
NO SUICIDE AWARENESS TRAINING NO
GROUP THERAPY WE HAD AN ON GOING
WAIT LIST FOR INDIVIDUAL
COUNSELING.
TODAY WE HAVE FOURTEEN
COUNSELORS IN A FULLY INTEGRATED
HEALTH AND MENTAL HEALTH CENTER
WE SEE 7210% OF OUR STUDENT
POPULATION.
WE PREVENTED EE SCREEN FOR
DEPRESSION DURING OUR HEALTH
CENTER VISITS WE OFFER URGENT
CARE COUNSELING SAME DAY IN
TAKES.
SUICIDE AWARENESS TRAINING
WELLNESS IN THE CLASSROOM
STUDENT CLUBS PEER HEALTH
EDUCATORS SATELLITE COUNSELING
OFFICES.
EVENING HOURS SINGLE SESSION
VISITS AN INDIVIDUAL AND GROUP
COUNSELING.
IT'S A IT'S COMMON TO HEAR WE
NEED TO HIRE ADDITIONAL STAFF
SIMPLY ADDING MORE COUNSELORS
ISN'T ALWAYS THE BEST WAY TO
IMPROVE QUALITY CARE OR IMPROVE
ACCESS.
THERE ARE MANY APPROACHES
CAMPUSES CAN TAKE TO MEET
SERVICE DEMANDS.
AND BUILD CAPACITY.
CAMPUSES ACROSS THE COUNTRY ARE
DEVELOPING CREATIVE INNOVATIVE
SERVICE DELIVERY MODELS THAT
MEET THE UNIQUE NEEDS OF THE
STUDENTS.
THIS FALL WERE PLANNING TO
DEVELOP A PEER COUNSELING
PROGRAM ON OUR CAMPUS WE'VE
HEARD FROM OUR STUDENTS HOW
IMPORTANT MENTAL HEALTH PEER
SUPPORT IS.
A RECENT REPORT FROM NAMI THE
NATIONAL ALLIANCE ON MENTAL
ILLNESS SURVEYED STUDENTS LIVING
WITH MENTAL HEALTH CONDITIONS
AND FOUND THAT 42% OF THE
STUDENTS STATED.
THAT MENTAL HEALTH PEER SUPPORT
SERVICES AND STUDENT CLUBS IS
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT TO THEIR
SUPPORT IN COLLEGE.
ADDITIONALLY WE NEED TO INCREASE
STUDENT HELP SEEKING A
SIGNIFICANT NUMBER OF DISTRESS
DUNES TO NOT SEEK HELP FROM
MENTAL HEALTH PROVIDERS.
CAMPUSES ARE USING MANY
DIFFERENT STRATEGIES TO OVERCOME
THE BARRIERS TO HELP SEEKING.
IDENTIFYING STUDENTS AT RISK IS
NOT LIMITED TO MENTAL HEALTH
PROFESSIONALS ON A DAILY BASIS
OUR STUDENTS COME INTO CONTACT
WITH FACULTY STAFF RESIDENT HALL
ADVISORS COACHES SUCCESSOR.
SCREENING FOR DEPRESSION DURING
PRIMARY CARE MEDICAL VISITS AND
OFFERING GATEKEEPER TRAINING
TRAINING AND MENTAL HEALTH FOR
STATE TO FACULTY AND STAFF ARE
JUST A FEW OF THE STRATEGIES
THAT CAMPUSES ARE EMPLOYING.
A YOU SEE CD THE ASSOCIATION FOR
UNIVERSITY COUNSELLING CENTER
DIRECTORS RECENTLY OFFERED A NEW
METRIC THAT MAY BE MORE USEFUL
THAN THE OFTEN QUOTED ONE TO
FIFTEEN HUNDRED STAFFING MODEL.
THE NEW METRIC PROPOSES ONE
HUNDRED A HUNDRED AND TWENTY
STUDENT CLIENTS PER ONE FULL
TIME COUNSELORS THAT ARE
ACTUALLY RECEIVING TREATMENT AND
COUNSELING.
THIS IS BASED ON YEARS OF COP
COLLEGE COUNSELING UTILIZATION
DATA.
I AM NOT AWARE OF ANY RESEARCH
THAT SUPPORTS THE ONE TO FIFTEEN
HUNDRED STAFFING MODEL.
WE FULLY AGREE WITH THE NEED FOR
MORE FUNDING AND MORE ATTENTION
TO MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES WE
NEED TO INVEST IN COMPREHENSIVE
APPROACH IS TO MENTAL HEALTH
PROMOTION.
AND SUICIDE PREVENTION IN
ADDITION TO ENSURING ACCESS TO
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES OTHER
INVESTMENTS.
SHOULD INCLUDE SUICIDE
PREVENTION EDUCATION AND
AWARENESS PROGRAMS PEER SUPPORT
PROGRAMS RISK FACTOR SCREENINGS
TECHNOLOGY BASED SERVICES
FACULTY STAFF TRAINING AND
CURRICULUM BASED PROGRAMS IN THE
CLASSROOM. FOR STUDENTS WITH
CHRONIC OR SEVERE MENTAL HEALTH
ISSUES OUR PARTNERSHIPS WITH
COUNTIES AND OTHER COMMUNITY
RESOURCES ARE ESSENTIAL.
CAMPUSES ARE DEVELOPING WORKING
RELATIONSHIPS WITH OUR LOCAL
COMMUNITY RESOURCES. TO CONNECT
STUDENTS TO PROVIDERS THAT WILL
BE THERE TO SET THEM UP FOR ON
GOING SUCCESS AFTER THEY
GRADUATE.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME I URGE
YOU TO MAKE MEANINGFUL AND
EFFECTIVE INVESTMENTS IN OUR
STUDENTS MENTAL HEALTH.
I'M HERE TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU ANY OF THE OPPOSITION.
MEMBER SMALL GROUPS -- THEN YOU
CAN COME TO A MICROPHONE
[inaudible]
OKAY -- ALL RIGHT.
YOU CAN WALK UP. TO THE
MICROPHONE OKAY STATE YOUR NAME
AN ORGANIZATION AND YOUR
POSITION.
ALL RIGHT MY NAME IS AMBER AMERO
I AM A STUDENT AT FRESNO STATE
UNIVERSITY WITH STUDENTS FOR
LIFE AT FRESNO STATE AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
THANK YOU IN THE OTHER.
ANY OTHER MEMBERS SUPPOSE IN
OPPOSITION NO IT WAS JUST ME
THAT TO HAVE AN OPINION ARE ALL
RIGHT THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
AND WHEN I TURN TO OUR COMMITTEE
MEMBERS FOR ANY QUESTIONS SO OR
STATEMENTS.
I I MISSED YOUR INTERACTION SOME
SORT OF YOU COVERED THIS BUT
HE'S RESPONDED THAT CONCERN
RAISED BY THE OPPOSITION IS TO
THERE BEING NO RESEARCH TO BACK
UP FIFTEEN HUNDRED ONE IS SORT
OF AN IDEAL RATIO YEAH.
SOME WE ACTUALLY QUITE
DISAPPOINTED THAT -- CSE WOULD
CLAIM THERE IS NO RESEARCH ARE
NO EVIDENCE. TO TO BACK UP THIS
RATIO ACTUALLY THIS RATIO COMES
IN INTERNATIONAL ASSOCIATION
COUNSELING SERVICES ACTUALLY
THIS IS THE UPPER END OF THE
RATIO THAT SHE HAD A RANGE
FIFTEEN HUNDRED THE UPPER AND
BUT I THINK IF YOU HEAR FROM THE
STEWED WITNESSES.
WHO CAME IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL
THEY RECOGNIZE THERE'S A PROBLEM?
SO CERTAINLY YES WE WANT TO USE
A VARIETY OF DIFFERENT
APPROACHES FOR SINCE I'VE HAD
THE THE THE THE THE PRIVILEGE OF
BEING ABLE TO VISIT SACKS STATE
AND THEIR FACILITIES AND SO
FORTH -- AND I WOULD BUT I WOULD
ALSO NOTES HEARING FROM STUDENTS --
THAT -- THEY DO NOT FEEL LIKE
THEY HAVE TIMELY ACCESS THAT WE
TALK ABOUT THE FACT THAT
STUDENTS.
OFTEN ARE DON'T WANT TO COME
FORWARD MENTAL HEALTH PART OF
ITS STAKE MOTHER PART OF IT IS
THEY KNOW WHEN THEY COME FORWARD
THEY DON'T GET HELP.
NOW I APPRECIATE THAT
PARTICULARLY ATTACKS STATE THEY
HAVE COME UP WITH THE SYSTEM TO
TRY TO GET THOSE STUDENTS AND
FIRST AND EARLY AS SOON AS THEY
SHOW UP.
AND THAT CERTAINLY WOULD LIKE TO
SEE AN ALL OF THE CSU CAMPUSES
HOWEVER I WOULD POINT OUT THAT --
THERE'S CLEARLY A NEED FOR FOR
MORE -- SERVICES THAT ARE.
AVAILABLE AND I THINK WHEN YOU
THINK ABOUT THE RATE OF OF THE
MENTAL HEALTH CONDITIONS IN
COLLEGE STUDENTS COMPARED.
TO YEAH WE THINK ABOUT ONE IN
FIFTEEN HUNDRED I MEAN YOU START
THINKING ABOUT HOW MUCH YEAH
YEAH.
WITH THE KIND OF NOW THEY COULD
YES THEY COULD HAVE SECURE
SUPPORT THEY CAN HELP WITH THAT.
AND THAT'S GOING TO BE HELP IN
THAT WILL STRETCH THAT WILL
PROVIDE SOME SUPPORT AND SO
FORTH BUT YOU THINK ABOUT WHAT
KIND OF WAITING TIME THAT MEANS
THAT A COUNSELOR WE FOR FROM
COUNSELOR HERE.
BUT THAT REALLY MEANS IF THEY
ACTUALLY HAVE FIFTEEN HUNDRED
STUDENTS AND THINK ABOUT THE
PERCENTAGE OF THOSE THAT WILL
HAVE MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES --
THAT PIERRE AND AND SO EVEN IF
THEY CAN REFER SOMEBODY COUNTY
AND BY THE WAY -- THAT'S A
LITTLE BIT THE CHALLENGE --
BECAUSE COUNTY MENTAL HEALTH THE
SOMEONE WHO ACTUALLY OVERSEAS.
ARE MEDI CAL MENTAL HEALTH
SYSTEM OVER BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE
WELL WHAT YOU WHICH COUNTY DO
YOU ACTUALLY LIVE AND WHICH
COUNTY MENTAL HEALTH SYSTEM DO A
SEND YOU TO BECAUSE THE ONE
YOU'RE AND MAY NOT NECESSARILY
BECAUSEYOU'RE NOT RESIDENT OF
IT CETERA.
SO I MEAN THERE'S A WHOLE BUNCH
OF BABY IF CHALLENGES SO.
AT THAT POINT OUT THIS BILL SUCH
AS THE GOAL.
I MEAN I AND AND I THINK THAT WE
HEAR FROM THE STUDENTS THEY
DON'T HAVE ENOUGH ACCESS.
WE SET A GOAL WE WANT DATA.
I THINK THAT'S PRETTY REASONABLE
TO ASK OF THE CSU SYSTEM AND I
AND AND SO YOU KNOW I WANT TO
WORK WITH THEM -- I I DON'T I I
HAVE MET I AM NOT SO HAPPY TO
HEAR.
THAT TESTIMONY SAYS THERE'S NO
EVIDENCE AS SOMEONE WHO'S
DEFERENCE AND DATA DRIVEN I
THINK I HAVE -- THAT -- AND SO
WHEN YOU DID WORKFORCE RESEARCH
BEFORE PRIOR TO COMING EMILY THE
OTHER INSTITUTION UNIVERSITY
CALIFORNIA.
I THINK I TRY TO TAKE DATA AND
AND AND AND VERY SERIOUSLY SO --
YOU KNOW WE CAN HAVE DIFFERENCES
OF OPINION THAT'S FINE BUT
PLEASE DON'T SAY THAT I DON'T
HAVE ANY DATA BEHIND THE BILL
THANK YOU.
THANKS AND HAVE THAT COMMUNITY
COLLEGES WAITING BECAUSE IT
LOOKS LIKE THEY HAVE -- ONE THE
SEVEN THOUSAND RATIO NOW SO THAT
AFTER WHAT THE LEAST QUADRUPLE
THE NUMBER OF OF COUNSELORS AND
HAVE FEASIBLE THAT MY ME.
WELL I THINK YEAH AGAIN THAT'S
THAT THAT IS WHAT OUR BIGGEST
CHALLENGE SO.
IN FACT ACTUALLY WE SEE YOUR IS
THAT CALIFORNIA'S CURRENTLY AT
1-210-005-0050 SIX AND FACT
APPRECIATE THE GOVERNOR GAVE
THEM SOME ADDITIONAL SUPPORT FOR
THEIR FOR MENTAL HEALTH THERE.
SEE IF YOU WERE AT ROUND
1-210-001-0009 HUNDRED SEVENTY
NINE IT'S ALMOST ONE TO TWO
THOUSAND AND E DON'T HAVE DATA --
FOR THE COMMITTEE COLLEGES BUT
YOU'RE RIGHT.
XIN IS A COMMITTEE COLLEGES EVEN
FARTHER BEHIND SO WE DO SET
THESE GOALS AND THE CURRENT
VERSION THE BILL AND I THINK WE
NEED TO BETTER DEFINE THE
PROBLEM AND AND THEN -- AND
COLLECT DATA AND THEN SEE WHAT
KIND OF POLICY SOLUTIONS WE WILL
MAKE AND OF COURSE YOU KNOW
THROUGH WHETHER THROUGH
LEGISLATION OF THE BUDGET
PROCESS HOW WE CAN GET THOSE
RESOURCES.
THANK YOU THANK YOU SENATOR.
I WILL BE SUPPORTING BUT THEY
HAVE A COUPLE OF CLARIFICATIONS
ON A MAKE US.
THANK YOU.
SINCE THE CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE OF
A CSU.
OF OPPOSE AND STATING THAT THAT
THEY ARE DOING [inaudible]
WHILE.
WHAT THE WAS THE -- MOTIVATION
WHEN YOU.
HAD TO A PROPOSED THIS BE OUR
WAS THERE ANY -- OUT CRYING --
STUDENT BODY WE NEED MORE
COUNSELORS SO WAS IN THE RECENT
OF US -- NUMBER ONE QUESTION AND
THEN I KNOW THIS IS A POLICY
COMMITTEE BUT THE HAVE YOU.
CONSIDERED THE NUMBERS TO NEEDY
TELL WHETHER THIS WOULD BE WHAT --
OUT OF THE OLD BUDGET OR THE
SEPARATE BUDGET PROPOSED TO IS
THAT YOUR INTENT.
SO AGAIN AS I MENTIONED THAT --
AFTER WENT THROUGH PREPARATIONS
IN THE SENATE WE ESTABLISHING
THIS IS A CALL WE ALSO WANT SOME
DATA COLLECTION WE WANT I WANT
TO WORK WITH -- THE CSU TRUSTEES
AND CHANCELLORS THAT CERTAINLY
IS A SOMEONE WHO USED TO BE A
FACULTY MEMBER CERTAINLY
UNDERSTAND THE UNIVERSITY
GOVERNANCE.
BUT I THINK ALSO WHERE HE SAID
THAT WHEN IT COMES TO THE BILL
WE'RE HEARING FROM STUDENTS WERE
HEARING FROM FACULTY OR TEACHING
STUDENTS THEY'RE SEEING STUDENTS
STRUGGLE.
THEY NOTE THAT THE STRUGGLE IS
DUE TO MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES AND
THERE ARE FINE YEAH HEARING FROM
THE STUDENTS THAT -- THEY'RE
HAVING TROUBLE ACCESSING THE
SERVICES AT SOME AT MANY
CAMPUSES AND WE'RE HEARING FROM
STUDENTS AND YOU SAW WE SAW ALL
THE STUDENTS TESTIFYING SAID
THEY SUPPORT THE BILL SO --
LET'S LISTEN TO THE STUDENTS
LET'S LISTEN TO THE FACULTY.
LET'S SET A GOAL IS COLLECTED
DATA LET'S WORK WITH THEIR
UNIVERSITIES AND TRY TO BE SURE
WE GET THEM ACCESS TO THE MATH
HELP THEY NEED BECAUSE WE DON'T
WANT STUDENTS DROPPING OUT WE
DON'T STUDENTS NOT ABLE TO
GRADUATE NOT ABLE TO COMPLETE
THEIR COURSES ARE PASSED THE
COURSES.
BECAUSE THEY HAVE UNMET MENTAL
HEALTH NEEDS I MEAN THAT'S THE
LOS THAT'S HAPPENING TO OUR
CAMPUSES AND EVENTUALLY THAT
MEANS TO OUR STATE WHEN THAT
HAPPENS.
DO HAVE BEEN ABOARD PROP UP
FIGURE HOW MUCH HEARERS TAKE TO
IMPLEMENT YOU YOU ARE NOT OF THE
TARGET NUMBER.
FIFTEEN HUNDRED WELL CERTAINLY
IF HE SAID THAT WE SET THAT AS A
GOAL -- SO.
IT'S A AND IN TERMS OF THE SO IT
CERTAINLY IS A GOAL THERE'S NOT
REQUIREMENTS -- AND SO IN THAT
SENSE WE DON'T HAVE THE FISCAL
ASSOCIATE WITH THE RECORD NOW
WITH THAT BEING A REQUIREMENT
IT'S MAINLY FOR THE DATA
COLLECTION OKAY THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS WHEN THE
MEMBERS.
ARE A DOCTOR OR A MEMBER OF I
JUST WANTED TO ECHO THE COMMENT
I BELIEVE OF DOCTOR WALLACE THE
GOAL IS TO PROVIDE COUNSELING
SERVICES AND NOT CRISIS SERVICES.
AND THE ASPIRATIONAL GOAL THAT
YOU'VE SET FOR CS USE WILL ALLOW
US TO GET TO A POINT.
TO DO THE EARLY INTERVENTIONS
AND PREVENTIONS THAT YOU WERE
SPEAKING ABOUT.
AND I ENCOURAGE THE CS USED TO
PARTICIPATE AND LOOK FORWARD TO
THIS PASSAGE.
OKAY MOTION HAS BEEN MADE BY A
DOCTOR ARAMBULA IN THE NINE
SECONDED.
AND THE CLOAK GO YOU LOCAL
SCHOOL.
THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
MEDINA.
CHOI AYE CHOI I -ARAMBULA.
ARAMBULA I BLOOM.
BLOOM I GABRIEL.
GABRIEL I IRWIN.
IRWIN I KILEY.
KILEY NOT VOTING LEVINE.
LOW.
LOW I PATTERSON.
PATTERSON I SANTIAGO WEBER.
SEVEN ZERO OF THE BILL ITSELF.
THANK YOU THANKS VERY MUCH OKAY.
THANK YOU DOCTOR PAN
[inaudible]
WHICH NUMBER.
OKAY IS SENATOR A THAT'S OKAY --
OKAY GO AHEAD.
ALSO.
WHICH WAY FOR THE WHICH NUMBERS
THAT.
LATER THAT DAY I HAVE
[inaudible]
TO WE WANT.
YOU GUYS ARE WHICH ONE SENATOR
ABREAST FOOLED.
FILE NUMBER SIX AS BEFORE. TWO
SIX AND IF ANYONE MIND I MISSED
YOUR WE'RE GONNA START WITH FIVE
SEVEN FIVE OKAY FIVE SEVEN FIVE
A NUMBER TWELVE MISTER MISTER
VICE YOUR MESSAGE JUST QUIT
POINT OF CLARIFICATION JUST ON
THE I UNDERSTAND THAT -- OF THE
BILL'S TODAY THAT WE STILL HAVE
ADDITIONAL TEN TEN BILLS AND UP
AND WE'VE ALREADY BEEN ABOUT AN
HOUR AND FIFTEEN IS THAT
ACCURATE THAT WERE JUST ABOUT
WITH TEN BILLS AGO APPROXIMATELY.
YEAH THERE WAS A TOTAL OF
FOURTEEN BEYONCE OF THE OKAY
FIFTY ISN'T HAS BEEN DRIVE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH.
OKAY GO AHEAD THE SENATOR.
YEAH THANK YOU.
AND FIRST LET ME THINK OCT
SENATOR LABOR FOR YOUR DINNER
TIME AND I'M GOING TO MAKE THIS
PRESENTATION VERY BRIEF --
NELSON MANDELA OFTEN STATED THE
MOST POWERFUL WEAPONS CHANGE THE
WORLD IS TO EDUCATION SO WE AS
LEGISLATORS MUCH AFTER CELLS
WHAT ARE TRULY COMMITMENT IS.
AS POLICY MAKERS WE SHOULD ALSO
ALWAYS OUT ANSWER YES AND AGAIN
AND DANCERS YES THEN WE MUST ASK
WHY WE BàN CAL GRANT FOR THOSE
WHO ARE INCARCERATED THIS BILL
IS ABOUT PROVIDING CAL GRANT.
FOR INCARCERATED INDIVIDUALS
HERE IN STATE CALIFORNIA SB FIVE
SOME FIVE REMOVED OUTDATED
BARRIERS AND EXPANDS ACCESS TO
POSTSECONDARY DUCATION
OPPORTUNITY TO INCARCERATED
STUDENTS.
TO THE SECOND CHANCE GRANT WHILE
SUPPORTING AFFECT THE
REHABILITATION EFFORTS WITH AND
OUR CORRECTIONS SYSTEM I'M GOING
TO YIELD THE BALANCE OF MY TIME
TO MY TWO WITNESSES AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
ANY WITNESS YES GOOD AFTERNOON --
MY NAME IS STEPHANIE LAMB I AM
THE SENIOR DIRECTOR FOR THE
CENTER FOR ENGAGEMENT SERVICE
AND THE PUBLIC GOOD AT CAL STATE
LA.
CAL STATE LA IS THE ONLY
UNIVERSITY IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THAT OFFERS A FACE TO
FACE BACHELOR'S DEGREE PROGRAM
FOR INCARCERATED STUDENTS.
WE CURRENTLY OFFER A PROGRAM TO
TWO COHORTS OF ABOUT FORTY FIVE
STUDENTS TOTAL AT LANCASTER
STATE PRISON -- I'M HERE TO TELL
YOU THAT WE BELIEVE
WHOLEHEARTEDLY SINCE WE BEGAN
THIS PROGRAM IN LATE TWO
THOUSAND AND FOURTEEN THAT
EDUCATION WORKS WE SEE THAT IT
WORKS WITH OUR STUDENTS OUR
STUDENTS RECEIVE THE SAME
EDUCATION THAT THEY WOULD ON THE
MAIN CAMPUS THE SAME.
TENURE TRACK FACULTY THE SAME
CLASSES AND OUR STUDENTS INSIDE
OUR ROOM HAVE HIGHER GPAS
CUMULATIVE GPA IS THAT OUR
STUDENTS ON THE MAIN CAMPUS.
WE ALSO KNOW THAT OUR STUDENTS
WHO ARE A PART OF THIS PROGRAM --
GO ON AND CAN CONTINUE THEIR
EDUCATION AND HAVE GAINFUL
EMPLOYMENT AFTERWARDS.
OF OUR FORTY FIVE STUDENTS THREE
OF THEM HAVE HAD THEIR SENTENCES
COMMUTED AND ARE CURRENTLY
FINISHING THEIR DEGREES ON THE
CAL STATE LA MAIN CAMPUS.
AND ARE SCHEDULED TO GRADUATE --
WITH DEGREES IN COMMUNICATIONS
BY THE END OF DECEMBER OF TWO
THOUSAND AND NINETEEN AND LASTLY
WE SEE THAT THESE -- STUDENTS
INSPIRE AND MOTIVATE OTHER
INDIVIDUALS OF TO ALSO PURSUE AN
EDUCATION THAT'S BREAKING THE
CYCLE OF INTERGENERATIONAL
INCARCERATION THEY INSPIRE THEIR
FELLOW YARD BATES THEY INSPIRE
EACH OTHER AND THE INSPIRE THEIR
FRIENDS AND THEIR FAMILY TO
CONTINUE TO PURSUE AN EDUCATION.
CAL DAILIES PROGRAM IS CURRENTLY
A SECOND CHANCE PAUL OF PILOT
SITE AND WE RECEIVED PRIVATE
FOUNDATION FUNDING.
AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO
ADDITIONAL SUPPORT THANK YOU.
ADDITIONAL STATEMENT.
I MEAN THE WITNESS.
HELLO HI -- JEFF STEIN I'M A
FORMERLY INCARCERATED PERSON
THAT THE HOMES ABOUT TO GRADUATE
IN DECEMBER WITH A BACHELOR'S
DEGREE IN ORGANIZATIONAL
COMMUNICATION.
ON FOR SOMEONE WHO WAS GIVEN
THAT.
WE ALL UNDERSTAND IT'S A ONCE IN
A LIFETIME DESTINY ALTERING
OPPORTUNITY.
AND THAT CHANGES ME AS AN
INDIVIDUAL THE OTHER STUDENTS AT
A THAT I TOOK COURSES WITH.
I SEEN IT CHANGE FAMILIES IN IT
THAT DID PUT A STOP TO THE
INTERGENERATIONAL ON CRIMINALITY
BECAUSE NET NOW YOU'RE HAVING A
RIPPLE EFFECT ON I SEE HOW THAT
CAN HELP SOCIETY.
AND I'VE JUST HAD A SUPPORT
NETWORK WITH THE UNIVERSITY
PROJECT REBOUND ASL HOMES AN ARC
[inaudible]
AND SHE NOW THAT I GOT MYSELF
TOGETHER AND I'M ON THAT LIFE
PATH I GET LETTERS EVERY DAY
FROM.
WOMEN AND MEN WHO ARE ASKING FOR
HELP TO GET ON THE SAME LIFE
PATH.
AND I SEE HOW THAT'LL MAKE
SOCIETY SAVER AND INCREASE THE
PRODUCTIVITY OF THE STATE
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON BRANDON BIGGER
WITH THE CALIFORNIA STUDENT A
COMMISSION WEREN'T STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
CHECK OF RECORD NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORK
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
I MANAGE WORK AND YOU HAVE A SAY
OF CALIFORNIANS STRONG SUPPORT.
KATHLEEN SAYING GRADUATE OF UC
BERKELEY AND STRONG SUPPORT.
SELENA PRIOR CALIFORNIA STATE
AND DOUBLE ACP AND SUPPORT.
MICHELLE MONICA RESPECT LIKE
SPEAKER I'M IN STRONG SUPPORT.
I AM AND SANG SITTING AT SIERRA
COLLEGE IN STRONG SUPPORT.
ON A CIRCUIT HERE DO STUDENT
BODY PRESIDENT UC BERKELEY
STRONG SUPPORT.
IS A FIREBALL UC BERKELEY IN
WILLIAM THE REALIST ANTI
RECIDIVISM COALITION STRONG
SUPPORT.
KAREN MILLER STUDENT CALIFORNIA
LIFTING UNIVERSITY STRONG
SUPPORT.
RACHEL GARBO CAL POLY SLOW LIME
IN STRONG SUPPORT.
I'M INTERESTED IN AND YOU SEE
RIVERSIDE IN STRONG SUPPORT.
EMILY MONTELLO TELFORD UCSB
ALONG NINE STRONG SUPPORT.
FELIPE AVAILABLE STUDENT AT UCSB
IN STRONG SUPPORT.
WHEN YOU'RE LIKE ALLOWS STUDENT
AT UC RIVERSIDE STRONG SUPPORT?
A ROBBIE.
ROBBIE A SON UC BERKELEY ALUMNI
IN STRONG SUPPORT.
MARSA HERSCHEL STUDENT AT UC
RIVERSIDE AND MEMBER OF
UNDERGROUND ALWAYS INITIATIVE
WHICH BUILDS A PRISON TO SCHOOL
PIPELINE AND TRANSPORT.
MORGAN LOVE ACCESS WOMEN HEALTH
JUSTICE STRONG SUPPORT.
EMILY YESTERDAY I YOU SEE OUR
STRONG SUPPORT.
IN GEORGIA STUDENT AT UC
RIVERSIDE IN STRONG SUPPORT.
SANDY HERNANDEZ STUDENT AT UC
RIVERSIDE A STRONG SUPPORT.
VANESSA BLAYLOCK'S AT PITZER
COLLEGE STRONG SUPPORT.
ANDY FIELD ALLEY AT UC BERKELEY
ELEVEN SUPPORT.
IF YOU'RE A COMMA ALARM OF UC
BERKELEY AND FORMER GT TUTOR AT
SAN QUENTIN STATE PRISON IN
SUPPORT.
EMILY MARTINEZ SAID IN A YOU SEE
ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT.
NUMBER SEVEN CENTS SHOULD AN
ISSUE RIVERSIDE IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
RACHEL CODE ACCESS WOMEN'S
HEALTH JUSTICE STRONG SUPPORT.
LIBBY BENEDICT UCLA ALARM IN THE
LAST STUDENT ENROLLED IN THE
SCHOOL OF CRIMINOLOGY UCLA IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
THE FEAR MANAGER FROM THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
RIVERSIDE IN STRONG SUPPORT.
BRIAN CARROLL ON THE STATE
COMMITTEE OF THE AMERICAN
SOLIDARITY PARTY IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
ASCENSION STUDENT COSTS A
FORTUNE A STRONG SUPPORT THIS
BILL.
IN ADDITION UC BERKELEY ALARM IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
SERRA SHINES UNIT UC BERKELEY IN
SANTIAGO CHEVY Là UC SANTA CRUZ
A LEMON STRONG SUPPORT.
SHERRI LEAVE FROM UC SANTA CRUZ
IN STRONG SUPPORT.
WHEN TENER STUDENT AT LOYOLA
MARYMOUNT UNIVERSITY STRONG
SUPPORT?
EDWIN PROCTOR REBOUNDS SECOND
STATE UNIVERSITY STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS BILL.
AS FUNDING IS WITH THE ANTI
RECIDIVISM COALITION WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS BILL.
GOVERNOR JOHNSON FROM PROJECT
REBOUND SACRAMENTO STATE STRUCK
ME STRONG SUPPORTER OF HI LE
CANTON PROJECT REBOUND
SACRAMENTO STATE STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS BILL.
ALL OF USE METER WITH THE UC
STUDENT ASSOCIATION WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT.
MARIO GUERRERO ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA FACULTY ASSOCIATION
SUPPORT -- ROBERT BYRD FROWN ON
CITY BECAUSE OF SAN FRANCISCO IN
SUPPORT.
AMBER AMERO AT FRESNO STATE
UNIVERSITY WITH STUDENTS FOR
LIFE IN STRONG SUPPORT.
LARA HUMANISTS CALIFORNIA
LETTING US REPRODUCTIVE JUSTICE
IN STRONG SUPPORT.
KATIE BLESSED PROJECT CHANGE
COLLEGES SAN MATTEO IN VERY
STRONG SUPPORT.
JACQUELINE RODRIGUEZ COLLEGE OF
SAN MATTEO PROJECT CHANGES
TRANSPORT.
MONEY MORALIS -- COLLEGES EMMA
TALE PROJECT CHANGE STRONG
SUPPORT.
NICK WAS JUST SO PROJECT CHAINS --
UCLA TRANSFER -- INSTRUCTS
SUPPORT.
ANY THEATERS COLLEGES SAN MATTEO
STAFF IN STRONG SUPPORT.
KILLING HENNESSY UC BERKELEY
ALSO IN STRONG SUPPORT.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE ANY QUESTIONS
COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
IT'S A NINE MR GABER.
I CENTER I JUST WANT TO THANK
YOU FOR ME FOR THIS BUT I THINK
IT'S AN IMPORTANT MEASURE IT'S
REALLY GOOD PUBLIC POLICY PLEASE
TO SUPPORT IT TOO AND I JUST
WANTED TO THANK YOUR WITNESS FOR
COMING BY AND FOR ADDING YOUR
VOICE TO THE CONVERSATION I
THINK YOU.
HAVE A REALLY POWERFUL ROLE TO
PLAY IN THIS WE APPRECIATE YOU --
YOUR THE COMMENTS THAT YOU MADE
TO THANK YOU FOR THAT THANK YOU
SO MUCH.
CENTER BRADFORD WOULD YOU LIKE
CLOSE YES I I WANT TO THANK ALL
THE WITNESSES CAME IN SUPPORT
AND ESPECIALLY MY WITNESSES
ESPECIALLY JEFF STEIN'S PERSONAL
STORY HE JUST TRUNCATED IT
BECAUSE OF THE TIME THAT WE'RE
HERE BUT IT'S A FANTASTIC STORY.
AND LAST WEEK WE CELEBRATED
SMALL BUSINESS AND MY SMALL
BUSINESS OWNER WAS AN INDIVIDUAL
WHO DID SEVEN YEARS INCARCERATED.
GOT IS EDUCATION WHILE
INCARCERATED IS COME OUT AND NOW
IS A SUCCESSFUL -- IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA SO I THINK THIS IS A
TESTAMENT WHAT THIS PELL GRANT
CAN DO WE INITIALLY OFFERED THIS
ON THE FEDERAL LEVEL IN NINETEEN
SIXTY FIVE AND JUST BECAUSE OF
OUR TOUGH ON CRIME.
STANCE OVER THE LAST FORTY YEARS
WE STOPPED -- ISSUE IN IT
PRESIDENT BARACK OBAMA SUPPORTED
IN TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN A SECOND
CHANCE PELL GRANTS PROGRAM SO I
THINK IT HAS PROOF OF THAT IT'S
WORTH -- ITS MERIT AND AND
MISTER STEIN IS A PRIME EXAMPLE
THAT IT WORKS ARE STRICTLY OUT
FOR YA VOTE.
I WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
BRING IN THE BILL FORWARD.
I WAS ACTUALLY A TUTOR AT THE
CALIFORNIA INSTITUTION FOR WOMEN.
WHEN I WAS A STUDENT AT UC
RIVERSIDE AS PART OF THE WOMEN'S
RESOURCE CENTER -- AFTER BEING A
TUTOR THERE.
I I BECAME A TEACHER AN ADULT
EDUCATION AT CALIFORNIA
INSTITUTION FOR WOMEN AT
FRONTERA.
AS A TEACHER THERE I SAW --
FIRST HAND THE POWER OF
EDUCATION -- TO MEN AND WOMEN
WHO HAVE BEEN INCARCERATED VERY
PROUD TO THAT WE HAVE BEEN
SUPPORT IN THE REBOUND PROGRAM --
THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND THE GOOD WORK
THAT THAT PROGRAM HAS DONE HAD
THE OPPORTUNITY TO VISIT -- SAN
DIEGO STATE TWO WEEKS AGO AND
SEEING THEIR THEIR PROGRAM THERE
SO I THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD.
WE HAVE A MOTION WE NEED A
SECOND.
THE MOTION BY MISTER BLOOM
SECOND BY DOCTOR RUMBULA --
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
MEDINA HI MEDINA I CHOI.
CHOI I ARAMBULA.
ARAMBULA I BLOOM.
BLOOM I GABRIEL.
GABRIEL I IRWIN -- WHEN I KILEY?
KILEY I LEVINE.
LOW.
LOW I PATTERSON [inaudible]
SANTIAGO WEBER [inaudible]
WEBER II. TEN ZERO YOUR BILL IS
OUT WE WILL LEAVE IT OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS THANK YOU I
APPRECIATE CHAMBER.
MEMBERS THANK YOU AND I'LL BE
ROBE BABRI FOR MY SECOND MEASURE --
SP -- FOUR TO SEVEN NOT FULL
DISCLOSURE [inaudible]
IS IT.
THE SECOND.
I RESPECT AS RIVAL.
YOU JUST MEDICAID IF YOU'RE
DOING.
ANYWAY THIS IS IN SUPPORT.
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
ANY WITNESSES AND OPPOSITION
[inaudible]
ANY WINNERS.
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
THE COMMITTEE [inaudible]
OF WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE I
WOULD JUST SIMPLY SAY -- SB
FORTY FOUR TO SEVEN IS TO DIE IN
THESE.
OUR FELLOWS PROGRAM WE ALL KNOW.
OF FORMER CONGRESSMAN FORMER
LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR FORMER STATE
CENTER FORMER SETTLEMENT MURDER
TIMES LEGACY ON CAL STATE
DOMINGUEZ HILLS WE ARE WITH
FALLS PROGRAM THIS WILL STOP
ALLOW YOUNG PEOPLE IN HIGH
SCHOOL -- TO BOT BUILD SKILLS
NECESSARY TO BE SUCCESSFUL NOT
ONLY IN COLLEGE BUT IN THE
COMMUNITY I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR VOTE.
THANK YOU WE HAD A MOTION BY
MISTER LOWE SECOND BY A DOCTOR
RUMBLE -- AND MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE MEDINA
HI MEDINA I CHOI.
CHOI NOT VOTING ARAMBULA.
ARAMBULA I BLOOM.
GABRIEL GABRIEL I IRWIN -- WHEN
I KILEY [inaudible]
LEVINE.
LOW LOW I PATTERSON SANTIAGO
WEBER.
WEBER I SIX ZERO WILL KEEP THAT
ON CALL FOR ABSENT MEMBRANE
COMMITTEE CHAIR COMMITTEE
MEMBERS AND MOST IMPORTANTLY
SENATOR LEYVA.
THANK YOU AND NEXT SO.
FILE ITEM.
TO SB TWENTY FOUR SENATOR LABOR
[inaudible]
SHARE.
GOOD AFTERNOON WELCOME THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT MISTER CHAIRMAN BURRS
FIRST I'D LIKE TO THINK YOU AND
YOUR COMMITTEE STAFF FOR YOUR
WORK ON THIS BILL IS MUCH
APPRECIATED.
IN NINETEEN SEVENTY THREE THE US
SUPREME COURT RULED THAT DUE
PROCESS THE DUE PROCESS CLAUSE
OF THE FOURTEENTH AMENDMENT TO
THE CONSTITUTION.
PROVIDES A FUNDAMENTAL RIGHT TO
PRIVACY THE PROTECT THE WOMAN'S
RIGHT TO CHOOSE WHETHER OR NOT
TO HAVE AN ABORTION.
AS WE ALL KNOW THAT LANDMARK
CASE IS ROE V. WADE.
NOW ALMOST A HLF A CENTURY
LATER PEOPLE GROUPS AND
INSTITUTIONS HAVE DONE
EVERYTHING THAT THEY CAN THINK
OF TO RESTRICT ASKED ACCESS.
AND TO SHAME THOSE WHO CHOOSE TO
HAVE AN ABORTION.
THOUGH OUR FORMER GOVERNOR MAY
HAVE BELIEVE THAT IT WAS NOT
UNREASONABLE FOR A COLLEGE
STUDENT TO TRAVEL OFF CAMPUS TO
ACCESS MEDICATION ABORTION.
I RESPECTFULLY AND PROFOUNDLY
DISAGREE.
MEMBERS JUST THREE YEARS AGO A
GROUP OF COMMITTED UC BERKELEY
STUDENTS START A GRASSROOTS
EFFORT TO BRING MEDICATION
ABORTION TO THEIR ON CAMPUS
STUDENT HEALTH CENTER.
AFTER SPEAKING. TO THEIR
ADMINISTRATION AND RAISING
SIGNIFICANT FUNDS TO THAT END
THEY WERE STILL REJECTED BY
SCHOOL ADMINISTRATION AT THAT
POINT I WAS ASKED TO LEAVE THE
EFFORT HERE IN THE CAPITAL.
SB TWENTY FOUR IS A CONTINUATION
OF THAT EFFORT.
THE COLLEGE STUDENT RIGHT TO
ACTS AS A COLLEGE STUDENT RIGHT
TO ACCESS ACT WOULD REQUIRE ALL
ON CAMPUS STUDENT HEALTH CENTERS
AT PUBLIC UNIVERSITIES. TO
PROVIDE MEDICATION FOR EARLY
PREGNANCY TERMINATION FOR
STUDENTS BY JANUARY ONE OF
TWENTY TWENTY THREE RESEARCH
FROM UC SAN FRANCISCO ESTIMATES
THAT EVERY MONTH FIVE HUNDRED
AND NINETEEN STUDENTS AT THIRTY
FOUR UC AND CSU CAMPUSES.
SICK MEDICATION ABORTIONS AT OFF
SITE HEALTH CARE FACILITIES IF
WE TRULY VALUE ACCESS TO
ABORTION IN CALIFORNIA AND THE
IMPORTANCE OF SUPPORTING STUDENT
SUCCESS.
THAT IT'S CRITICAL THAT THESE
HUNDREDS OF STUDENTS EVERY MONTH
ARE ABLE TO ACCESS THE SERVICES
ON CAMPUS.
MEDICATION ABORTION IS A TWO
STEP PROCESS WHERE A PATIENT
TAKES TWO SETS OF PILLS OVER THE
COURSE OF TWO DAYS DURING THE
FIRST TEN WEEKS OF PREGNANCY.
ACCORDING TO UC SAN FRANCISCO
STUDY PLUS YOU.
MEDICATION ABORTION IS VERY SAFE
WITH MAJOR COMPLICATIONS
OCCURRING ONLY ZERO POINT 3% OF
CASES MAKING IT SAFER THAN
TYLENOL FOR ****.
THOUGH MANY CUP HEALTH
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC UNIVERSITIES
ALREADY OFFER REPRODUCTIVE
HEALTH CARE SERVICES SUCH AS
PREGNANCY OPTIONS COUNSELING AND
CONTRACEPTIVES NONE CURRENTLY
OFFERS ACCESS TO MEDICATION
ABORTION ON CAMPUS.
MEDICATION ABORTION IS
CLINICALLY SIMPLER THAN MUCH OF
THE CARE ALREADY OFFERED A
COLLEGE STUDENT HEALTH CARE
CENTERS.
SUCH AS DIABETES MANAGEMENT
MENTAL HEALTH CARE AND THE
DIAGNOSIS AND TREATMENT OF
SEXUALLY TRANSMITTED DISEASES.
ACCESS TO STE IS SEVERELY
LIMITED FOR COLLEGE STUDENTS
SINCE ONLY 15% OF THE CLOSEST
OFF CAMPUS ABORTION PROVIDERS
ARE OPEN ON WEEKENDS.
MEETING THAT STUDENTS MAY HAVE
TO MISS CLASS EXAMS AND WORK.
AND TO ACCESSIBLE OR XIN WHICH
THE SUPREME COURT HAS DETERMINED
ALMOST HALF A CENTURY AGO TO BE
A PROTECTED CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHT.
BEING ABLE TO ACCESS MEDICATION
ABORTION ON COLLEGE CAMPUSES IS
CRITICAL SINCE STUDENTS MUST
RECEIVE THIS CARE WITHIN THE
FIRST TEN WEEKS OF PREGNANCY.
MOST WOMEN DON'T EVEN FIND OUT
THAT THEY'RE PREGNANT UNTIL THE
FIFTH OR SIXTH WEEK.
MEMBERS THE RIGHT TO CHOOSE
ISN'T JUST A SLOGAN BUT RATHER A
COMMITMENT TO IMPROVING TRUE
ACCESS TO ABORTION FOR
CALIFORNIANS ACROSS OUR STATE
INCLUDED COLLEGE STUDENTS AT A
PUBLIC UNIVERSITIES.
HERE WITH ME TODAY IN SUPPORT IS
DOCTOR BUSH MY UPDATE ASSOCIATE
PROFESSOR IN RESIDENCE AT THE
APARTMENT OF OBSTETRICS
GYNECOLOGY AND REPRODUCTIVE
SCIENCES.
ANY RESEARCH AND RESEARCH AT THE
ADVANCING NEW STANDARDS AND
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH RESEARCH
PROGRAM YOU'RE BUSY LADY.
AND MCKENNA FETZER A STUDENT AT
UC BERKELEY.
GOOD AFTERNOON AND THANK YOU FOR
THIS OPPORTUNITY MY NAME IS
DOCTOR OR SMOKE POT YEAH I AND I
AM ASSOCIATE PROFESSOR AND A
PUBLIC HEALTH SCIENTIST.
AT THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
SAN FRANCISCO IN A UNIVERSITY
PROGRAM THE ADVANCING NEW
STANDARDS IN REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH
ANSWER.
AT UCSF WE RECENTLY PUBLISHED
TWO STUDIES RELATED TO CAMPUS
ACCESS TO MEDICATION ABORTION IN
CALIFORNIA.
THE FIRST STUDY LED BY MY
COLLEAGUE DR DANIEL GROSSMAN
COLLECTED INFORMATION FROM ALL
OF THE UC AND CSU STUDENT HEALTH
CENTERS. TO UNDERSTAND IF THEY
HAVE THE CAPACITY TO PROVIDE
MEDICATION ABORTION ON CAMPUS.
THE STUDY CONCLUDED THAT IT
WOULD BE VERY FEASIBLE TO OFFER
MEDICATION ABORTION AT THEIR
FACILITIES.
I LED THE SECOND STUDY ABOUT
MEDICATION ABORTION AMONG
STUDENTS AND THE CURRENT
BARRIERS THEY FACE.
IN THIS STUDY WE FOUND BETWEEN
THREE HUNDRED AND TWENTY TWO AND
FIVE HUNDRED AND NINETEEN UC AND
CSU STUDENTS SEEK MEDICATION
ABORTION OFF CAMPUS EACH MONTH.
GIVEN THAT TO VISITS ARE
RECOMMENDED FOR A MEDICATION
ABORTION MANY STUDENTS HAVE TO
TRAVEL OVER TWO HOURS BY PUBLIC
TRANSPORT.
AND TRAVEL TIME FOR FIVE
CAMPUSES ALL OF WHICH ARE CS USE
IS MORE THAN ONE HOUR EACH WAY
OR FOUR HOURS TOTAL.
MANY STUDENTS HAVE LIMITED
FINANCIAL RESOURCES TO SUPPORT
GOING OFF CAMPUS FOR CARE.
OVER HALF FOR LOW INCOME AND
MANY DO NOT HAVE ACCESS TO A CAR.
APPOINTMENT AVAILABILITY AND
SCHEDULING AN APPOINTMENT OFF
CAMPUS MAY CAUSE FURTHER DELAYS.
STUDENTS MAY BE FORCED TO MISS
CLASSES WORK OR OTHER SCHOOL
COMMITMENTS WHICH MAY ADVERSELY
IMPACT.
THEIR ACADEMIC SUCCESS.
MEDICATION ABORTION IS SAFE AND
SIMPLE TO PROVIDE ALMOST FOUR
MILLION US WOMEN HAVE HAD A
MEDICATION ABORTION AND SERIOUS
COMPLICATIONS ARE VERY RARE LESS
THAN ONE THIRD OF 1% BASED ON
MEDI CAL DATA.
CLINICIANS USUALLY GIVE PATIENTS
THE MIFEPRISTONE TO TAKE RIGHT
AWAY AT THE CLINIC AND THE MESA
PROSTITUTE TAKE HOME ABOUT FORTY
EIGHT HOURS LATER.
SO WHETHER STUDENT GETS ABORTION
PILLS FROM A LOCAL CLINIC OR A
STUDENT HEALTH CENTER THE
ABORTION WILL TAKE PLACE AT HOME
OR WHERE SHE CHOOSES.
STUDENTS SEEKING ABORTION NEED
ACCESS TO HEALTH CARE SERVICES
THAT DO NOT INVOLVE UNNECESSARY
INTERRUPTION AND SIGNIFICANT
BARRIERS IN THERE ARE COMPLEX
LIVES.
BEING FORCED OFF CAMPUS WHETHER
OTHER WHAT WHEN OTHER HEALTH
CARE SERVICES ARE ALREADY
AVAILABLE ON CAMPUS.
UNNECESSARILY BURDEN TO THOSE
STUDENTS WHO NEED AN ABORTION.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
HELLO.
MY NAME IS MCKENNA FETZER AND
I'M A SENIOR AT UC BERKELEY
THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME TODAY.
LAST YEAR I DISCOVERED I WAS
PREGNANT.
I WAS SURPRISED BECAUSE I HAD AN
IED.
I KNEW I WANTED A MEDICATION
ABORTION.
UNFORTUNATELY I WAS UNABLE TO
GET THE METHOD OF CARE I HAD
CHOSEN.
NOR WAS I ABLE TO GET MY
ABORTION IN A TIMELY MANNER.
I HAD TO GO TO MULTIPLE
PROVIDERS.
AN URGENT CARE CENTER TO CONFIRM
THE PREGNANCY AT A HOSPITAL TO
CONFIRM THE PREGNANCY WAS AN
ECTOPIC.
GETTING AN ABORTION AT THAT
HOSPITAL WOULD HAVE COST
THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS.
CLINICS IN SAN FRANCISCO AND
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA THAT I
CALLED WERE BOOKED FOR WEEKS AND
I NEEDED CARE QUICKLY.
BECAUSE I WAS ABOUT TO LEAVE THE
COUNTRY. FOR MY STUDY ABROAD IN
A COUNTRY WHERE ABORTION IS
LEGAL.
I NEEDED MY STUDENT HEALTH
CENTER.
ULTIMATELY I ENDED UP HAVING A
SURGICAL ABORTION WHICH WAS NOT
MY PREFERRED METHOD OF CARE.
WITH SENATE BILL TWENTY FOUR I
COULD HAVE AVOIDED THREE
THOUSAND DOLLARS WORTH OF BILLS
AND FIVE HOURS OF DRIVING
BETWEEN HOSPITALS AND CLINICS
THAT MADE MY EXPERIENCE
STRESSFUL AND EXPENSIVE.
HAD SENATE BILL TWENTY FOUR BEEN
IN PLACE I WOULD HAVE BEEN ABLE
TO CALL THE TANK CENTER FOR
SUPPORT.
I WOULD HAVE BEEN ABLE TO GET MY
ULTRASOUND CONFIRMED THE
PREGNANCY WAS NOT ECTOPIC.
AND ULTIMATELY GET THE ABORTION
PILL ALL IN ONE PLACE.
THE HEALTH CENTER WOULD HAVE
ALSO KNOWN THAT MY STUDENT
HEALTH INSURANCE PLAN COVERED
ALL OF MY SERVICES.
INSTEAD I WAS ALONE.
CALLING CLINIC AFTER CLINIC
NAVIGATING CONFUSING INSURANCE
QUESTIONS AND COMPLICATED
REFERRALS.
I DIDN'T KNOW WHERE TO TURN FOR
HELP.
MY EXPERIENCE DIDN'T HAVE TO BE
THIS WAY.
STUDENTS ON BIRTH CONTROL CAN
STILL GET PREGNANT.
STUDENTS WILL ALWAYS NEED
ABORTIONS.
AND SENATE BILL TWENTY FOUR
ENSURE IS NOT ONLY THAT
MEDICATION ABORTION IS AVAILABLE
ON CAMPUS WHERE WE ALREADY GET
OUR HEALTH CARE.
BUT THAT WE HAVE A SOURCE OF
SUPPORT TO TURN.
TO I SHARE MY STORY WITH YOU
TODAY TO URGE YOU TO SUPPORT
STUDENTS AND VOTE YES ON SENATE
BILL.
TWENTY FOUR THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
[inaudible]
YEAH.
PLEASE COME UP GIVE YOUR NAME
AND GROUP YOU REPRESENT.
SAVANNAH RODRIGUEZ SOPHOMORE AT
UC BERKELEY I STAND IN SUPPORT.
ERIC BONE SISTER NAPA UC
BERKELEY AND SUPPORT.
HI GOOD AFTERNOON SABRINA ASHMAN
LEGISLATIVE CHAIR FOR CALIFORNIA
WOMEN LAWYERS AND THE VICE CHAIR
FOR PUBLIC POLICY FOR NATIONAL
WOMEN'S POLITICAL CAUCUS AND
WE'RE BOTH ORGANIZATIONS ARE A
STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
THANK YOU.
MAY WASHINGTON WITH CAL STATE
STUDENT ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
DEBBIE BAMBERGER NURSE
PRACTITIONER ABORTION PROVIDER
AND UCSF DOCTORAL STUDENT IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
I DIVA CON ALARM OF UC BERKELEY
AND ALSO A CO FOUNDER OF
STUDENTS UNITED FOR REPRODUCTIVE
JUSTICE AT BERKELEY I URGE YOU
TO SUPPORT THE SPELL.
RANDY FEEL VALUED ALSO UC
BERKELEY ELEVEN CO FOUNDER OF
STUDENTS AND OF REPRODUCTIVE
JUSTICE AT BERKELEY COSPONSORED
THE BALLOT IN SUPPORT.
RYAN BAZ CO CURRENT STUDENT AND
CO PRESIDENT OF PLANNED
PARENTHOOD GENERATION ACTION AT
UC SAN DIEGO IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL.
FEAR MANCHU STUDENT FROM THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
RIVERSIDE AND PLANNED PARENTHOOD
GENERATION ACTION IN STRONG
SUPPORT THIS BILL.
MORGAN LOVE ACCESS A WOMEN'S
HEALTH JUSTICE STRONG SUPPORT.
ASCENSION WITH KELSEY FULTON AND
SHOW SUPPORT.
WELL AS A COPY ON IN WITH PLAN
PARA GENERATION ACTION AT UC
RIVERSIDE IN STRONG SUPPORT.
VINCENT ROSTER WITH A STUDENT UC
RIVERSIDE ALSO INCOMING
GOVERNMENT LESIONS DIRECTOR IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
PHILIP A WHIRLING GAME A SILLY
OF CALIFORNIA PROUD CO SPONSOR
AND STRONG SUPPORT.
CARE MILLER STUDENT WITH
CALIFORNIA LIFTING UNIVERSITY
STRONG SUPPORT.
LIZ EVANS IN THE STUDENT AT UC
RIVERSIDE IN STRONG SUPPORT.
WHERE IS THE HARDER SO IT'S AN
EASY REPRESENT A STRONG SUPPORT?
THANK YOU HERNANDEZ STUDENT AC
RIVER SAID IN A STRONGLY SUPPORT.
IN GEORGIA COMMITTEE CHAIR THE
CITY HOW THAT BY THREE CENTER AT
THE UNIVERSITY BECAUSE WHEN OF
RIVERSIDE AND VICE PRESIDENT OF
PUMPING EDUCATION ACTION STRONG
SUPPORT.
BUT IT IS A MODERN OF INVALIDS
OF STUDENT YOU SEE ARE ON IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU FOR
SHARING YOUR STORY.
GOT THE AMMO YESTERDAY I YOU SEE
OUR STRONG SUPPORT.
VANESSA BLAYLOCK STUDENT PITZER
COLLEGE STRONG SUPPORT.
LIBBY BENEDICT REPRESENTING
PROUD SUPPORTER NAY ROLE PRO
CHOICE CALIFORNIA IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
MEN'S WORK IN A SEA OF
CALIFORNIA AS WELL AS CONSENT I
YOU SILLY Là AND A LOT OF UC
DAVIS AND STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
JOURNALISTIC EASY BERKELEY IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
Q. AND HENNESSY UC BERKELEY ALSO
IN STRONG SUPPORT.
KATHLEEN SAYING ALUMNI HAVE UC
BERKELEY AND STRONG SUPPORT.
I'M AND THINGS DID NOT FEAR
COLLEGE IN STRONG SUPPORT.
RACHEL GARBO CAL POLY ALIGNMENT
PREVIOUS PRESIDENT OF PLANNED
PARENTHOOD GENERATION ACTION AND
I STRONGLY SUPPORT.
EMILY ESCOBAR ALUMNI OF CAL
STATE LONG BEACH REPRESENTING
THE FEMINIST MAJORITY FOUNDATION
IN STRONG SUPPORT.
CURRENT AVAILABLE WITH A MISS
MAJORITY AND COSTS CURRENCY NOW
CALLS ATTENDANCE AND STRONG
SUPPORT.
WHEN TENER STUDENT AT LOYOLA
MARYMOUNT UNIVERSITY ALSO WITH
FEMINIST MAJORITY FOUNDATION AND
I STRONGLY SUPPORT?
ROBBIE HAS SON UC BERKELEY
GRADUATE IN STRONG SUPPORT.
EMILY MONTELLO TELFORD UCSB ALUM
NINE PRESIDENT OF STUDENTS GET
SEXUAL SAUL AND I'M IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
FELIPE AVAILABLE STUDENT AT UC
SANTA BARBARA I'M PRESIDENT OF
STUDENTS VERY PRODUCTIVE JUSTICE.
UNTIL IT ALLOWS STUDENT AT UC
ARE STRONG SUPPORT.
NUMBER SEVEN ST PRESIDENT OF THE
COLLEGE DEMOCRATS THE UC
RIVERSIDE STRONG SUPPORT.
IN THE NAY MARTINEZ SAID IN A
YOU SEE RIVERSIDE IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
I'M A CIRCUIT HERE DO STUDENT
BODY PRESIDENT UC BERKELEY
STRONG SUPPORT.
ASIA FIRE BY UC BERKELEY IN
RACHEL CO UC BERKELEY ALUMNI
WITH ACCESS WOMEN'S HEALTH
JUSTICE PROUD BECAUSE HUNTER IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
SANTIAGO CHEVY LE UC SANTA CRUZ
ALUMNI AND STRONG SUPPORT.
CHECK A BREAKER NATIONAL
ASSOCIATIONS SO SHORT CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU FOR SHARING YOUR STORY.
JUDITH ALL ON YOU SEE OUR ALARM
IN STRONG SUPPORT.
SHERRI LEAVE FROM UC SANTA CRUZ
MARIO GUERRERO ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA FACULTY ASSOCIATIONS
TRANSPORT.
ANDREW MS FISHER WITH THE LEAGUE
OF WOMEN VOTERS OF CALIFORNIANS
SUPPORT.
ALICE KESSLER BEHALF OF A
QUALITY CALIFORNIA AND SUPPORT.
I LEAN MENTAL AMERICAN ACADEMY
OF PEDIATRICS SONGS CALIFORNIA
STRONG SUPPORT.
IN ADDITION UC BERKELEY ELEMENTS
ON SUPPORT THANK YOU.
SIR AB SHINE UC BERKELEY STUDENT
PRESENT OF CALPERS THE DEMOCRATS
AND BOARD MEMBER FOR THE UC SOON
ASSOCIATION IN STRONG SUPPORT.
BRENT SPENCE ON BEHALF OF THE
AMERICAN COLLEGE OBGYN THIS
DISTRICT NINE IN SUPPORT.
AUTUMN ROCK STUDENT AT
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY%
CHICO AND ON BEHALF OF THE
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORK -- STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
FRANKIE HERNANDEZ PUBLIC HEALTH
HEALTH EQUITY STUDENT AT MILLS
COLLEGE IN STRONG SUPPORT.
KAMALA WOODROW STUDENT AT AS
SACRAMENTO STATE UNIVERSITY IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
REBECCA CHEN SMALL NURSE
PRACTITIONER STUDENT AT UCSF IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
SOFIA COPIES THAT ANA ALUMNI
FROM UC RIVERSIDE AND
REPRESENTING CALIFORNIA LET THE
NEST REPRODUCTIVE JUSTICE AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL.
I AM LIMB FIRST YEAR UC
RIVERSIDE STUDENT AND SONGS
SPORTS.
ELAINE A DAN ECHO CHAIR
CALIFORNIA STATE STUDENT
ASSOCIATION LIAISON VICE CHAIR
OF LOBBY CORPS AND PRESIDENT OF
HUMANS FOR FEMINISM SACRAMENTO
STATE IN STRONG SUPPORT.
MEDINA SEBASTIANO SECOND YEAR
MEDICAL STUDENT AT UC DAVIS
SCHOOL OF MEDICINE IN VERY
STRONG SUPPORT.
HI KERR CAM MEDICAL STUDENT AT
UC DAVIS SCHOOL OF MEDICINE AND
FORMER REPRODUCTIVE OPTIONS
CONCERN VERY STRONG SUPPORT.
TARA APRIL AT A NURSE
PRACTITIONER CITY IT AT UC SAN
FRANCISCO IN STRONG SUPPORT.
KATIE GOT THREE CURRENT STUDENT
AT UC BERKELEY IN STRONG SUPPORT.
LINEAR MAC FROM SANTA BARBARA
CITY COLLEGE IN STRONG SUPPORT.
I'M LILY ARE THIAGO WITH THE
FEMINIST FORCE FROM CAL STATE
FULLERTON AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT.
HI JESSE Là SILAS -- HERE TO
REPRESENT THE NATIONAL NETWORK
OF ABORTION FUNDS IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
MY RIBS SIMPLY PARENT AT THE
CALIFORNIA STRONG SUPPORT.
MY COLLEAGUES IN ALL
REPRESENTING AMERICAN
ASSOCIATION OF UNIVERSITY WOMEN
IN STRONG SUPPORT.
OBLIVIOUS METER REPRESENTING THE
UC STUDENT ASSOCIATION IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
STEPHANIE IS A WITH THE
COMMISSION ON THE STATUS OF
WOMEN AND GIRLS IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
AFTER TO HEAR SUDANESE HE
BERKELEY IN STRONG SUPPORT.
ISRAELIS BUT AS MANY AS YOU SEE
CENTER AT UC BERKELEY AND
STRONGLY IN SUPPORT.
MARKETS BECAUSE THEIR HOME TO
THE CALIFORNIA BENEFIT HEALTH
NETWORK IN ON BEHALF OF HAVING
OUR SAY COALITION IN SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
AND MEMBERS JOSEPHINE FIGURE ON
BEHALF OF INSURANCE COMMISSIONER
THE CARD A LOT IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THURMOND OF UC BERKELEY STUDENTS
STRONG SUPPORT.
ABRAHAM'S ON THE WATER FROM THE
UNIVERSITY OF SAN FRANCISCO AND
ON BEHALF OF TRY TO LINE X.
UNDERGRADUATE COLLECTED FOR
HIGHER ACHIEVEMENT.
IN STRONG SUPPORT.
LUCY LEASE STUDENT AT UNIVERSITY
OF SAN FRANCISCO IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
JACQUELINE RODRIGUEZ STUDENT
PARA COLLEGES ON THE TOWN STRONG
SUPPORT.
I AM EYELESS COLLEGES AMATIL
STRONG SUPPORT.
NICOLAS JESSEL UCLA STRONG
SUPPORT.
LARA HUMANA'S UC SAN DIEGO AND
SAN FRANCISCO STATE UNIVERSITY
ALUMNI ALSO EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
CALIFORNIA LETTING US
REPRODUCTIVE JUSTICE THE PROUD
BILL COSPONSORED IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
RACHEL WALLACE GRADUATE STUDENT
AT UC BERKELEY IN SUPPORT.
CARLY VENDOR -- GRADUATE OF UC
BERKELEY IN STRONG SUPPORT.
DâN OFFER UC DAVIS ALONG WITH
THE WOMAN FOUNDATION OF
CALIFORNIA PROD CO SPONSOR OF
THIS BILL IN STRONG SUPPORT.
DANDURAND CSU NORTHRIDGE ALUMNI
IN STRONG SUPPORT.
HI I'M DOCTOR SCHWARTZ FROM UC
DAVIS MY GOD LOVING MOTHER.
FULL SUPPORT OF THIS BILL CURTIS
FOR THANK YOU.
ALISA DAVIS THIRD YEAR STUDENT
AT UC BERKELEY IN STRONG SUPPORT.
FIFTY MARKLEEVILLE PLAN
GENERATION ACTION AT UC BERKELEY
IF IT WASN'T FOR ACCESSIBLE
ABORTION KERRY WOULDN'T BE ALIVE
TODAY.
THINK.
HI IVAN AND IS THAT IN YOUR
STUDIO YOU SEE BERKELEY IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
HI RENT BANGLE ACTING JUST EVEN
AT UC BERKELEY -- A STRONG
SUPPORT.
HI RUN QUAN -- UC DAVIS ALONA
AND STUDENT AT UNIVERSITY OF
MINNESOTA LAW SCHOOL IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
IF YOU COME FORWARD TO THE TABLE
[inaudible]
THEY BEGIN.
WELCOME THANK YOU MY NAME IS
BERNADETTE TASTY AND I JUST
GRADUATED WITH MY MA FROM FRESNO
STATE AND ALSO THE PRESIDENT OF
FRESNO PRO LIFE FUTURE.
I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL AND
I'D LIKE TO GIVE MY TOP THREE
REASONS WHY THIS BILL
CONTRADICTS ITSELF.
NUMBER ONE THIS IS SUPPOSED TO
BE ABOUT ACCESS BUT THE BILL
STILL PLACES THE MANDATE ON ALL
PUBLIC UNIVERSITIES EVEN THOUGH
MANY SCHOOLS HAVE AN ABORTION
PILL PROVIDER WITHIN JUST A FEW
MILES OF THE CAMPUSES.
YET THERE HAS BEEN NO DISCUSSION
OF AN EXEMPTION FOR SCHOOLS LIKE
THESE.
NUMBER.
TWO ESTIMATES FOR TIME TAKEN TO
TRAVEL TO THE ABORTION PILL
PROVIDER ARE BASED ON PUBLIC
TRANSPORTATION TAKING MUCH MORE
TIME THAN SAY AN OVER.
OF COURSE AND OVER HAS A SMALL
CHARGE BUT IS MUCH FASTER THAN
THE THIRTY MINUTE BUS ROUTE
ESTIMATE PRESENTED BY PROPONENTS
OF THE BILL.
LAST YEAR THE AUTHOR STATED THAT
THE SUPER COSTS WOULD BE MORE OF
A BURDEN HOWEVER FOR ONE THING
IF YOU'RE ON MEDICARE AL
TRANSPORTATION SERVICES ARE
PROVIDED FOR FREE.
END OF THE CSU AND YOU SEE
SYSTEMS BOTH STATE IN
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
ANALYSES BOTH LAST YEAR AND THIS
YEAR AT THE FUNDS FOR SB TWENTY
FOUR ARE INSUFFICIENT BY THE
MILLIONS.
AND AT THE COST WOULD LIKELY
FALL TO THE STUDENTS SO ALTHOUGH
THIS BILL SHOULD BE SAVING US
FROM SPENDING MORE MONEY ON AND
OVER IT WILL ACTUALLY COST US
MORE IN OUR MANDATORY STUDENT
FEES.
NUMBER THREE DR DANIEL GROSSMAN
WHO HAS TESTIFIED IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL SEVERAL TIMES CO
AUTHORED AN ARTICLE STATING THAT
THE FAILURE RATE OF THESE PILLS
IS BETWEEN THREE AND OVER 15%.
THIS NUMBER VARIES DEPENDING ON
HOW FAR ALONG THE WOMAN IS IN
HER PREGNANCY SO OF ALL THE
STUDENTS TAKE THE PILLS IN THE
SIXTH WEEK OF PREGNANCY THERE
MIGHT BE A 3% FEEL RIGHT.
BUT IF THEY'RE IN THE NINTH WEEK
OF PREGNANCY IT MIGHT BE OVER
15% AND IF WE GO WITH THE
AUTHORS ESTIMATE OF FIVE HUNDRED
STUDENTS USING THIS SERVICE ACH
MONTH.
THIS MEANS THAT ANYWHERE BETWEEN
FIFTEEN AND SEVENTY FIVE GIRLS
WOULD NEED A FOLLOW UP SURGICAL
ABORTION EACH MONTH.
SEVERAL PRO CHOICE INDIVIDUALS
HAVE SIGNED A PETITION AGAINST
THIS BILL AND OUR OWN FORMER PRO
CHOICE GOVERNOR BROWN VETO THIS
BILL BECAUSE IT IS IRRESPONSIBLE
AND UNNECESSARY.
THERE ARE MORE QUESTIONS THAN
ANSWERS REGARDING THIS BILL AND
BECAUSE OF THAT I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR NO VOTE.
OR ABSTAIN FROM VOTING THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS TO MICAH BASSMAN I
GRADUATED LAST MONTH FROM UC
BERKELEY I'M STRONGLY OPPOSED SB
TWENTY FOUR LIKE TO SHARE WITH
YOU FOUR REASONS WHY TODAY.
NUMBER ONE IS THIS BILLS HISTORY
THIS BILL ORIGINATED ON MY
CAMPUS WIDE STUDENT THERE YET
BERKELEY'S OWN OPENLY PRO CHOICE
ADMINISTRATION REFUSED TO
IMPLEMENT THIS BILL THE FIRST
TIME.
AFTER TWO YEARS OF DISCUSSING
THIS BILL AT THE STATE LEVEL I
SIMPLY MUST ASK WHY WE STILL
HAVE NOT ADDRESS MY
MINISTRATIONS REGIONAL CONCERNS.
NUMBER TWO THIS BILLS
INCONSISTENT AIM OF HOLDING
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHTS.
OUR STATE SHOULD BE UPHOLDING
ALL CONSTITUTIONAL PROTECTED
RIGHTS WE CAN'T JUST PICK AND
CHOOSE WHICH ONES.
THESE INCLUDE THE RIGHT TO
RELIGIOUS FREEDOM POSSESSED BY
ALL PUBLIC UNIVERSITY STUDENTS
INCLUDING THOSE HER PERSONAL
MORAL OBJECTIONS TO THEIR OWN
STUDENT FEES DIRECTLY FUNDING ON
CAMPUS ABORTIONS.
YES BE TWENTY FOUR HAS NO SIMPLE
OPT OUT PROVISION FOR THE
STUDENTS.
AND THIS LOOKS THE OTHER WAY
WHEN IT COMES TO THEIR
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHTS.
REASON NUMBER THREE STUDENT
SAFETY.
THE BILL'S AUTHORS HAVE A SORT
QUOTE UNQUOTE CLINICALLY SIMPLE
TO PROVIDE BUT THEY HAVE YET TO
ADDRESS THE DIFFICULTY OF TRYING
TO CONTAIN.
INDUCEMENTS CARROTS WITH A NON
PRIVATE UNSANITARY AND CO ED
DORM ON A CAMPUS WITH ALLIES IS
UNDERSTAFFED ESTO YOU'LL
SERVICES I HAVE LIVED IN SUCH AN
ON CAMPUS FOR MYSELF.
WHETHER OR NOT LIKE THIS REALITY
THIS IS THE REALITY OF THE
LIVING CONDITIONS ON CAMPUS.
AND FINALLY NUMBER FOR STUDENT
FEES.
SB TWENTY FOUR CONTAINS AN
OVERLY SIMPLISTIC ONE SIZE FITS
ALL THIRTY ONE CAMPUSES BLANKET
FINANCIAL PROGRAM PROVIDES NO
MEANS OF COVERING ONGOING COSTS
WHICH THIS COMMITTEES OWN
ANALYSIS REPORTS AS UP TO THREE
POINT THREE MILLION DOLLARS
ANNUALLY AFTER.
TWENTY TWENTY THREE THE UC
SYSTEM ALONE.
THIS INADEQUATE FINANCIAL PLAN
COMES AT A PRICE LIST PRICE IS
GOING TO BE PAID FOR HIGHER
STUDENT FEES BUT THE SAME
STUDENTS ALREADY FACE FINANCIAL
BEARS THE EDUCATION.
IS FOR THESE REASONS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK THAT YOU CHOOSE
TO VOTE NO OR TO OBTAIN FROM
VOTE IN SB TWENTY FOUR TODAY
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
HE'D COME TO THE MIKE GIVE YOUR
NAME THE GROUP YOU REPRESENT.
HELLO ASSEMBLYMEMBERS AND
SENATOR -- I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR NAY OR ABSTENTION I'M
ALEXANDER KIRK ACEH I'M WITH PRO
LIFE SAN FRANCISCO FORMER CITY
COLLEGE OF SAN FRANCISCO --
STUDENT GRADUATED THANK YOU.
CECILIA CODY CALIFORNIA RIGHT TO
LIFE EDUCATIONAL FUND AND WE
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
I'M CHARLOTTE GRAHAM CALIFORNIA.
RIGHT TO LIFE AND I STRONGLY
STRONGLY OBJECT TO THIS BILL. TO
RESERVE A COVERT ACTION ATHEIST
DEMOCRAT FOUNDER AND EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF PRO LIFE SAN
FRANCISCO IN STRONG OPPOSITION.
STILL YES GOOD BEETLE UNIVERSITY
ALUMNI. THIRTY TWO YEARS OF
EDUCATION EDUCATING AND IN A
PUBLIC SCHOOL AND A MOTHER AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSED THIS BILL.
THESE ARE MY TWINS THAT I SAVED
FROM ABORTION CLINIC.
HI MICHELLE MONICA MY TWELVE
YEAR OLD SON MADE THIS.
YEAH AND I'M A RESPECT LIFE
SPEAKER AND I OPPOSE MOTHERS
SLAUGHTERING THEIR CHILDREN.
THANK YOU.
MIKE UP UPSIDE DOWN.
WHEN OUT SILLS DIRECTOR OF
CALIFORNIANS FOR LIFE WHO
RECOGNIZE THE HUMANITY OF THE
CHILD IN THE WOMB?
THE SCIENCE THAT REPRESENTS THAT
IN THE TRAUMA THAT ABORTION
CAUSES WOMEN THANK YOU WE OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
MARY SERI.
MOTHER GRANDMOTHER.
I BELIEVE IN PROTECTING THE
CHILDREN NOT KILLING THEM.
REYES A FERNANDES WITH THE
CALIFORNIA CATHOLIC CONFERENCE
IN OPPOSITION.
RICKY SILVER PRESIDENTE SPARSE
FOR LIFE IT SOUNDS A STATE
UNIVERSITY IN STRONG OPPOSITION.
BROOKE ARMY THE REGIONAL
COORDINATOR FOR STUDENTS FOR
LIFE OF AMERICA REPRESENTING
FIFTY FIVE STUDENT GROUPS AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS.
KILL MULLINGS AMBASSADOR FOR
LIVE CTION ORGANIZATION AND
PRESIDENT OF STUDENTS FOR LIKE
AMERICA AT SEATTLE PACIFIC
UNIVERSITY AND I ADAMANTLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
LYDIA HIGH CAMP PRESIDENT OF
STUDENTS FOR LIFE AT PORTLAND
COMMUNITY COLLEGE AND ADAMANTLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
ELIJAH MASON STUDENT AT PORTLAND
COMMUNITY COLLEGE AND I
ADAMANTLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
SERRA HOOKER STUDENT WESTMONT
COLLEGE AND I ADAMANTLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
JENNIFER LAYERED STUDENT AT S.
SAN DIEGO STATE UNIVERSITY AND I
ADAMANTLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
AMBER AMERO STUDENT AT FRESNO
STATE UNIVERSITY WITH STUDENTS
FOR LIFE AT FRESNO STATE AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
GABBY LARA PUBLIC RELATIONS
OFFICER SAN JOSE STATE
UNIVERSITY STUDENT FOR LIFE AND
AYE OPPOSED TO SPELL.
MILES WILEY THIS IN A STUDENT
ASSN TRY COLLEGE IN PRESIDENT
STUDENTS FOR LIFE.
OF THAT'S IN TRY COLLAGEN
ADAMANTLY OPPOSE THIS BILL
[inaudible]
RALPH MERLONI.
MEMBER ST ROSE CATHOLIC PARISH
SOUTH SACRAMENTO AND AN ALUMNUS
OF CAL STATE UNIVERSITY
NORTHRIDGE I STRONGLY OPPOSE IS
DANGEROUS AND UNNECESSARY BILL.
BRIAN CARROLL OF THE STATE
COMMITTEE OF THE AMERICAN
SOLIDARITY PARTY AND WE OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
HI I'M JENNY ISSUE FROM
BAKERSFIELD AND I JUST WANTED TO
READ IT SAYS THE LORD CALLED ME
FROM THE WOMB FROM THE BODY OF
MY MOTHER HE NAME TO MY NAME.
I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HELLO COMMITTEE AND MY NAME IS
ROBERT BYRD ON THE SOCIAL MEDIA
COORDINATOR FOR WITH PRO LIFE
SAN FRANCISCO AND I URGE A NO
VOTE OR AN EXTENSION THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS CALLIE FERRARI I
AM A FORMER GRADUATE FROM SAN
JOSE STATE AND MEMBER OF
SPARTANS FOR LIFE AND I AM
ENTERING A CREDENTIALING PROGRAM
AT CAL POLY AND I'M A MEMBER OF
THE KAPALI STUDENTS FOR LIFE AND
I ADAMANTLY OPPOSE THIS BILL
ENERGY.
A NO OR ABSTAINED VOTE.
HI I'M MARY LEE SHRIDER
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR RIGHT TO LIFE
OF KERN COUNTY IN STRONG
OPPOSITION.
JUDY GOOD WITH RIGHT TO LIFE OF
KERN COUNTY NAY STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
CURRENT HAND FROM UC DAVIS AND
TREASURER OF ARGUES FOR LIFE AND
I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
SALLY MAJESTIC CSU SACRAMENTO
ALONE I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS
BILL.
ANTHONY TOMORROW FROM SPOKANE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE AND I
ADAMANTLY OPPOSED TO SPELL.
SIR CRESCENT INCIDENT MEREKA
STATE COLLEGE I ASK YOU TO
PLEASE OPPOSE THIS BILL.
JOHN JORDAN A CYNIC GONZAGA
UNIVERSITY AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
ANGELIQUE CLARK AT THE
UNIVERSITY OF LAS VEGAS NEVADA
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
CARLY LOGIC ALUMNI WESTERN
WASHINGTON UNIVERSITY
REPRESENTING OVER FORTY STUDENT
GROUPS AND THE NORTHWEST AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
NICOLE LAND FROM SAN DIEGO STATE
UNIVERSITY AND ADAMANTLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
JULIANNA JOHNS FROM TACOMA
COMMUNITY COLLEGE AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THE SPELL.
KATIE LOGIC I AM THE NATIONAL
FIELD DIRECTOR FOR STUDENTS FOR
LIKE ACTION I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
LESLIE MORRIS RIGHT TO LIFE
STRONGLY OPPOSE.
I'M LOUISE LENTEN OF SERGEANT AT
ARMS OF OFFICER AT THE U. OF THE
YMCA YOUTH IN GOVERNMENT AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
LEE LENTEN EL DORADO HILLS AND
SAINT JOHN'S CATHOLIC CHURCH I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
DEGREE NO SIR REGIONAL
COORDINATOR FOR STUDENTS LIVE
AMERICA REPRESENT OVER FORTY
STUDENT GROUPS THROUGHOUT THE
STATE AND I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
THAT YOU REAFFIRM GOVERNOR BROWN
TO VETO AND VOTE OPPOSITION
THANK YOU.
MIKE RASMUSSEN BY SAY CALIFORNIA
I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
LINDEN THEM NOW I'M A REGISTERED
NURSE GRACHEV UC SAN FRANCISCO I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK
YOU.
THROUGH OUR INNER KERN COUNTY
RIGHT TO LIFE I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS NADIA UNIT AND I'M
FROM CSU FRESNO WHEN I URGE YOU
TO VOTE NO.
A ROOM HER STUDENT AT CSU FRESNO
AND STRONGLY OPPOSE.
EMILY SAUL SENIOR AT CALIFORNIA
STATE UNIVERSITY FRESNO A CO
PRESIDENT OF STUDENTS FOR LIFE
AT FRESNO STATE AND STRONG
OPPOSITION.
LIAM GRAY ARE COMING STUDENT OF
A BUSINESS AT UNIVERSITY AND THE
STRONG OPPOSITION OF THIS BILL.
LARA RODRIGUEZ I'M WITH STUDENTS
BLACK PRESENCE STAY AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
CHANDRA RT ON BEHALF OF OUR
THOUSANDS OF SUPPORTERS AT RIGHT
TO LIFE OF CENTRAL CALIFORNIA OF
WHOM I'M THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
WE STRONGLY.
URGE YOU TO VOTE NO OR TO
ABSTAIN.
JULIA QUASAR WITH FRESNO STATE
STUDENTS FOR LIFE AND ENERGY TO
VOTE NO ON THIS BILL.
HOW DO YOU ACQUIRE STUDENTS FOR
LIFE AND I OPPOSE?
THE REAL QUESTION COMING COLLEGE
STUDENT I STRONG YOU AN EXTRA
VISIT US OPPOSE THIS BILL.
ANNA BACH REGIONAL COORDINATOR
WAS SINCE FOR LIFE OF AMERICA
REPRESENTING TWELVE HUNDRED
STUDENT GROUPS NATIONALLY AND WE
STRONGLY OPPOSE.
KAMALA CISNEROS THE PRINT ON
CAMPUS DIRECTOR WITH STUDENTS
FOR LIFE OF AMERICA ASKING THAT
YOU PLEASE OPPOSE THEIR OBSCENE
THANK YOU.
MONICA STROMBIDAE GRADUATE OF
CAL STATE FRESNO MEMBER OF
CENTRAL CALIFORNIA RIGHT TO LIFE.
I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
CHRISTINE ROSE A GRADUATE OF CSU
FRESNO AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
CURLING CHRISTIANSEN BILL.
LINDA FURTADO IF MERCED COUNTY
UNITED FOR LIFE WE STRONGLY
OPPOSES BELT.
JULIANNE L. CHARGIN FROM FRESNO
STRONGLY OPPOSED TO SPELL.
LINDA RAE CONCERNED CALIFORNIA
CITIZEN AND PARENT OF AND FRESNO
STATE ILLNESS AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
SUSAN BLACKBURN.
MOTHER STRONGLY OPPOSE.
STEVE GRAY TAXPAYER I OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
REVEREND OLDER HERMAN I
REPRESENT THE COUNCIL THE UNITED
STATES AND LYFT TEAMS
INTERNATIONAL AND SEVERAL
PASTORS IN THE COMMUNITY AND IN
CALIFORNIA THROUGHOUT THE US.
AND WE STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS THIS
BILL THESE ARE BABIES AND YOUR
FUTURE STUDENTS.
SHERRI REASSURE RIGHT TO LIFE I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
DEAN AGO DENIES STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
RITA HOW OFTEN ACT MOTHER
GRANDMOTHER EDUCATOR FROM FRESNO
I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
SIDE OF IT ANIL FRESNO STATE
GRADUATE I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS
BILL.
SIDE AYE DADDY MEMBER OF RIGHT
TO LIFE AND CENTRAL CALIFORNIA I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS MARK CODA AND I AM
THE PROUD BIRTH FATHER OF A FIVE
YEAR OLD BABY GIRL WHO LIVES IN
AUSTIN TEXAS A THIRD DOCTOR OF
PARENTS.
AND I URGE YOU TO VOTE ON THIS
BILL.
I'M PASSED THEIR TYRONE CAR
THEIR OF ABBAS'S MINISTRY FRESNO
CALIFORNIA.
I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL
BECAUSE IT'S WRONG -- JONATHAN
KELLER -- CONSTITUENT OF DOCTOR
ARAMBULA.
AND THE SOME I CENTER LIVE
EXCUSE ME I APPRECIATE YOUR
HEART BEHIND THE BILL THAT
RESPECTFULLY ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA FAMILY COUNCIL -- WE
OPPOSE.
HOLDEN ROMBERG ARE UNIVERSALLY
CALIFORNIA ALANIS.
AND CENTER FOR DOCUMENTATION OF
AMERICAN HOLOCAUST.
DO NOT MAKE A WHOLE ACOSTA
STUDENTS ON THE CAMPUS.
REJECTED THANK YOU.
FILE.
THANK YOU.
ANY TWO WINNERS.
THE CLEANERS LIKE TO COME UP TO
THE TABLE [inaudible]
YOU MAY. TWO MINUTES EACH.
IF YOU HAVE TWO MINUTES EACH
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS MY
NAME IS ANGELA GILYARD AND THE
DIRECTOR OF STATE HEALTH POLICY
FOR THE UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA
HEALTH SYSTEM.
THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
MANDATE THAT ALL STUDENTS HAVE
HEALTHCARE.
THE UNIVERSITY OPERATES A HEALTH
PLAN FOR STUDENTS CALLED YOU SEE
SHIP.
REPRODUCTIVE.
HEALTH CARE IS CONSIDERED AN
ESSENTIAL BENEFIT FOR STUDENTS.
AND THE UNIVERSITY FULLY SUPPORT
REPRODUCTIVE RIGHTS FOR EACH
STUDENT WE HAVE NOT WAVERED IN
THIS RESOLVE.
HOWEVER YOU SEE DOES NOT HAVE A
POSITION ON SB TWENTY FOUR
BECAUSE THERE ARE.
OUTSTANDING ISSUES WE ARE
WORKING THROUGH WITH THE AUTHOR
THE ISSUES ARE PRIMARILY AROUND
IMPLEMENTATION AND COSTS WHILE
MOST OF THE PUBLIC CONVERSATION
SURROUNDING THIS BILL HAS.
CENTERED ON THE WOMEN'S RIGHT TO
CHOOSE THIS HAS NEVER BEEN AN
ISSUE FOR THE UNIVERSITY WE HAVE
MADE IT CLEAR ON REPEATED
OCCASIONS THAT WE SUPPORT A
WOMAN'S RIGHT TO CHOOSE.
OUR RIGHT OF CHOICE THE PROBLEMS
WITH ACCESS TO THE SERVICE OR
NOT PROXIMITY RATHER THE
PROBLEMS ARE THAT REFERRALS HAVE
NOT BEEN SEAMLESS AND THEY
SHOULD BE. FOR THIS REASON WE
UNDERSTAND THE OFFERS BILL WOULD
LIKE THE SERVICE ON CAMPUS
DIRECTLY WHICH WILL HELP RESOLVE
SOME OF THE INSURANCE CONNECTION
TYPE ISSUES.
STUDENTS HAVE EXPERIENCE WE HAVE
BEEN WORKING ON SOLUTIONS WITH
THE OFFERS OFFICE AND WE STILL
NEED TO SOLVE THE PROBLEM OF
FUNDING SOURCES.
POST IMPLEMENTATION TWENTY
TWENTY THREE BRINGING THE
SERVICE ON CAMPUS WITHOUT A
FUNDING SOURCE BEYOND TWENTY
TWENTY THREE WOULD INCREASE
COSTS TO STUDENTS.
SINCE HEALTH CARE CENTERS ARE
SUPPORTED BY STUDENT FEES.
WE KNOW WE HAVE A CHAMPION AND A
GOOD WORKING RELATIONSHIP WITH
SENATOR LEYVA OFFICE AND ARE
HOPEFUL WE CAN RESOLVE.
THESE OUT YOUR FUNDING ISSUES
THEN NOW THIS IS REYES IMPORTANT
POLICY QUESTIONS AND WE ARE HERE
TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS THE
COMMITTEE MIGHT HAVE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
HI MAGGIE RIGHT WITH THE CSU
I'LL BE VERY BRIEF I'D REITERATE
AT THE COMMENTS MADE BY MY UC
COLLEAGUE WE DO HAVE A PENDING
POSITION ON THIS BILL AT THE CSU.
OUR VERY THANKFUL FOR THE
COMMENTS MADE AND THE ANALYSIS
UP PARTICULARLY GUARDING I'M
GOING COSTS AN IMPLEMENTATION
WHICH HAVE BEEN OUR PRIMARY
CONCERNS WITH THE BILL WE'RE
VERY THANKFUL TO THE AUTHOR AND
HER OFFICE FOR THE ON GOING
DIALOGUE WITH FORTY CONTAINING
TO WORK TOGETHER.
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER TWEENER.
SEE NINE ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE
[inaudible]
MISTER PATTERSON [inaudible]
AGAIN -- THIS IS FAMILIAR
TERRITORY WE'VE BEEN HERE BEFORE.
AND THAT -- THE PREVIOUS
GOVERNOR -- VETOED WITH I THINK
SOME.
PRETTY CLEAR -- CONCERNS AND HI
I JUST.
I JUST WANT TO REITERATE.
THAT.
THIS IS -- THERE'S THERE THERE
THERE ARE RISKS INVOLVED IN THIS --
WHICH WE'VE HEARD TESTIMONY OF
HEALTH RISK -- WE'VE HEARD
TESTIMONY LIABILITY RISK.
I THINK THAT THE UNIVERSITIES
ARE [inaudible]
CAREFULLY.
ARE COMMUNICATING WITH OF THIS.
COMMITTEE ON THE BILL
[inaudible]
BUT ABSENT.
SOLVING THE COST QUESTION.
OR THE QUESTION OF STUDENT FEES --
THIS I THINK HAS THE SAME KINDS
OF PROBLEMS THAT THE PREVIOUS
BILL.
I HAD BEFORE AND SO I'M I'M
GOING TO BE A NO VOTE AGAIN.
BUT ALSO -- IT SEEMS TO ME THE
THAT THAT THIS IS AN UNNECESSARY.
THE EFFORT TO INVOLVE THE
UNIVERSITIES IN SOMETHING. FOR
WHICH I THINK THE UNIVERSITIES
ARE [inaudible]
TRYING.
AND YET THEY ARE EXPRESSING THE
KINDS OF CONCERNS OVER COST
LIABILITY.
PUSHING THIS OFF ON STUDENT FEES
THOSE KINDS OF THINGS WHEN.
BY BY THE TESTIMONY THE OF THE
PREVIOUS.
BILL AND TESTIMONY HERE.
WE HAVE SERVICES.
LIKE THESE IN CLOSE PROXIMITY TO
THE UNIVERSITIES.
OUR AND SO I I FIND THE THE RISK
THE COST THE LIABILITY AND THE
UNCERTAINTY OF THE UNIVERSITIES
OVER THIS.
COMPELLING REASONS TO OPPOSE.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
MR CHOI.
THANK YOU CHAIR.
US SENATOR -- LEYVA.
I DON'T WANNA GET INTO UP PRO
CHOICE OR PRO LIFE QUESTION
ISSUE BUT THE A RELATED -- TO
LIABILITY ISSUE COSTS OF I
WONDER.
WHO'S GONNA BE IN CHARGE F THE
MEDICAL WASTE.
FROM THE CHEMICAL ABORTION
CSU CAMPUSES.
SINCE THE ARE LOW CLEARLY STATES
THAT THE CSU AND ARE YOU SEE.
ARE RESPONSIBLE OR FOR THE
HEALTH AND THE WELFARE OF THE
STUDENTS SO ON THE CAMPUS.
IT WOULD BE HANDLED BY THE
HEALTH CARE CENTERS.
DO YOU HAVE ANY -- EXPECTATIONS
HOW THEY WOULD HANDLE THEM.
SINCE I HAVE NEVER DONE THAT I
DON'T WORK AND HEALTH CARE
FACILITY NO I DO NOT I WOULD
LEAVE IT TO THEM BUT I THINK I
HAVE A DOCTOR WHO CAN.
HELP ME OUT [inaudible]
I'M.
MEDICATION ABORTION IS DONE ONLY
UP TO TEN WEEKS OF PREGNANCY SO
THERE'S PREGNANCY TISSUE THAT
WOULD COME OUT THAT IT EXPELLED
IF THE PERSON IS FIVE TO SIX
WEEKS IT'S IT'S RESEMBLES LIKE.
THE MOST -- VERY SEVERE CASE OF
MENSTRUATION SO IT IS THE
CONTENTS OF THE UTERUS.
COME OUT OVER IN USING PADS OVER
THE COURSE OF A DAY OR TWO OKAY.
EXPANDING THE LIABILITY -- AFTER
ISSUING SUCH OF TAMMY CALLED TO
STUDENTS SO IF THERE'S ANY
COMPLICATIONS.
SEVERE AND FOURTEEN
COMPLICATIONS OF THOSE CHILDREN
BODY -- AND THE HOST COULD NOT
BE -- RESPONSIBLE.
SO I'VE ONLY I WOULD LIKE TO
ANSWER THAT SO BE NO DIFFERENT
THAN WHEN AS SOON BECAUSE TO THE
HEALTH CARE CENTER AND GETS A
SUICIDE COUNSELING.
IF THAT STUDENT THEN ULTIMATELY
COMMITTED SUICIDE IS THE DISEASE --
THE U. S. SEATS ISSUE ARE YOU
SEE RESPONSIBLE FOR THAT.
SAID THE HEALTH CARE CENTERS
ALSO OFFERED DIABETIC COUNSELING
IF THE STUDENT WENT INTO A
DIABETIC COMA WITH THE HEALTH
CARE CENTER THEN BE RESPONSIBLE
FOR THAT AS WELL.
SO IT'S SIMILAR TO THOSE ISSUES.
AND AND REGARDLESS OF WHETHER
THE STUDENT RECEIVES A MEDICATED
MAN MEDICATION FOR THE MEDICAID
ABORTION.
ON CAMPUS OR OFF CAMPUS THEY
WILL STILL BE GOING BACK TO
THEIR DORM ROOM [inaudible]
I PERSONALLY FEEL -- THAT --
THIS KIND OF ISSUE IS SOME MORE
PERSONAL.
RATHER THAN INSTITUTION THE
CAMPUS IS.
OUT WOULD HAVE TO STEP IN.
AND THAT ENCOURAGE AND HELP ON
HOW TO CONDUCT.
THEM.
IT IS ACTUALLY -- BEAUJON.
AND SO IT IS A SOLEMN NOW MY
MORAL ISSUE A WOULD NOT BE ABLE
TO SUPPORT [inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
DOCTOR WEBER.
YES I WANT -- TO I WANT I WANT
TO THANK SENATOR LEAHY BEFORE
BEING PERSISTENT AND BRINGING
THIS FORWARD I KNOW THIS IS A
DIFFICULT ISSUE FOR MANY OF
FOLKS TO UNDERSTAND BECAUSE THEY
ARE COMPLETE.
THE BASIC INFLATING THE ISSUE
WITH THE NORMAL ABORTION THAT
YOU SEE THAT HAPPENS IN A
HOSPITAL MEDICAL FACILITY WHERE
YOU HAVE TO HAVE A LOT MORE
STAFFING.
AND THAT IS NOT THE CASE WITH
THIS THIS IS SOMETHING THAT
ALREADY EXIST -- WITH IS A BLOCK
FROM CAMPUS OR A MILE FROM
CAMPUS THE SAME PROCEDURES THERE.
AND THE SAME RISK IS THE S. OUR
YOUNG PEOPLE ARE GOING TO BE
INVOLVED IN THAT -- YOU KNOW
HAVING SPENT -- MOST OF MY LIFE
FOR THE UNIVERSITY WORKING WITH
STUDENTS FOR OVER FORTY YEARS.
OF AND HAVING BEEN INVOLVED WITH
A NUMBER OF STUDENTS WHO ARE IN
A CRISIS SUCH AS THIS -- I KNOW
THAT IT'S A DIFFICULT TIME FOR
THEM AND THE FRIENDLY PLACE TO
BE IS A PLACE WHERE THEY ARE
MOST COMFORTABLE AND AND FEEL
THEY KNOW THE INDIVIDUALS.
HAVE HAD STUDENTS WHO HAVE TO
TRAVEL OFF CAMPUS AND IT WASN'T
HOURS AND HOURS THAT THEY HAD TO
GO AS WE RIGHT IN THE HEART OF
SAN DIEGO.
BUT THEY WERE GOING TO A A PLACE
THEY DID THEY WERE FAMILIAR WITH.
OFTENTIMES THESE ARE STUDENTS
WHO COME TO THIS CAMPUS WHO KNOW
VERY LITTLE ABOUT THE CITY OTHER
THAN THE IMMEDIATE ENVIRONMENT
WHERE THEY GO TO SCHOOL AND
WHETHER PART IT IS BUT THEY HAVE
NO.
REAL CONNECTIONS TO THE MEDICAL
A COMMUNITY OR ANYTHING LIKE
THAT IN THEIR ONLY SOURCE REALLY
OF MEDICAL CARE IS THE STUDENT
CENTER.
AND THEY HANDLE A LOT OF
DIFFERENT ISSUES I MEAN IT'S NOT
THAT THEY GO IS JUST FOR COLDER
THE FLU THEY HANDLE AN AWFUL LOT
OF STUDENT ISSUES AND ILLNESSES
THAT OCCUR -- ESPECIALLY FOR THE
FIRST YEAR STUDENTS WHO WHO MAY
HAVE SOME FORM OF HEPATITIS A
MAY HAVE ALL OF THE KINDS OF
BILLS ILLNESSES STDS YOU NAME IT.
AND THE CAMPUSES HAVE TO HANDLE
ALL OF THOSE THINGS AND THEY ARE
AS PROFESSIONAL ENOUGH TO KNOW
WHICH ONES CAN BE HANDLED THERE
AND WHICH ONE SHOULD BE HANDLE
SOMEWHERE ELSE.
MY UNDERSTANDING IS THAT THIS
BILL COMES WITH THE SONOGRAM OF
FORUMS TO MAKE IT SO THAT WE
UNDERSTAND WHAT'S GOING ON AND
AND SOLD ACT I STRONGLY.
RECOMMEND THAT WE WE MOVED WITH
THIS BILL MAINLY BECAUSE IT
REALLY IS AN ISSUE OF ACCESS NO
SHE MORE THAN THE ISSUE OF PRO
LIFE OR WHATEVER BECAUSE THOSE
ARE.
ISSUES THAT ARE BEING RESOLVED
OR EITHER NEVER GOING TO BE
RESOLVED. TO EVERYONE'S
SATISFACTION BUT AS LONG AS THEY
ARE THIS IS LEGAL AND IT IS AS
SIMPLE AS IT IS IT MAY SOUNDS
DIFFICULT FOR US IN THIS
GENERATION.
BUT IT'S A SIMPLE AS IT IS -- WE
HAVE TO BASICALLY MAKE SURE THAT
IT THAT STUDENTS HAVE ACCESS TO
IT.
AND I'VE SEEN STUDENTS WHERE.
THEY HAD TO MAKE DIFFICULT
CHOICES THEY'RE MAKING A
DIFFICULT CHOICE ANY TIME THAT
THEY'RE PREGNANT AND THEIR
STUDENT AT MERRITT ON CAMPUS
THEY MAKE DIFFICULT CHOICES
ABOUT WHAT'S GOING TO HAPPEN I
DON'T IMMEDIATELY BUT TO THEM IN
THE FUTURE.
AND IT'S NOT SOMETHING THAT THEY
ENTER INTO LIGHTLY AS MOST FOLKS
THINK THEY DO AND I'VE HAD
STUDENTS ON BOTH SIDES OF THE
ISSUE WHO FOR WHATEVER REASON
DECIDED NOT TO CONTINUE WITH THE
PREGNANCY.
I'VE HAD STUDENTS ON THE OTHER
SIDE WHO CONTINUE TO TERMINATE
WHO WHO TERMINATE A PREGNANCY
AND EACH ONE IT WAS A VERY
DIFFICULT AND A PERSONAL
DECISION.
AND EACH ONE'S LIFE IT WAS OF AN
IMPACTED BY IT OF SO THAT
STUDENTS WHO FELT THAT WAS THE
ONLY THING THEY HAD AVAILABLE TO
THEM.
FOR ECONOMIC REASONS AND A HOST
OF OTHER THINGS HAD TO MAKE
PEACE WITH THE DECISIONS THAT
THEY MAY AND MOVED ON WITH THEIR
LIFE AND SOME OF THEM STILL
WRITE ME TODAY.
WHO'S NOW MARRIED AND HAD KIDS
AND ALL THOSE THINGS AND OTHERS
WHO HAVE THE CHILDREN STILL
WRITE ME TO WOULD DAY WITH A
FIFTEEN YEAR OLD KID THAT THEY
HAD WHEN THEY WERE IN COLLEGE
BUT IT'S A DIFFICULT DECISION.
AND I THINK WE SHOULD NOT MAKE
IT MORE COMPLICATED OR PUT IN
OBSTACLES IN PEOPLE'S WAY WHEN
THEY'RE HAVING SOME LIFE
DECISIONS THAT HAVE TO BE MADE.
BASED ON THEIR VALUES BASED ON
THEIR FAMILY BASED ON THEIR
NEEDS AT THAT PARTICULAR TIME
LIKE I SAID HAVING GONE THROUGH
THIS WITH A NUMBER OF MY
STUDENTS.
I KNOW THAT IT IS NOT AN EASY
TASK IN MY JOB WAS NEVER TO TELL
THEM WHAT TO DO.
BUT TO MAKE SURE THAT THEY
THOUGHT IT THROUGH KNEW WHAT
THEY WANTED TO DO AND IF THEY
NEEDED MORE SUPPORT TO PROVIDE
THAT MORAL SUPPORT FOR THEM --
IT IS -- AND SO I RECOMMEND THAT
WEEK THAT THIS BILL IS SOMETHING
THAT WE MOVE FORWARD WITH MY
COLLEAGUES HAVE ALREADY.
MOVED IT I SEE MY GOOD FRIEND
ARAMBULA WHO IS THE A POSITION
WHO KNOWS HOW UNCOMPLICATED THIS
CAN BE BUT WE DON'T WANT TO
COMPLICATED MORE IN TERMS OF THE
LIVES OF YOUNG PEOPLE THIS IS A
VERY PERSONAL.
DIFFICULT DECISION THE FACT THAT --
STUDENTS TRIED GET IT DONE THE
NORMAL PROCESS WHAT WE SAY WELL
ORGANIZED GET YOUR CAMPUS
TOGETHER.
PUT TOGETHER GOOD PROPOSAL HELP
RAISE MONEY BLAH BLAH THEY TRIED
ALL THAT AND RAN INTO A WALL AND
SOMETIMES THOSE WALLS ARE MORE
POLITICAL THAN THEY ARE ANYTHING
ELSE MEDICAL.
AND AND SO THEN IT BECOMES OUR
RESPONSIBILITY ASK QUESTIONS
WILL STUDENTS REALLY NEED ON THE
CAMPUS STUDENTS AT THE CAP
WONDERFUL HEALTH FACILITIES --
SOME FOLKS EVEN OPPOSED TO THAT
THAT WE HAVE HEALTH FACILITIES
ON CAMPUS IS -- BUT WE
DISCOVERED THAT THE CAMPUS IN
FALL APART BECAUSE WE NOW HAVE A
NICE CLINIC ON CAMPUS THAT MEETS
THE NEEDS OF OUR STUDENTS
BECAUSE STUDENTS COME FROM
EVERYWHERE AND THEY NEED HELP
THEY NEED SUPPORT.
AND THE LAST THING THEY NEED IS
COMPLICATION WHEN THEY HAVE A
CRISIS IN THEIR LIFE AND THEY
NEED THE KIND OF PROFESSIONAL
SUPPORT THEY CAN GET TO MOVE
FORWARD.
SOMEONE THANK YOU FOR BRINGING
THIS FORWARD IN THOSE WHO HELPED
OF THE LAST YEAR TO HAVE.
TO DEAL WITH THE RESOURCES THAT
ARE THERE -- THAT'S NECESSARY TO
OPEN THESE CLINICS OPEN IN A
PROFESSIONAL MANNER AND I ASK
ALL OF YOU HOPEFULLY TO SUPPORT
THIS PROPOSAL AS IT GOES FORWARD.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
DOCTOR LEYVA OF JEWS ME SENATOR
LABEL IF YOU LIKE THE OTHER.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I WILL BE
IMMEDIATELY GOING BACK TO SCHOOL
SO THAT I CAN ABOUT THAT -- I I
REALLY WANT TO THANK EVERYONE
WHO HAS COME OUT TODAY BOTH IN
SUPPORT AND IN OPPOSITION THIS
IS WHAT DEMOCRACY LOOKS LIKE AND
EVERYONE SHOULD BE ABLE TO COME
AND VOICE THEIR OPINION.
I WANT TO ADDRESS A COUPLE
THINGS THAT WERE SAID --
ASSEMBLY MEMBER PATTERSON IN THE
GOVERNOR'S.
VETO MESSAGE HE DID NOT EXPRESS
CLEAR CONCERNS HE ACTUALLY JUST
SAID THAT HE DID NOT FIND IT ON
REASONABLE FOR SOMEONE TO TRAVEL
OFF CAMPUS.
I DISAGREED WITH HIM PUBLICLY
OVER THAT AND I STILL DISAGREE
WITH HIM OVER THAT.
AND I THINK THAT AS A DOCTOR
WEBER SAID.
WE'RE NOT TELLING ANYONE WHAT TO
DO HERE WE'RE NOT TELLING ANY
STUDENT TO HAVE AN ABORTION THIS
IS SIMPLY ABOUT CHOICE AND IT'S
ABOUT ACCESS IT'S ABSOLUTELY
CLEAR.
THAT BY RECENT EFFORTS ACROSS
THE COUNTRY THAT ACCESS ON
ABORTION AND WOMEN'S RIGHTS L.
G. B. T. RIGHTS IN GENERAL ARE
UNDER ATTACK.
WELL OTHER STATES ARE TAKING A
GIANT LEAP BACK TO THE DAYS OF
FORCED PREGNANCY AND MISOGYNY SB
TWENTY FOUR WILL CONTINUE TO
MOVE CALIFORNIA FORWARD.
BY REAFFIRMING THE
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHT OF COLLEGE
STUDENTS TO ACCESS ABORTION CARE
ON CAMPUS.
ALL CALIFORNIANS INCLUDING
COLLEGE STUDENTS SHOULD HAVE
ACCESS TO THE FULL RANGE AND
CHOICES OF REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH
CARE SO THEY PLAN THEIR LIVES
THEIR FUTURES.
AND THEY CAN DECIDE WHEN TO
INCORPORATE A FAMILY INTO THEIR
LIFE I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU I'D ALSO LIKE TO THANK --
WITNESSES ON BOTH SIDES FOR
COMING FORWARD TODAY THANK YOU
FOR EXPRESSING YOUR VIEWS AND
DOING IT SO IN AN ORDERLY -- AND
AND CIVIL -- WAY I APPRECIATE
THAT I I ALSO WANT.
TO EXPRESS MY OWN OPINION --
THAT I I ALSO BELIEVE THAT THIS
BILL IS IS NOT ABOUT -- PRO
CHOICE.
OR PRO LIFE THAT THAT WAS
DECIDED WHEN I WAS A COLLEGE
STUDENT BACK IN NINETEEN SEVENTY
THREE IS THE LAW OF THE LAND.
AND BUT IT IS ABOUT WHAT IS
AVAILABLE TO STUDENTS AND AS
WE'VE HEARD FROM -- STUDENTS A
BILL OVER THE PAST YEAR FOR THE
NEED FOR MORE MENTAL -- A
SERVICES A MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES I THINK THAT I HAVE
BEEN EDUCATED IN THE PAST YEAR
SENATOR WITH YOUR BILL I'VE
LEARNED A LOT MORE THAN I KNEW
PREVIOUSLY.
FROM A YEAR AND I DO BELIEVE
THAT THIS IS SOMETHING THAT CSU
AND YOU SEE CAN PROVIDE WITH
THAT SAID I WOULD ALSO ASK THE
AUTHORED TO LOOK.
AT PAGES SEVEN AND EIGHT OF THE
ANALYSIS AND TO LOOK AT THE
QUESTIONS OF BILLING AND TO SEE
HOW WE RESOLVE THOSE THOSE
ISSUES.
SO WE'VE HAD A MOTION BY DOCTOR
RUMBULA SECOND BY MR GABRIEL OF
MADAM CHAIR IF YOU'D PLEASE --
CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
MEDINA AYE MEDINA AYE CHOI.
CHOI NO ARAMBULA.
ARAMBULA I BLOOM.
BLOOM I GABRIEL -- WHEN -- WHEN
I KILEY?
KILEY NO LEVINE.
LEVINE I LOW.
LOW I PATTERSON.
PATTERSON NO SANTIAGO WEBER HI
WEBER HI. SEVEN THREE THE BILL
IS OUT WE WILL LEAVE IT OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR THANK YOU MEMBERS.
THANK YOU ALL FOR COMING.
WE'LL GO TO ITEM EIGHT SB FOUR
EIGHTY FOUR CENTER PORTANTINO
[inaudible]
YEAH [inaudible]
WELL -- TRYING TO GET DRESSED UP
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY THEIR
SENATOR [inaudible]
WELCOME [inaudible]
THANK YOU -- I LIKE THAT.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS.
THEY'RE PRESENTING SB FOUR
EIGHTY FOUR WHICH WOULD
SIGNIFICANTLY SIMPLIFY.
THE TRANSFER PROCESS FOR
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGE
STUDENTS BASICALLY IF YOU GET
THE COURSE WORK DONE YOU SHOULD
GET THE DEGREE.
YOU SHOULDN'T HAVE TO WORRY
ABOUT WHEN YOU GRADUATE HIGH
SCHOOL YOU DON'T HAVE TO GO
APPLY. TO GET THE DIPLOMA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES SHOULD
FUNCTION THE SAME WAY I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR MY VOTE.
ANY WITNESSES IN SUPPORT WE DO
HAVE ONE BUT I DON'T I THINK
THERE SHOULD.
PLEASE COME IN.
TIMES LIKE YOU GOT A LOT OF
SUPPORT FOR THIS BILL SAYS
THAT'S WHY I CUT IT SHORT OKAY --
YOU CAN GO AHEAD AND WHAT WHEN
WE GO AHEAD ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
SEEING NONE WE HAD A MOTION BY.
MR LOW I RESPECTFULLY ETCETERA
BY [inaudible]
DR RUMBULA.
I DON'T SEE ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE SO
MADAM CHAIR FEET PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
MEDINA HI MEDINA I CHOI HI CHOI
I ARAMBULA.
ARAMBULA I BLOOM.
BLOOM I GABRIEL -- WHEN -- WHEN
I KILEY?
KILEY I LEVINE.
LEVINE I LOW.
LOW I PATTERSON.
PATTERSON I SANTIAGO WEBER
[inaudible]
WEBER I'D. ELEVEN ZERO YOUR BILL
IS OUT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU SENATOR.
WE HAVE ONE MORE OKAY.
SO WILL MOVED UP ITEM ELEVEN SB.
FIVE SIXTY EIGHT THANK YOU --
THIS ONE I WOULD LIKE TO TAKE A
MOMENT SINCE THE DOCTOR BY OUR
CAME HERE FROM GLENDALE. TO TALK
A LITTLE BIT ABOUT -- SB FIVE
SIXTY EIGHT WHICH WOULD
AUTHORIZE GLENDALE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE'S GOVERNING BOARD
PURSUANT TO A MEMORANDUM OF
UNDERSTANDING TO PROVIDE.
APRIL TWENTY FOURTH SHALL BE A
GLENDALE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
HOLIDAY -- IN COMMEMORATION OF
THE ARMENIAN GENOCIDE -- WHEN
GLENDALE UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT
DECIDED TO CLOSE OUT OF RESPECT
FOR APRIL TWENTY FOURTH UNDER
EDUCATION BECAUSE A LOT TO DO
THAT NOT LOSE
ANY ADA UNFORTUNATE COMMITTEE
COLLEGES DON'T HAVE THE SAME
FLEXIBILITY SO WHEN GLENDALE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE WANTED TO
COMMEMORATE APRIL TWENTY FOURTH
WHICH IS THE DAY -- THE FIRST
GENOCIDE OF THE TWENTIETH
CENTURY -- IS COMMEMORATED THEY
ACTUALLY LOSE.
MONEY WHEN THEY DO THAT IN THIS
BILL WOULD ALLOW THEM -- IN A
DISTRICT FRANK ARRIVE THE
LARGEST ARMENIAN AMERICAN
POPULATION IN THE COUNTRY AND A
STUDENT BODY THAT IS A
SIGNIFICANTLY.
ARMENIAN AMERICAN IT WOULD ALLOW
GLENDALE COMMITTEE COLLEGE TO
PROPERLY.
AND APPROPRIATE COMMEMORATE THE
GENOCIDE AND NOT LOSE ANY
REVENUE AND WITH ME I HAVE THE
PRESIDENT OF THE COLLEGE DR
DAVID BYE BYE ARE HERE. TO SAY A
FEW WORDS WELCOME WELCOME TO YOU
TO AND CHAIR MEDINA THANK YOU
VERY MUCH AND MEMBERS OF THE
ASSEMBLY HIGHER ED COMMITTEE.
I A SENATOR PORTANTINO HAS
INDICATED GLENDALE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE SERVES A CITY AND THE
REGION WITH THE HIGHEST
CONCENTRATION OF ARMENIAN POP
POPULATION OUTSIDE OF ARMENIA
PROPER.
AND WITHIN THE ARMENIAN DIASPORA
ACROSS THE WORLD WE'RE PROUD
THAT CLOSE 240% OF OUR CREDIT
STUDENTS AND 50% OF OUR NON
CREDIT STUDENTS ARE OF ARMENIAN
ETHNICITY. FOR A NUMBER OF YEARS
OUR COLLEGE IS ANNUALLY HELD A
NUMBER OF COMMEMORATIONS
EDUCATION AND AWARENESS EVENTS
DURING APRIL LEADING TO THE
APRIL TWENTY FOURTH ARMENIAN
GENOCIDE REMEMBRANCE DAY.
HOWEVER ON APRIL TWENTY FOURTH
DUE TO THE STATE LAW REGULATIONS
AND INTERPRETATIONS OF TITLE
FIVE REGULATIONS WE HAVE NOT
BEEN A AS A COLLEGE TO DECLARE.
A PUBLIC HOLIDAY SO THAT OUR
STUDENTS ARE FACULTY OR STAFF
COULD JOIN IN GLENDALE AND LA
REGION COMMEMORATIVE EVENTS
MARCHES AND CONTEMPLATE OF TIME
KEEPING THE ARMENIAN GENOCIDE IN
PEOPLE'S MINDS SO THAT NEVER
AGAIN.
WILL WE ACCEPT GENOCIDE OF ANY
RACE OR ETHNICITY AND NEVER
FORGET THE ATROCITIES TO
HUMANKIND THAT OCCURRED.
CENTER PORTANTINO'S SENATE BILL
FIVE SIXTY EIGHT AS AMENDED IS
CONSISTENT WITH KEY PRINCIPLES
THAT REFLECT CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGE SYSTEM ONE THE
MISSION TO MEET AND REFLECT THE
EDUCATIONAL NEEDS OF OUR LOCAL
COMMUNITIES.
THE ROLE OF LOCAL ELECTED BOARDS
TO KEEP THIS LOCAL FOCUS AT THE
CENTER OF THE WORK OF THE LOCAL
COMMUNITY COLLEGE AND THE
IMPORTANCE OF CONSULTATION WITH
OUR LOCAL EMPLOYEE ORGANIZATIONS.
FURTHER SENATE BILL FIVE SIX
SIXTY EIGHT AS AMENDED DOES NOT
COST THE STATE AND LOCAL
TAXPAYERS ANY MONEY.
AND IT DOES NOT LESSEN OUR
OBLIGATION AS A COLLEGE TO
MAINTAIN THE NUMBER OF
INSTRUCTIONAL DAYS REQUIRED BY
LAW STATE REGULATIONS AND
ACCREDITATION STANDARDS.
THE GLENDALE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
BOARD OF TRUSTEES EXPRESSES
GREAT APPRECIATION TO SENATOR
PORTANTINO FOR TAKING THE LEAD
IN MOVING FORWARD THIS
LEGISLATION.
AND WHICH IS IMPORTANT TO OUR
COMMUNITY AND IT'S COLLEGE AND
WE ARE CHEN AYE VOTE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
CNN ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
[inaudible]
ANY TWEETERS.
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE [inaudible]
DR RUMBLE.
IF IT'S POSSIBLE SENATOR
PORTANTINO -- I BELIEVE THE
ARMENIAN GENOCIDE -- RECOGNIZES
THE FORGET ME NOT FLOWER -- TO
REMEMBER AND NEVER FORGET AND IF
YOU CAN NOT FORGET TO ADD ME AS
A CO AUTHOR.
AS THIS BILL GOES FORWARD I
WOULD APPRECIATE THAT.
BE HONORED TO HAVE YOU THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
A CENTER WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
I WOULD THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISTER CHAIR AND I APPRECIATE
YOUR YOUR STAFF AND YOUR
INTEREST IN.
DISCUSSING WITH THIS ISSUE WITH
ME LAST WEEK -- IT SHOWS THE
IMPORTANCE OF AND I APPRECIATE
THAT -- THIS IS AN APPROPRIATE
WAY -- TO APPROPRIATELY
COMMEMORATE THE GENOCIDE IN THE
DISTRICT WITH A WITH A
POPULATION THAT WOULD GREATLY
APPRECIATE IT AND SO I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU.
WE WE WE WE WE WILL NEED A
MOTION BUT BEFORE.
MOVE BY DOCTOR RUMBLE AS SECOND
BY DOCTOR WEBER -- AND BEFORE I
ASKED HER TO CALL THE ROLL I
JUST WANT TO SAY THANK YOU FOR
THE CONVERSATIONS THAT WE HAVE
AND VERY MUCH SUPPORT THE IDEA.
OF OF EVERY LIKE YOUR OWN TO BE
ABLE TO COMMEMORATE AND AND MAY
BE MOVING FORWARD -- YOU KNOW WE
LOOK FOR LOOK TO OTHER AREAS AS
WELL.
THAT MAY -- COMMEMORATED PAT I
THINK LIKE YOU FOUND A GREAT
SOLUTION TO THE ISSUE.
THAT YOU HAD.
SO THE MOTION WAS -- BY DOCTOR
RUMBULA SECOND BY DOCTOR WEBER --
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
MEDINA HI MEDINA I CHOI.
CHOICE I ARAMBULA.
ARAMBULA I BLOOM.
BLOOM I GABRIEL -- WHEN -- WHEN
I KILEY?
KILEY AYE LEVINE.
LEVINE I LOW LOW I PATTERSON.
PATTERSON I SANTIAGO.
WEBER [inaudible]
WEBER I'D. TEN ZERO THE BILL IS
OUT WE WILL LEAVE IT OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN -- TO PRINCIPLE.
TO SO WE WILL GO TO FILE ITEM
FOURTEEN SB [inaudible]
SEVEN ONE SIX SENATOR MITCHELL.
THE WELCOME CENTER.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
AND MEMBERS.
I DON'T KNOW ABOUT YOU BUT A
LONG AFTERNOON IT'S BEEN
[inaudible]
IT HAS.
THE BILL I'M THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR THAT [inaudible]
J..
TWO TODAY TO PRESENT SENATE BILL
SEVEN SIXTEEN WHICH WILL TAKE A
CORRECTIVE STEP TOWARDS ENSURING
THAT INCARCERATED YOUTH WHO HOLD
A HIGH SCHOOL DIPLOMA HAVE
ACCESS TO A COLLEGE EDUCATION.
AND CAREER VOTE TRAINING
CURRENTLY CALIFORNIA LAW DOES
NOT REQUIRE JUVENILE FACILITIES
TO PROVIDE POST SECONDARY
PROGRAMS FOR THESE YOU.
STATUTES ONLY REQUIRES COUNTY
OFFICES OF EDUCATION AND THE
DIVISION OF JUVENILE FACILITY TO
PROVIDE A FULL HIGH SCHOOL
CURRICULUM TO YOU CAN KATHY
WHO'VE NOT YET COMPLETED HIGH
SCHOOL.
ALTHOUGH THERE IS NO STATUTORY
OBLIGATION FOR FEW WEEKS TO
PROVIDE POST SECONDARY EDUCATION
PROGRAM THE HIGH SCHOOL
GRADUATES IN STEADY STATE
REGULATIONS DO REQUIRE COUNTY
PROBATION TO ENSURE THAT ALL
YOUTH IN THEIR FACILITIES.
ARE TREATED EQUALLY WITH REGARD
TO EDUCATIONAL PROGRAMS.
ADDITIONALLY THE YOUTH BILL OF
RIGHTS STATES THAT YOU IN D. J.
F. FACILITIES HAVE THE RIGHT TO
RECEIVE.
A QUALITY EDUCATION.
THE YOUTH BILL OF RIGHTS DOES
NOT PLACE AGER GRADE LEVEL
LIMITATIONS ON THESE RIGHTS.
WHERE WHERE CONCERNS FROM THE
PROBATION OFFICERS REGARDING THE
TIMING OF SEMESTER SCHEDULES A
WE THE MINUTE THE BILL TO
SPECIALLY ADDRESS COURSE
ELIGIBILITY AND COURSE
SCHEDULING CONCERNS -- WE
UNDERSTAND IS CONCERNED ABOUT
UNFUNDED INFRASTRUCTURE AND
STAFFING COSTS RELATING TO
ONLINE COURSES.
AGAIN A BILL BY ONE OF YOUR
COLLEAGUES ASSEMBLYMAN GIBSON AB
TWENTY FOUR FORTY EIGHT ALREADY
MANDATES THAT COUNTY FACILITIES
PROVIDE ACCESS TO INTERNET AND
COMPUTER TECHNOLOGY. FOR
PURPOSES OF EDUCATION THESE YOU
COULD BE ELIGIBLE FOR TUITION
WAIVERS THEREFORE THERE SHOULD
NOT BE ANY ADDITIONAL COSTS
ASSOCIATED WITH TUITION.
WE UNDERSTAND ABOUT THE VERY
LENGTH OF STAY IN JUVENILE
DETENTION FACILITIES WE ALSO
AMENDED THE BILL TO NARROW THE
MANDATE TO ONLY ONLINE COURSES
SO THAT OUR YOUTH IS ABLE TO
CONTINUE THEIR EDUCATION ONLINE
ONCE THEY'RE RELEASED FROM THE
FACILITY.
ANOTHER CONCERN STATES THAT THE
BILL SHOULD INSTEAD REQUIRE A
POSTSECONDARY AND VOCATIONAL
PLAN.
WE ABSOLUTELY AGREE THAT THE
INTENT OF THIS BILL SHOULD BE
BOTH THIRD WITH THE INCLUSION OF
AN EDUCATIONAL AND VOCATIONAL
PLAN BUT IT SHOULD NOT BE TAKEN
IN LIEU OF ACTUALLY PROVIDING
PROGRAMMING.
WE LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING
OUR WORK WITH PROBATION OFFICERS
ON BOTH THREE IN THE BILL WITH
THE INCLUSION OF THIS PROVISION.
A QUALITY EDUCATION HAS THE
POWER TO READ THE LETTER DIRECT
LIVES OF ANY YOUNG PERSON
ESPECIALLY THOSE LAWS THE WHOSE
LIVES HAVE BEEN TOUCHED BY THE
JUVENILE JUSTICE SYSTEM.
EDUCATIONAL EDUCATION AND
VOCATIONAL TRAINING DEVELOPED
OCCUPATIONAL SKILLS AND LEADS TO
PRODUCTIVE CAREER PATH WHICH IN
TURN WE NOW THE OBVIOUS REDUCES
RECIDIVISM.
AND FUTURE INVOLVEMENT WITH THE
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM.
I HAVE TO ADVOCATES WITH ME HERE
TODAY LUCY CARTER WITH THE YOUTH
LAWCENTER AND JACQUELINE
RODRIGUEZ A STUDENT GO AHEAD.
AT THE COLLEGE OF SAN MATTEO I
ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
HELLO MY NAME IS JACQUELINE
RODRIGUEZ I FIRST WANT TO THE
JUVENILE HALL WHEN I WAS TWELVE
YEARS OLD IN SEVENTH GRADE.
I GOT OUT FOR A MONTH AND THEN
WENT BACK IN AND LITERALLY DID
THREE YEARS I DO NOT CAMP GROUP
HOMES THE JUVENILE HALL OR ON
THE RUN.
WHILE I WAS IN THE CAMP
EDUCATION WAS SO HARD FOR ME IT
WAS ONE CURRICULUM FOR EVERYONE
AND I WAS LEARNING WHAT THE
OTHER GIRLS WERE LEARNING EVEN
THOUGH THEY WERE MUCH OLDER.
THAN A LOT OF THE GIRLS
GRADUATED FROM HIGH SCHOOL WHILE
THEY WERE STILL IN CUSTODY.
AND AFTER THE GRADUATION THEY
STILL CAME TO COURT SCHOOL WITH
THOSE BUT THEY SAT IN THE BACK
OF THE CLASSROOM AND DID NOTHING
BUT COLORING AND WRITING IN
JOURNALS OR WRITING LETTERS.
ARE THEY WENT OUTSIDE IN THE
GARDEN THEY HAD NOTHING TO STUDY
NOTEBOOKS ARE EDUCATION PROGRAMS
WERE OFFERED TO THEM.
I DIDN'T THINK IT WAS FAIR
BECAUSE I BECAME CLOSE THOSE
GIRLS AND I NEED A POTENTIAL
THEY TELL ME THE GOAL THEN THE
DREAMS THEY HAD ONE WANTED TO BE
A DOCTOR ANOTHER A PROBATION
OFFICER.
BUT I WILL SAY TO THEM THERE'S
NO HOPE FOR US WHO IS GOING TO
HELP US.
IT DIDN'T GIVE ME MOTIVATION
BECAUSE THESE INTELLIGENT GIRLS
HAD JUST FINISHED HER HIGH
SCHOOL EDUCATION AND THERE WAS
NOTHING FOR THEM TO DO WITH IT.
WE TALKED ABOUT THEM GOING TO
COLLEGE BUT THEY GOT NOTHING TO
HELP THEM FIGURE OUT HOW TO DO
IT WHILE THEY WERE STILL INSIDE.
NO RESOURCES NO REAL OPPORTUNITY
AND NOW I KNOW THAT ONLY TWO OF
THOSE GIRLS WENT ON TO COLLEGE
AND THOSE TO STUDY COSMETOLOGY.
NOW I'M IN MY THIRD YEAR OF
STUDY AT COLLEGE OF SOME TAIL I
AM HOPING TO RECEIVE ASSOCIATES
DEGREES AND POOR SUBJECTS.
WHAT I EXPERIENCE INSIDE DID
PUSH ME TO ONE A COLLEGE
EDUCATION BECAUSE I WANTED TO
BREAK THE CYCLE BREAK THE SCHOOL
TO PRISON PIPELINE EDUCATE
MYSELF AND BE A ROLE MODEL FOR
MY KIDS?
NOW BEING A COLLEGE STUDENT I
FEEL READY FOR ANYTHING I'M SO
EXCITED TO BE SUCCESSFUL AND TO
LEARN AND TO LEARN FROM OTHERS
AND JOB OTHERS LEARN FROM ME.
I STRONGLY SUPPORT SB SEVEN ONE
SIX BECAUSE I BELIEVE THAT ALL
YOUTH WERE INCARCERATED HOW FULL
POTENTIAL LIKE ANYONE ELSE.
AND THEY JOB EVERY OPPORTUNITY
EVEN MORE OPPORTUNITIES THAN
EVERYONE ELSE BECAUSE OF WHAT
THEY ARE GOING TO AND THE
POSITION THEY ARE AND AS THE
SEVEN ONE SIX PROVIDES THE
NECESSARY OPPORTUNITY FOR THEM
TO GO TO COLLEGE.
BREAK THE CYCLE AND MAKE A
DIFFERENCE IN OUR SOCIETY I ASK
YOU TO VOTE FOR SB SEVEN ONE SIX
THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS LUCY SOL SIEGEL
CARTER AND I'M THE POLICY
ADVOCATE THE USE LAWCENTER.
SO YOU HEARD MS RODRIGUEZ'S
TESTIMONY -- I WISH THAT HER
EXPERIENCE WAS UNIQUE BUT IT IS
NOT.
THERE'S A GROWING PERCENTAGE OF
YOUTH WHO ARE IN CUSTODY HAVE
THEIR HIGH SCHOOL DIPLOMAS AND
HAVE NO EDUCATIONAL PROGRAMMING
FOR THEM -- A BILL WAS PASSED IN
TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN THAT ALLOWS
YOUNG PEOPLE -- IN CUSTODY TO
GRADUATE WITH MINIMUM STATE
REQUIREMENTS.
AND THE PERCENTAGE OF YOUNG
PEOPLE IN CUSTODY WHO HAVE THEIR
HIGH SCHOOL DIPLOMAS.
IS ANYWHERE FROM BETWEEN TEN AND
15% IN THE COUNTY FACILITIES BUT
AS HIGH AS 50% IN THE STATE
FACILITIES.
AND I WANT TO HIGHLIGHT THAT WE
HAVE SOME POST SECONDARY ED
PROGRAMS ALREADY IN FACILITIES --
AROUND THE STATE WE HAVE SOME
MODEL PROGRAMS AND THEY ARE
DOING WHAT THE SENATOR MENTIONED
WHICH IS.
THEY ARE ALLOWING YOUNG PEOPLE
TO TAKE ONLINE CLASSES IN
CUSTODY AND THEN WHEN THEY LEAVE
THE FACILITY CONTINUED TAKING
THOSE ONLINE COURSES WHEN THEY
COME OUT.
SO NO CHALLENGES WITH REGARD TO
SCHEDULING IT DOES TAKE SOME
FLEXIBILITY -- BUT THEY'RE ABLE
TO DO IT.
AND WE TALKED ABOUT COSTS
ALREADY SO I WON'T I WON'T GO
INTO THAT -- AND BUT WHAT I
WOULD LIKE TO SAY IS THAT THESE
YOUNG PEOPLE WANT TO CONTINUE
THEIR EDUCATION.
THEY WANT TO BE ABLE TO RE
ENVISION THEMSELVES.
SO WE WE REALLY SHOULDN'T
PENALIZE THEM FOR BEING
MOTIVATED TO FINISH HIGH SCHOOL
WHILE IN CUSTODY GIVEN
ESPECIALLY GIVEN ALL THE
CHALLENGES ARE FACING.
SO RATHER THAN PENALIZE THEM LET
SUPPORT THEM TO CONTINUE THEIR
EDUCATION WITHOUT DELAY AND WITH
THE TIME THEY HAVE WHILE THEY
ARE STILL IN CUSTODY.
SO FOR THESE REASONS FOR YOUTH
LAWCENTER ASKS FOR YOUR AYE VOTE
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS PAMELAGIVES
REPRESENTING THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY OFFICE OF EDUCATION WOULD
LIKE TO THANK THE AUTHOR AND THE
SPONSORS FOR THE EXTRAORDINARY%
BILL.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON BRIANNA BRANDS OF
THE CALIFORNIA ADDS COALITION IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
MAN DOES WORK ON THE OFFICE
YOU'RE CALIFORNIA IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
MARIA IS A FERNANDES WITH THE
CALIFORNIA CATHOLIC CONFERENCE
IN SUPPORT.
KATHY HALL WITH THE CALIFORNIA
STATE PTA AND SUPPORT.
KATIE BLESS PROJECT CHANGE
COLLEGES SAN MATTEO IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
BONNIE MORALIS FORMALLY
INCARCERATED NOW A COLLEGE WHO
SAN MATTEO STUDENT PROJECT
CHANGE.
NICK WAS JUST SO FORMING CRISIS
STUDENT UCLA IN STRONG SUPPORT.
AND YOU MAYES FISHER WITH THE
LEAGUE OF WOMEN VOTERS OF
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
CHECK OF RECORD NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORK
OFFERING CHAPTER IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
RUN QUAN -- STUDENT AT
UNIVERSITY OF MINNESOTA LAW
SCHOOL IN STRONG SUPPORT.
SHELLY MILLING COLLEGE IN THE
SAN MATTEO FACULTY IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
ANY TERRORISTS CONGESTION MATTEO
STAFF IN STRONG SUPPORT.
TORONTO CHAPEL COLLEGES SAN
MATTEO AND STRONG SUPPORT.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
[inaudible]
ANY WINNERS.
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
THE COMMITTEE.
AT A MOTION.
SENATE REVIEW LIKE TO CLOSE I
ASKED THE GUY VOTE.
WITH A MOTION BY MISTER LOW IF I
COULD GET A SECOND.
SECOND BY DOCTOR RUMBULA.
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THE BILL
FORD AND MADAM SECRETARY COULD
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO TO
THE PUBLIC SAFETY COMMITTEE.
MEDINA AYE MEDINA AYE CHOI.
CHOI I ARAMBULA.
ARAMBULA I BLOOM.
BLOOM I GABRIEL -- WHEN -- WHEN
I?
KILEY.
KILEY I LEVINE LEVINE I LOW.
LOW I PATTERSON.
PATTERSON AYE SANTIAGO WEBER
[inaudible]
WEBER HI. TEN ZERO THE BILL IS
OUT WE WILL LEAVE IT OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS APPRECIATE YOU
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
WE'LL GO TO ITEM TEN SENATOR
ROTH [inaudible]
MISTER CHAIR [inaudible]
RESEARCHER.
MAKE IT A POINT OF CLARIFICATION
ON THE TO AUTHOR IS THAT I A C.
PRESENT IN THIS COMMITTEE RIGHT
NOW THAT THERE IS A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION ON BOTH SIDES OF
THE AISLE FOR THE TWO SENATORS
IN THIS IS OF IT IN IS THAT
CORRECT.
YES THANK YOU VERY MUCH
[inaudible]
WELCOME CENTER.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN OF THE
BILL.
AS CHAIR AND A GOOD DAY FOR YOU
CENTER IF -- IF YOU'D PREFER I
RESPECTFULLY AS FOR AN AYE VOTE.
WE'LL GO WITH THAT.
WE'LL GO WITH THAT HAS BEEN A
GOOD DAY FOR YOU.
WELL SOME PLACES.
SO WE HAD A MOTION BY.
MR LOW A SECOND.
BY MR BLOOM -- THANK YOU CENTER
FOR BRINGING THE BILL FORD -- AS
A FORMER TEACHER OF ADULT
LEARNERS ARE VERY MUCH --
SUPPORT YOUR BILL THANK YOU
MISTER.
SO MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE MEDINA
AYE MEDINA AYE CHOI.
CHOI I ARAMBULA ARAMBULA I BLOOM.
BLOOM I GABRIEL -- WHEN -- WHEN
I KILEY?
KILEY I LEVINE.
LEVINE I LOW.
LOW I PATTERSON.
PATTERSON I SANTIAGO WEBER
[inaudible]
WEBER I TEN ZERO THE BILL IS OUT
WE'LL LEAVE IT OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
AND MEMBERS.
AND SEE MISTER ALLEN WILL COLUMN
UP.
FILE ITEM ONE SB
THREE WELCOME CENTER. FIVE OF
THE BILL SECOND WHY I THANK YOU
SO MUCH MEMBERS I I HEARD THE
COMMENTS OF ME -- I WITH THE
RISE OF THE PREVIOUS BILL BY THE
NUMBER AND I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS -- OR GET MORE
DETAIL AS A WITH THIS BILL BUT I
THINK IT'S AN IMPORTANT THING
FOR CORNING INFORMATION AT THE
HIGHER EDUCATION LEVEL.
AND I RESPECT FASTER ABOUT.
AND I DO HAVE IN THIS AREA.
WE HAD A VERY GOOD.
MEMBERS FROM THE CAMPAIGN
BECAUSE OPPORTUNITY.
IF FOLKS ARE JUST AND ASK
QUESTIONS.
SO WE HAD A MOTION BY DOCTOR
RUMBULA SECOND.
OF MEASURE BELOW.
A SECOND BY MISTER LOW.
THAT'S IT ANY QUESTIONS COMMENTS --
MATTER SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
THANKS A MILLION.
I THINK WE'RE GOOD.
WE'RE GOOD.
I DON'T KNOW SAID.
I AM SHE I JUST WANNA MAKE SURE
IT IS THERE ANY OPPOSITION TO
THIS BILL.
BETWEEN -- OKAY [inaudible]
CALIFORNIA.
HE SAID THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
REACH OUT TO STAFF I JUST WANTED
TO RAISE THE ISSUE -- THAT WE'VE
RAVED AND RAVED RAISED EXCUSE P.
AND PREVIOUS BIRD IS THE BILL
THAT WE STILL PREFER. TO HAVE A
SEAT ON THE STATUTORY COMMITTEE
AS OPPOSED TO THE ADVISORY BOARD.
I DO KNOW THAT THE GOAL OF YOUR
BILL THOUGH I'M FOR YOUR STAFF
IS INDEPENDENCE SO WE UNDERSTAND
THAT AND WE STILL WE STILL WE
STILL KIND OF ARE YOU THAT IF
IT'S GONNA BE ACCORDING TO BODY
WE WOULD.
LIKE TO HAVE A SEE THE TABLE A
SEAT AT THE TABLE -- BUT DO YOU
UNDERSTAND THE GOAL OF YOUR BILL.
THANK YOU.
AND SENATOR ALLEN WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE.
I RESPECT FASHION VOTE I I
CERTAINLY WILL CONTINUE
DISCUSSIONS WITH THAT ALL THE
UNITS IN WEREN'T KEEP WERE
DEFINITELY A GAUGE THEM AND AND
I AND I SEE IN MY NOTES THAT --
SOMETHING MEMBERS LOW AND EGGMAN
HAVE INTRODUCED SIMILAR BILLS
AND I'M WERE AND ENCOURAGE. TO
GATHER AND COME TOGETHER YEAH.
SO WE HAD THE MOTION.
BUT MR BLOOM SECOND BY.
MISTER LOW MAN SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE MEDINA
AYE MEDINA AYE CHOI.
CHOI I ARAMBULA.
ARAMBULA I BLOOM.
BLOOM I GABRIEL -- WHEN -- WHEN
I KILEY?
KILEY I LEVINE.
LEVINE I LOW.
LOW I PATTERSON.
PATTERSON ICE SANTIAGO.
WEBER.
WEBER II.
THANK YOU MEMBERS THANK YOU. TEN
ZERO THE BILL IS OUT WE WILL
LEAVE IT OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS.
WE'RE WE'RE GONNA GO TO CONSENT.
MOVED BY MISTER LOWE SECOND BY
DOCTOR WEBER -- MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ON THE
CONSENT ITEMS.
MEDINA AYE MEDINA AYE CHOI.
CHOI I ARAMBULA.
BLOOM.
BLOOM I GABRIEL -- WHEN -- WHEN
I KILEY?
KILEY AYE LEVINE.
LEVINE I LOW.
SO I PATTERSON.
PATTERSON I SANTIAGO WEBER
[inaudible]
WEBER I NINE ZERO CONSENT ITEMS
ARE APPROVED WE WILL LEAVE IT
OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS.
AND WE ARE -- WAITING FOR ONE
AUTHOR.
A SENATOR HERTZBERG.
WE DO A CAN WE DO ADD ONS
[inaudible]
YEAH
.
WE'RE WE'RE GONNA GO TO CALLING
ON IN THE ABSENT MEMBERS
[inaudible]
YES.
OKAY CONE FILE ORDER AND ITEM
THREE SB TWO THREE SEVEN EIGHT A
MOTION AND A SECOND.
SO NOW I'M SORRY THAT IS.
SORRY [inaudible]
NEVER AT OKAY.
BY SENATOR EDWARD COME ON
FORWARD PLEASE.
THIS SHOULD FILE ITEM THREE SB.
TWO THIRTY SEVEN THANK YOU --
MEMBERS APOLOGIZE I'M LATE. ONE
OF THOSE DAYS [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
BUT IT'S A LINK OF THE STEM IS
IMPORTANT STEM GLORIA THAT'S
WHAT WE'RE DOING WE CHANGE THE
BILL -- TO HI TO TO MOVE IT FROM
THE PRESS OFFICE OF THE
PRESIDENT -- TO THE CALIFORNIA
COUNCIL ON SCIENCE AND
TECHNOLOGY WE ALL THINK IT'S
FAIR TO SAY WERE PRETTY --
UNDERSTANDING OF HOW IMPORTANT
STEM IS IN CALIFORNIA AND IT
WITH THE FUTURE IS AND WHAT
TECHNOLOGY REQUIREMENTS ARE.
AS YOU'RE ABOUT.
SO WE AT WE TAKE THAT AS YOUR
CLOTHES THAT'S MY CLOSE BUT WE
HAVE -- WITH THIS IS IN SUPPORT.
AARON RODRIGUEZ TO THE UNION OF
CONCERNED SCIENTISTS IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
I LIKE THIS COMMITTEE CHAIRMAN
IMAGERY WITH TECHNO IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
ALEX TOURISM HAVE CODE DARK
TECHO MISTER IT'S BURKE IS
IMPORTANT THANK YOU SO MUCH.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
ANY TWO WINNERS.
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE.
SEEING NONE.
I I WOULD JUST ADD THAT
STEPHENSON POINT IMPORTANT --
ABOUT THE A FOR ARTS IN THEIR
JUST SOMETHING TO THINK ABOUT.
THANK YOU I APPRECIATE THAT OKAY
I THOUGHT I'D THROW THAT OPINION
BUT I'M OKAY I THROW THAT IN
YEAH.
ALL RIGHT.
ARTS ARE ALSO IMPORTANT SO WE
HAD A MOTION BY MISTER BLOOM
SECOND BY MISTER LOW.
A MAN SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL [inaudible]
THE MOST.
THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO THE
ACCOUNTABILITY AND
ADMINISTRATIVE REVIEW COMMITTEE.
MEDINA AYE MEDINA AYE CHOI.
CHOI I ARAMBULA ARAMBULA I BLOOM.
BLOOM I GABRIEL -- WHEN -- WHEN
I KILEY?
KILEY I LEVINE.
LEVINE I LOW.
LOW I PATTERSON.
PATTERSON AYE SANTIAGO WEBER
[inaudible]
WEBER I THANK YOU SENATOR. TEN
ZERO THE BILL IS OUT WE WILL
LEAVE IT OPEN FOR ANY ABSENT
MEMBERS.
OKAY WE'RE GOING FILE ORDER
[inaudible]
ITEM [inaudible]
ONE SB [inaudible]
THREE GABRIEL [inaudible]
SANTIAGO [inaudible] TEN ZERO SB
THREE IS OUT.
ITEM TWO SB [inaudible]
TWENTY FOUR GABRIEL [inaudible]
SANTIAGO [inaudible] SEVEN THREE
SB THREE IS OUT [inaudible]
ITEM.
THREE SB TWO THREE SEVEN GABRIEL
SANTIAGO [inaudible] TEN ZERO SB
TWO THIRTY SEVEN IS OUT.
ITEM FOUR SB TWO NINE SEVEN I
NEED A MOTION AND A SECOND
[inaudible]
MEDINA I MEDINA I CHOI.
CHOI I ARAMBULA.
ARAMBULA I BLOOM.
BLOOM AYE GABRIEL.
IRWIN -- WHEN I KILEY?
KILEY I LEVINE.
LEVINE I LOW.
LOW I PATTERSON.
PATTERSON I SANTIAGO WEBER
[inaudible]
WEBER I TEN ZERO SB TWO NINETY
SEVEN IS OUT.
ITEM SIX SB [inaudible]
FOUR TO SIX BLOOM.
BLOOM I KILEY.
KILEY I LEVINE.
LEVINE I PATTERSON.
PATTERSON I SANTIAGO. TEN ZERO
SB FOUR TWENTY SIX IS OUT.
ITEM EIGHT SB [inaudible]
FOUR EIGHT FOUR GABRIEL SANTIAGO.
TEN ZERO SB FOUR EIGHTY FOUR IS
OUT.
ITEM NINE SB FOUR NINE THREE I
NEED A MOTION AND A SECOND.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE.
MEDINA AYE MEDINA AYE CHOI.
CHOI A NO ARAMBULA.
ARAMBULA I BLOOM.
BLOOM I GABRIEL [inaudible]
IRWIN -- WHEN I KILEY?
KILEY NO LEVINE LEVINE I LOW.
LOW I PATTERSON.
PATTERSON NO SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO I WEBER [inaudible]
WEBER I'D. EIGHT THREE SB FOUR
NINETY THREE IS OUT.
ITEM TEN SB. FIVE FIVE FOUR
GABRIEL [inaudible]
SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO II. ELEVEN EXCUSE ME
ELEVEN ZERO SB FIVE FIFTY FOUR
IS OUT.
ITEM ELEVEN SB FIVE SIX EIGHT
GABRIEL [inaudible]
SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO I'D.
THE MOTION ON SB FIVE SIX EIGHT
IS DO PASSED TO THE TO THE FLOOR.
ELEVEN ZERO SB FIVE SIXTY EIGHT
IS OUT.
ITEM TWELVE SB [inaudible]
FIVE SEVEN FIVE LEVINE.
LEVINE I PATTERSON.
PATTERSON NOT VOTING.
SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO HI. ELEVEN ZERO SB FIVE
SEVENTY FIVE IS OUT.
ITEM THIRTEEN SB.
SIX SIX ZERO MEDINA AYE MEDINA
AYE [inaudible]
LEVINE.
LEVINE I SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO I WEBER [inaudible]
WEBER HI.
AT ELEVEN ZERO SB SIX SIXTY IS
OUT.
ITEM FOURTEEN SB [inaudible]
SEVEN ONE SIX GABRIEL.
GABRIEL I SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO I'D I WAS ITEM AND
FOURTEEN SEVEN ONE SIX TWELVE
ZERO SB SEVEN ONE SIX IS OUT.
AND THE CONSENT CALENDAR
[inaudible]
ARAMBULA.
ARAMBULA I GABRIEL.
THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
GABRIEL I SANTIAGO [inaudible]
SANTIAGO II. TWELVE ZERO THE
CONSENT CALENDAR IS OUT
.
ITEM ONE SB.
THREE GABRIEL.
GABRIEL ICE SANTIAGO
[inaudible]
SANTIAGO I TWELVE ZERO SB THREE
IS OUT.
ITEM TWO SB TWENTY FOUR GABRIEL.
GABRIEL I SANTIAGO [inaudible]
SANTIAGO II. NINE THREE SB
TWENTY FOUR IS OUT.
ITEM THREE SB TWO THREE SEVEN
GABRIEL [inaudible]
CORRECT.
GABRIEL I SANTIAGO SANTIAGO HI.
WELL ZERO FOUR SB [inaudible]
TWO NINE SEVEN GABRIEL.
GABRIEL EYES SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO HI. TWELVE ZERO SB TWO
NINETY SEVEN IS OUT.
ITEM SIX SB [inaudible]
FOUR TO SIX SANTIAGO
[inaudible]
SANTIAGO I ELEVEN ZERO SB FOUR
TWENTY SIX IS A ITEM EIGHT SB.
FOUR EIGHT FOUR GABRIEL.
GABRIEL I SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO I TWELVE ZERO SB FOUR
EIGHTY FOUR IS OUT.
ITEM NINE SB [inaudible]
FOUR NINE THREE GABRIEL
[inaudible]
GABRIEL I NINE THREE SB FOUR
NINETY THREE IS A ITEM TEN SB
FIVE FIVE FOUR GABRIEL
[inaudible]
GABRIEL I TWELVE ZERO SB FIVE
FIFTY FOUR IS OUT.
ITEM ELEVEN SB FIVE SIX EIGHT
GABRIEL.
GABRIEL I SANTIAGO [inaudible]
SANTIAGO I TWELVE ZERO SB FIVE
SIXTY EIGHT IS OUT.
ITEM TWELVE SB [inaudible]
FIVE SEVEN FIVE THE ELEVEN ZERO
SB FIVE SEVENTY FIVE IS OUT
[inaudible] ELEVEN ZERO SB SIX
SIXTY IS OUT [inaudible]
AND TWELVE ZERO SB SEVEN ONE SIX
IS UP.
SB -- FOUR NINE THREE FIVE FIVE
FOUR FIVE FIVE FOUR HAVE YOU
[inaudible]
HI.
IT WAS THE OTHER -- ONE FOUR
EIGHT FOUR WE HAVE USERNAME.
I THANK YEAH.
THAT IS A GOOD [inaudible]
THE JURY